A design system is a set of standards, reusable
components and patterns used to create visual
consistency throughout pages and projects.
Figma is a vector graphics editor and prototyping
tool in this course, Tim Sullivan will teach
you how to create a design system using Figma.
What is going on you guys Tutorial Tim here.
And today, I'm gonna give you a brief overview
of what we're going to be covering in this
series to come, I'm going to be creating a
design system.
And this design system is going to be materials
design system in figma.
And I'm going to do my best to translate what
is currently being displayed on this website
into figma itself as a design system.
So we'll be going over First, the foundation.
And the foundation entails things such as
the layout, and what is layout, like a response
to creating these responsive grid layouts
of styles and figma.
Understanding how to build these out using
proper space spacing methods, and how components
will be laid out on them.
So we'll be going over that.
And we'll also be going over how to apply
a color system utilizing material designs
color system and implementing that into figma,
as well as style color styles.
And also, we're going to be going over typography
and building out the typography system that
is specified here in material design.
But in figma, how do we do that and translate
this into figma.
Also, we'll be going over iconography.
And with iconography in figma, we're going
to be basically applying the structure for
the letter specified in the product icons.
I'll have this set of icons already in figma
when we go over, but I'm gonna show you how
to organize it and access it via the instance
drop down menu.
So you can swap amongst common components
and other component icons, which are components
as well.
And also, we're going to be going over a portion
of interaction, which is states states being
states for certain components.
So in that portion of building design system,
we'll go over foundation.
And then moving on from that, we'll go to
components.
And we'll literally build every single component
on this page from scratch and utilizing the
foundation that we've created in figma.
So we'll start with the app bars, app bar
bars, bottom at bars top all the way down
to the very last component being tooltips.
And we'll go over how to, like construct it
via its anatomy, right.
So we have all this information, how to use
it the placement and behavior.
And basically, I'll teach you how to basically
view this file and build it out in figma,
from scratch and apply the proper constraints.
So it's responsive, just in case designers
need to modify it.
And that is basically going to be the design
system that we'll be building in figma, which
is material design.
And that's the brief overview.
I'm gonna start off with a color system is
Yeah, so it's gonna kind of start off with
referencing the website to give you guys an
understanding what we're going to be building
out in in figma.
And what we're going to be doing in figma,
is basically translating, I'm going to give
you a brief overview right now what we're
going to be doing throughout the whole course
of the video, to give you a general understanding.
So we're gonna start with the color system,
implementing colors, and then adding that
into figma as a library, so you can see them
here.
For those of you who have, for those of you
who are able to utilize libraries, you can
see this color palette here.
And all the styles that have been created
in that library.
So with my material design, system colors
file and rename that real quick material design.
And we got materials on here.
And now, if I go here, we're going to be able
to add it to this library that will publish
eventually, with all these colors, but this
current files already published.
But what I'm going to do is delete all these
real quick.
All right, so we have these colors, we have
color styles, but we haven't added into the
library, I'm gonna show you how to do that.
But I'm gonna show you how to do that by developing
the developing book creating this color system,
we're gonna use the baseline material color
theme, to showcase how to build out these
colors as styles and figma for your whole
team to utilize in figma.
If you're working for an organization, for
example, or just a team, it's a much more
effective way of working.
So basically, what I'm going to do is screenshot
this to have all these values, so I don't
want to go back and forth between browsers.
And once I have that done, I'm just going
to remove everything here.
Don't need that.
And I'm going to start this is like a brand
spanking new file so you guys can follow.
Follow me from scratch.
I already have one page and I'm actually gonna
label this primitives because This, this component
is a primitive component.
So the way we're going to structure all these
components, in terms of its complexity is
from like its very simplest form, that being
labeled as a primitive, all the way to components,
and then patterns, which are composed of several
components.
And we'll get more into that later.
But let's just get started with the colors.
So now I have the screenshot pasted here.
And what I'm going to do is basically translate
all these colors into styles.
So without any further ado, I'm just going
to create some rectangles.
And actually, I'm going to hit Ctrl, C, to
copy this value here.
Notice that when I use Ctrl, C, the hex value
isn't what's indicated in the screenshot that
I've selected to copy the value and apply
to the rectangle.
So I'll have to manually input and put that
value that's indicated there.
And I'm just going to keep doing this until
I have completed all of the color values.
And I'll see you when that is done.
Right, so I've now completed creating all
these color blocks for you in figma, just
to kind of visually show you and apply the
correct color rows, because actually, what
I wanted to originally do was use a control
picker and apply these values, but it doesn't
actually reproduce the exact hex values specified
in the image, because of the screenshot that
I grabbed.
And anyways, long story short, let's make
these color styles now.
So now we're going to add the this into our
color system.
Currently, we don't have anything in our color
system.
So basically, what, what you can do is, we
already have the naming convention set for
our color styles.
So we can go to our color and select style,
add new style, and it will basically grab
the hex value of the rectangle we selected,
and then we can label it as primary.
And when we click Create style, it'll create
that style.
And when you hover over it, a tooltip will
appear below it.
And it will state the name of the style that
you're trying to look for.
And also, if you want to add labeling on let's
say, if we create a like primary variant,
whoops, and we select this little, these little
four icons, and then click Add style.
And then we do primary slash variant, this
will actually add labeling.
So we'll go and it'll, you'll start to see
that with with us utilizing the slash in the
name of your color style, that slash actually
creates this label for you to really easily
parse information in your color styles, which
is very good for, like ease of use, as opposed
to just like generating all of these colors.
And then just having them side by side and
hovering, to access the name of the color
you're looking for exactly.
And at least divide them into sections to
get you one step closer to finding the color
you need.
And I'm gonna unlink that, because it's not
exactly how I want to approach it.
I'm actually going to go here, and if you
if you'll notice, too, and your color styles,
if you haven't published them, there'll be
under local styles.
And then you can access your library by going
to, if you hit Command Shift, question mark,
you can type in library, and then it'll switch
you to Team library.
There's also a shortcut key, option three,
that'll take you there and also a shortcut
key option command o to access the libraries.
And you'll notice that I have 19 unpublished
changes to publish.
And I can publish those, but we'll publish
that once we have completed this.
And I'm going to continue to create the rest
of the colors as I go and label them accordingly.
Secondary, create style.
And then I'm going to create this as a primary
variant.
Create style.
And one thing you can do as well in the color
styles is you can actually drag and drop to
reorder the styles.
So I'm going to actually right click on this
one and delete style.
And one thing you can do with color styles
as well is you can go in edit and add description
and say this secondary color is used for x
component, x meaning the name of the component
or the or like also on surfaces for x component
as an example.
And then once you're once you've completed
that you can hit back and it'll save your
changes.
And then you can go back into the components
like that style and you notice those changes
are now there.
Which is another nice thing about colors to
get an understanding of usages behind them
when using them across like, say you're designing
for a product, for example, I'm going to pause
this video and generate the rest of these
colors.
And I'll see you in a bit.
So now I got everything done.
You can see my color styles has local styles.
So I got the baseline of the material theme
in its colors, right, and I got them all labeled
here.
From the screenshot, I snapped from the website.
And I basically just translated that into
figma.
And then I applied those styles all the way
from primary to the on error surface, a lot
of them are very similar.
But one thing I do not like about this approach
that I'll show you.
And the next approach of applying color styles
with a consistent naming convention that clearly
labels everything, when you try and access
it via the drop down menu is that this isn't
very clear what I'm trying to change the color,
right, I just have to hover to find the values.
And a description will appear for for components
that do have a description there, which is
why that tooltip was rather large for that
color style in this instance, just to provide
some context behind that.
And anyways, this is just isn't clear enough
for me to add color styles.
So what I'm going to do is in material design
2014 established right down here in 2014,
their color palette, and it's just comprised
of colors to work together harmoniously.
And basically, this is where I'm going to
use like a consistent naming convention and
structure based off of the, the colors given
here with, with what I like to call the variables
and their hex values, which I'll then apply
in figma.
And I'm gonna show you how to do that with
the top three.
So I'm gonna go back to figma.
And I'm going to show you before, I'm going
to show you, I'm going to remove all this,
because I don't want this anymore, I am going
to actually just leave it.
And so you can see the difference between
how to navigate colors with a consistent naming
convention, utilizing the slash when naming
these colors and the styles when creating
them of styles.
And anyways, I'm going to go here, grab my
rectangle.
And I'm literally just gonna actually copy
this block here on background label at Red,
red, red 50 to kind of mimic the layout that
we have here.
And then I'm gonna hit Command D to duplicate
and then option D to snap that to the right,
and then type in this hex value.
And this whole process you're seeing from
me is, I'm going to do it once and then I'm
going to pause the video and do it for the
rest.
And then I'll show you how to properly label
everything as a color style in figma.
And, and then I'll be back.
Alright, so I have now replicated this screenshot
I've taken from the website with the color
palette holds a portion of the color palette
that material design has to offer either utilize.
And I've just done the red, pink and purple.
So now what I'm going to do is start to show
you the difference and how helpful it can
be by doing applying this consistent naming
convention to all the color styles we're about
to create for red, pink and purple, which
you can apply to your system.
So I'm going to start with red, we got this
red 50 value, so we got red 50, we already
have the hex value, it's gonna click add color
style, I'm gonna label it read because we're
gonna have a section of rats, ranging from
values of one through 900, from light to dark,
and then also a 100 to a 700.
Not exactly sure what those values represent.
But uh, you get where we're going with this.
And I'm going to do red 100, and then specify
the hex value as well.
And the color style, which is always helpful,
so you don't have to actually go in and manually
apply the style and then unlink it to view
the hex value, which I find quite annoying.
So we got this format, I'm gonna click Create
style, hit enter.
Now we got red one.
So on hover, we'll see red 100 and then the
hex value.
And then if you click away, you also see the
way we named it is red slash 100 dash, the
hex value, which is nice and easy to parse.
And again, this is up to you and your team
to decide on how you label this in terms of
like doing this for an organization for teams
to utilize.
Now I'm going to go in and create the rest
of these Use for, for red.
It's the same process.
So we got, what do we got, we created red
100 was actually supposed to be labeled red
50 actually wrote the wrong hex value as well.
So I'm just gonna edit that.
And it's red 50 good to go hit enter tab,
go back.
Now we see that it's refined and reflects
the actual value.
Okay going to do on a couple more, so you
get the idea of how to name your color styles.
Now, I'm going to pause it and finish reds
and then do a couple of pink and then do a
couple of purple to see how effective utilizing
the slash and your color styles can parse
the information when trying to access the
colors to apply to your components moving
forward, when we continue to implement more
of this system as it becomes more dense.
So we got red 100 here, gonna add color style.
Red 100, good to go create color styles.
And we got two that fall under the red category,
because we're utilizing red space slash keeping
the naming convention consistent.
So I'm just gonna copy this hex value, Command
click on my rectangle with the color that
I want to be a style.
And then I'm going to paste red 100.
But change that to 200 and then reapply the
hex value for red 200 and create that style.
So now I'm going to move on to creating another
category which is pink.
We got I'm going to copy this again, Command
click and add color style.
And I'm going to go with pink space slash
space 50 and then dash and then the hex value.
Create that style.
And you'll notice in the color styles now,
we have our new our own pink section to reflect
what we'd like to mimic visually, but in our
color styles, which will be accessible to
everyone once you publish this, because currently
these are local styles.
As you can see, when you click somewhere random
on the canvas, the blank canvas, you'll see
the color styles here.
But they sitting there only local but we'll
push them once we're done completing this
stew.
I'm going to do purple now, because I'm pretty
sure by this time you guys already know how
to do this.
As I've done it multiple times, I'm going
to copy this hex value, select the background,
add the color style, and I'm going to go purple
space slash add the hex value there and then
type in fifth 50 did that.
Okay, enter.
Now we have our sections of red, pink and
purple.
The other sections we haven't implemented
from the material design website, which I
will do on my own are, are the following.
As you can see, I scrolled through a lot of
them, it will take a lot of time, but is the
same exact process.
But I will pause this video and complete that
and show you and then we'll publish it once
I'm done.
And that'll be the end of the video bareback.
All right, all right.
All right, I finished creating the rest of
the color styles using the method I specified
for pausing this video.
And you can kind of see how dense this, the
styles became.
So each one of these is now a color style
organized here from red, pink, and purple.
And there's plenty more to go, I will have
all of them created for you to reference as
well, in that, by that I mean all of these,
which are screenshots that will convert into
this figma file.
Take a little bit of time, but uh, it's not
an issue.
So now, the final step is publishing this.
So what do we what? How do we do this? Well,
there's a few ways I'll show you, we can select
assets, we can click on this library icon
and this little, that little blue icon right
there in the top right corner indicates that
there are publishers to be made changes, that
publishers to be made or whatever, you can
select it and you can see that you can publish
69 changes, the 69 changes being all the color
styles that we have applied to this library.
One thing I want to show you is the the differentiation
between the way we labeled these colors in
the beginning and then the way we labeled
these three sections in a much more organized
and clear concise manner.
So if we go here, create a rectangle and apply
a color style to it.
We just like this little icon here and you'll
see that the we have these colors right The
only way you can really tell what they are
labeled as is if we hover over a mother wait
to see that tooltip pop up as well.
And what we did with the colors that we use
the slash to indicate what the label was,
to the left of the slash being the Read, and
then the value being applied to the style,
which is read 50.
And then also on hover, being able to view
the hex value as well.
And we did that and split up red, pink and
purple in a much more clear and concise manner
for the user to navigate and use.
And again, this is still somewhat troublesome
because of how dense this color palette is.
But this is the best solution I think figma
has created for this and myself.
If there's any other better ways to do this,
please let me know in the comment section
below.
I hope you guys found this video extremely
helpful.
Thank you for your time, please leave a like,
comment, and subscribe and follow me on GitHub.
If not, I'll catch you in the next one.
What is going on you guys, I almost forgot,
we still got to publish the library.
So I showed you multiple ways of how to publish
it and use Go to View switch to Team library
or you can select this icon in the assets
panel.
And another way is my favorites.
My shortcut key is option command zero.
And then you can select Publish changes.
And then you can view every style that was
either modified.
So in this case, there's a bunch of removed
ones, you know, colors that weren't very explicit.
And then the colors we added, of course, and
I'm gonna hit and then you can also add a
description as to what you added.
So I'm just going to be it's like a kind of
like a message like a git commit message in
a way, which will display in the version control
history, once you publish this.
So I'm adding colors, adding a portion of
color into the curial.
Sign, color system to library.
And then you have a message, kind of explaining
what you did, and then publish.
And then it'll add this to your library, a
little snack bar indicating the the process
successfully updated.
And then you can view your assets.
And the nice thing about it is you can view
now if you go to material design, you can
view all your colors here.
And on hover, you can view everything.
It's not as nice laid out as the colors panel
here.
But yeah, that's how you publish the colors
to your library.
That is the final step.
Today I'm going to show you how to create
a type system figma specifically material
designs type system, link will be in description
to reference the type system material has
created.
And basically just going to give you a general
idea of how to really develop a type system
that is utilize for your content, specifically
your components and the patterns we'll be
creating here in figma.
I also recommend messing around with this
type, this type school generator, they have
this nice little interactive element to the
web page that allows you to really see the
type skill and different fonts specific maybe
more than likely a font family you're using,
you could see what that looks like at scale.
And if it's a great resource, figured I'd
share it.
And again, I recommend going through all this.
So basically, we're going to be going over
creating this from scratch and developing
them into type textiles in figma that are
easily reasonable crasher design system and
the one we'll be building.
So let's get started.
So I got figma open here, and you can also
access this exercise file if you don't want
to do it and just want to grab the values,
I'll have that figma file, a link in description.
So we got our our examples of the properties
summed up here for all of our headers or subtitles,
body and content, such as button caption over
line, and we're basically just going to be
applying all of these properties to our textile.
So without any further ado, let's get started.
Alright, so now that we got this, I'm gonna
open up my type tool here, and I'm just gonna
select type in h1.
I'm gonna set this to auto width because I
don't like any unnecessary out of line space
other than what's specified for the type.
And I'm just going to set this size to 96,
which it already is, the line height is set
to auto, but the letter spacing we're going
to modify to negative 1.5 as specified.
When I make sure I select that here, select
my type, and then type in negative 1.5.
Hit enter it tightened here, the kerning and
or our letter spacing better word for it,
as indicated here.
But anyways, I'm going to continue to build
these type styles here.
I'm going to type in h2, select my typography,
ensure that I got the letter spacing right
so I don't forget and set that to negative
0.5.
Hit Enter And, again, if you are confused
with anything and want to understand the properties
more, you can click on this icon here with
your text selected, the more icon and view
all the properties that this typeface has
to offer.
And one important thing to note that is if
you're using a different typeface, but creating
this type system, there are features and specific
fonts that are offered and aren't offered.
So if you are seeing some features here, that
aren't offered in a separate font you're using
in in context of this video, it's probably
because it doesn't offer the functionality.
So just note that I also recommend kind of
reading through all this is very great information.
But that is for another video, if you'd like
me to make it, leave a comment in the comment
section below.
And anyways, we got our letter spacing specified,
we need to change the sizing here.
And the weight is good.
And so the line height, and you can kind of
start to see this process, very straightforward.
And you repeat that, moving forward.
The only intricate details I'd say, before
I zip through this is the button property.
So if I go ahead and type in all lowercase,
I can actually apply the all caps sentence
casing in the text properties, which is fantastic.
I'm going to do that by selecting the uppercase
property.
And there are other properties such as lowercase
title case, small caps, and for small caps.
And I just want to note that, because I think
that is very important for these textiles,
to really optimize them.
So we're gonna go to letter spacing, and implement
add in 1.25, we've got the letter spacing
set.
Now we're just gonna change the size and weight
set to medium.
And now we have our all caps in the button,
we don't even have to hold down Shift, which
is fantastic.
And one other minute change here.
For this textiles, we're going to of course,
change the size and weight.
But most of all, we go to the text properties
we're gonna change the case to for small caps
to be in line with the case here, just because
the font size is so small set to 10.
And other than that you guys can go ahead
and make the rest of these also will have
this file and the description below.
So I'll be right back with all these textiles.
Alright, so now I know I've got all the textiles
created with a proper properties.
I hope you did that exercise too.
And anyways, now we're gonna go about organizing
our styles and then publishing them, and that'll
be the rest of the video.
So we're gonna be utilizing the way figma
structures accessing textiles, there's a really
nice way to like, thoroughly separate all
the header content from the subtitles from
the body as well as the textiles for other
types of content, such as buttons, and captions
and over lines.
So I'm just going to go here, select my textile,
click on this icon, click the plus button
to create a style.
And I'm going to type in headers slash.
And with the slash naming convention, it's
actually going to allow me to separate out
my textiles by category.
So we're going to have our headers and subtitles
and body and separate as well as the content
such as buttons, caption or lines.
So I'm going to specify this h1 here.
And then it's going to add this little dot
here to separate it.
So I got my h1.
And you can also specify the weight of the
font, which is this h1 is a light h1 in case
you have variants of h1 later on down the
road for specific reasons.
And one thing we can also specify is the size
here are sizes 96.
And I like to what that you can do is use
this divider and specify the line height in
relation to the size of your font, which is
also very important.
But I have all of these set to auto here in
figma.
But for example, you could write auto or specify
the line height.
And again, when you create that style, it
will now appear under headers whenever you're
trying to apply a style.
Say I want to apply style now.
It's under this category name headers.
And once this is more fleshed out, it'll be
much easier to see the organization of a The
content.
So I'm going to go ahead here and create the
same exact thing for my headers, the rest
of my headers again using the slash convention,
specifying that it's an h2.
And it uses the weight light.
And the font size is 60.
And the line height is set to auto.
And again, for your systems are probably going
to be more specific the line height, but in
this example, I'm not going to get to the
gritty in that regard.
So create that style, you notice that it updates
here, we're gonna populate that again, got
that h3, specify the weight again, and specify
the size.
And of course, the line height.
So you can see continues to populate.
And now I'm going to go ahead and finish the
rest of this.
I'll create one subtitle to so you can see
the differentiation of categorization between
two different categories, which will be our
headers and subtitles.
So I'm gonna go get here, add the style, label,
subtitle, subtitle and one, specify the weight,
just regular.
And then of course, the size of that font.
And I don't know, off the top of my head,
but I will leave it set to six subtitle set
to 16, which it is, and the line height set
auto.
So here you can see now that your textiles
are organized.
Here, clearly, and I'm gonna go ahead and
finish the rest of this.
And I'll be right back.
All right, so now we got all our content set
up and organized.
So you can see that I've now spliced these
into what does that 344 categories, we got
the headers with the subtitles, and we've
got the body and the content.
And one textile I'm actually missing is this
subtitle, what's going on here, let me just
above this real quick.
We've got subtitle, subtitle, subtitle wanted
to, oh, there we go.
I'm just going to organize that real quick.
There we go.
So in the order in which you create your textiles
is how it will appear in the hierarchy.
So you may have to organize that.
And now when we go ahead and create a textile,
I mean create, when we need to apply a textile,
we can go here, look at our textiles.
And now they're beautifully organized in a
clear, concise manner.
And not only are they organized, each textiles
named in such a way that it it's easy to specify
the size, and the line height as well.
And again, I just have that set auto.
Um, you could also make that the letter spacing
here if you wanted to depends on how technical
you really need to be.
And that's how you do that.
And now our last step is publishing this to
our library.
So now I got 26 changes to publish here.
And for those who do not know how to use this,
this is basically like a git commit.
For those of you who are developers ignore
all of these removed textiles, these are old.
And at here, you'll be able to see all the
changes that you've created, which are all
the textiles you've added.
And we can write a description.
adding text styles to design system.
This is very vague, but give you a general
idea how to do that.
And again, you can view all the changes made,
and everything that is unchanged here below.
And then and you can publish.
And the nice thing about leaving comments
is that it leaves a trail to track any history.
So if we go to show version history here,
by clicking this carrot, click Show version
history, we can see that we just published
our textiles and we left that message.
So we can actually go to that point in time
by clicking on it.
And it will take us there.
Or we could go even further back to a point
in time where these weren't even created.
So if I click on 6:47pm, it's going to load
and I'm viewing the time this autosave at
6:47pm.
And you can see that there are no textiles
here.
And you can't edit this version.
But say you needed to, you could duplicate
this and then go to that duplicate file and
grab what you need and then bring it into
the current version.
And if you hit escape, you can get back to
your current version or you can click the
button edit current version.
And if you're lost, I'd hit two under keyboards
the shortcut key to fit everything, everything
in your canvas to your frame and Now we found
ourselves back here, with all our textiles
here, not local anymore.
Now published.
So now designers can actually access this
in their panel here, we go to, I got mine
set to materials on here with all my colors
published and my textiles.
Today we're talking about elevation and material
design and how it's utilized.
So we'll be doing an overview of elevation,
which will entail elevation depicting, understanding
depicting elevation, the elevation hierarchy,
and the default elevation set for components.
And I have some documentation that I grabbed
off of material designs website, which you
can also access by clicking on this and the
exercise file and clicking open link.
And then you'll then get access to the elevation
page in material design, where it discusses
all of this, and as covered in the contents
here in depth.
And essentially, elevation is the relative
distance between two surfaces along the z
axis.
So what is the z axis? Well, we go ahead and
Google search that.
And for those of you who are beginners to
this and don't understand the z axis, it is
the third access usually representing depth
on a three dimensional grid.
It can be used in charts or graphs, and whatnot,
typically, in a Cartesian coordinate system,
and the z axis is perpendicular to both the
x and y axis, and is used to plot the value
of z, the third and unknown in mathematics,
which is, which is good to know.
And anyways, how this translates in figma
is basically the hierarchy.
And in the in the layers, you can think of
as like the hierarchy in the Layers panel,
say, for example, I have a frame here.
And then I have a couple of shapes.
And I'm going to offset this color here.
And currently, the shapes are being basically
utilize the Z index.
And you notice that because this rectangle,
when I overlap it over the rectangle above
it visually, this gray rectangle, and I add
this red rectangle there, you'll notice that
this red rectangle is higher up on the Z index
in and also you can think of that in the layer
order as well, I can even change that and
drag it below this gray rectangle, meaning
that it's now lower on the Z index the red
rectangle, and you can go ahead and move that
around and understand that that is the Z index
that is representing the layer order here.
And basically, what material design does is
that it has a set of components.
And here you can see a set of default elevation
values for all kinds of components.
And here, we have all of the elevations.
Values that will turn into styles as they
already are in this figma file locally.
And we're gonna go ahead and create a couple
of them from scratch so you understand how
they're built as styles.
And we'll also go ahead and do a brief overview
about how those are made based off of reading
the documentation.
So here, again, elevation is measured in dips.
And in elevation elevation material design
is measuring the distance between surfaces.
As you can see here, they're giving you a
representation of what this z index looks
like, by us utilizing this graph here, this
format to indicate how far a surface is from
one another.
But again, to us, it looks horrible to us
visually it is we're seeing this horse on
this flat surface on the screen.
But if you were to tilt that view sideways,
you could say, this is what that would look
like in the scenario where this example number
two indicates that there's a surface that
is one dip set to one dip elevation, and then
the other surface is set to eight dip elevation,
as viewed from from the side view here.
And the difference between the two surfaces
is seven dips as viewed from the side angle.
And you can represent that with using a drop
shadow.
And that will indicate the elevation and the
distance between these two surfaces.
So here's the one dip here in this rectangle,
and then which is represented from the side
view.
And then here is elevation being expressed
at a higher elevation, using eight dips with
much more visual emphasis on the drop shadow
as you can see, and that's also represented
here from the side.
And there's that distance Express there.
And there's another more complicated example
are both surfaces A and B are at the same
elevation a nBw are set to eight dip elevation,
and they cast different shadows because surface
B is in front of another surface that already
has elevation.
As you can see, the surface c already has
elevation set to four dips.
And then on top of that surface B is set to
eight dips, as you can see as represented
from the side here, whereas the surface a
is just doesn't have anything below it.
And it is set to eight dips of elevation.
So a and b are essentially on the same axis
elevation, it's just that it doesn't have
any other surface below it.
And you can understand the elevation system,
again, is utilized in components and all material
design surfaces and components have elevation
values, and surfaces at different elevations
do different things.
And those things being allowing surfaces to
move in front of and behind other surfaces
such as content scrolling behind app bars,
and reflecting spatial relationships such
as how floating action buttons shadow indicates
it is separate from a card and focusing attention
on the highest elevation.
This is commonly seen in components such as
dialogues, which temporarily appear in front
of other surfaces.
And we're gonna go ahead and look at some
great examples of how these components are
in some motion examples.
But here is a great example of resting elevation,
where the by default, this card component
here has elevation at the by default app set
to one dip.
And then once it is once there's an action
taken upon it, sometimes the elevation can
change.
So it is important to know so for example
with a button, the elevation will change based
upon when you press it.
So here in this example, when it when someone
is pressing on this button, you'll see that
from the side, it goes from two dips to eight
dips based on that action which raises it
to the surface, making this a much more immersive
experience and interactive, also conveying
certain key interactions and progression to
the user as they are communicating with their
product, which is built on top of material
design, for example.
And here you can talk you can see other examples
of elevation here with this card, as it is
being dragged, it goes from one dip elevation
to eight, and is then revisit and then rises
above the previous card as it's above it in
the Z index.
And here's another example of when you would
utilize elevation where these cards are scrolling.
And being on that elevation based system is
allowed to scroll over the surface that it
is currently above that you can see there.
And you can also read other important things,
such as understanding the surface overlaps
on top of other surfaces, and when to use
them, which is really important.
And also when to use a scrim background in
the UI to express that the content above it
is at a higher elevation also to provide more
emphasis on the most primary calls to action
in that moment in time.
And again, more great in depth analysis on
elevation.
And when it when you can use motion elevation
together, as for example, showing changes
in shadow or displaying overlap, or pushing
content around or scaling that content or
using parallax scrolling.
And what we're going to get to now is understanding
elevation hierarchy.
And basically going over the diagram of default
elevation values, which is super important.
And we have that in figma.
Now that we went over all that.
So we have this set of elevation values, which
tells us exactly what components have default
elevation values.
And this will be super important to implement
into our color styles.
So in this figma file I've already created.
I've already created a set of elevation values
and they're already effect styles in in your
figma file, this exercise file.
And again, this is the final result of what
we'll be baking, but I don't just want to
just hand this off to and actually show you
how to create these effects style.
So we'll go ahead and create a few of them
and then and then I'll pause this video and
have you built the rest by yourself.
So first I need to teach you how to actually
evaluate the values within each of these drop
shadows.
So here you can see these are all the elevation
values used in material design.
And again, this one isn't.
This one's at the the surface level, this
doesn't utilize elevation as you can see,
set to 00 dip.
And that then can't be in effect style because
it doesn't use any effects.
That is just the flat the baseline, just think
of 00 as the baseline.
And then, of course, one dip is used for the
search bar cards at a rested elevation state
by default, as well as the search bar at a
rested elevation state.
And also switch components.
And text buttons are set to zero and standard
side sheet components are set to zero as well.
So let's go ahead and make this I'm going
to copy this.
And you'll notice that it is attached to the
style, I'm going to go ahead and detach that.
And you'll notice that these styles are all
drop shadow.
So I'm gonna go ahead and remove all these.
So now this is flat here on the right, and
one thing we can do is we can manually go
in and click on these individual styles, which
is very tedious.
And we can go ahead and do it that way.
So if I click on this value, so for example,
I could screenshot all of these, because I
wouldn't want to go back and forth, clicking
on all these drop shadows, and copying, pasting
these properties.
So I'm going to show you the long way of doing
this.
And then I'm going to show you the fast way,
so you never do that approach again.
So let me just undo that there.
Then I'm going to paste this, here we go.
So I'm going to grab this last drop shadow
style.
And then with that drop shadow style set,
I have all three drop shadows, and I'm going
to recreate the elevation set for 01 dips.
So I'm going to go ahead and click on effects.
Whoops, I'm gonna click the Create effect
style icon I have, by default, it selects
drop shadow, and it'll give you some default
values.
So I'm gonna go ahead and create this one
here.
So I'm going to change the blur to one, and
this and that, I'm going to set the y axis
value to one here.
And then I'm going to keep the spread at zero
and change the opacity to 14%.
And it's using a color of black, which is
000000.
And then now I have that first drop shadow
style created, you can start to see that this
drop shadow is being applied here, but it's
very light in the drop shadow color compared
to this one where it's much more sharp and
darker on the edges of the rectangle.
And I'm gonna go ahead and create that second
drop shadow.
And with that, I'm going to just mimic the
properties in this drop shadow.
And that's set to one on the blur, zero on
the spread, and two on the y axis and an opacity
of 12% going to hit enter, I know that second
property of drop shadows applied, then I'm
going to go ahead and delete these two, so
I don't get confused and create my last effect,
which is another set of drop shadow, I'm gonna
go ahead and apply these values again.
So one on the y axis, three on the blur, zero
spread and 20% opacity.
Once I've created that, you'll notice I now
have an exact replica of the drop shadow.
Here.
The only difference is that this drop shadow
is brand new, it's still the drop shadow from
material design system.
It's just that it's not attached to a style
for learning purposes, specifically, so you
know how to create these drop shadows.
And we can go ahead and turn this into a style.
But before we turn this into a style, let's
go ahead and show you the easy way to do this.
So if we now that we have this style, maybe
we go ahead and duplicate the eight dip based
version of this, and it's still attached to
a, an effect style.
So I'm going to detach that style.
I'm going to duplicate this rectangle.
And I'm going to delete all these drop shadows.
And what I'm gonna do is make sure I have
my rectangle selected, and I'm going to hold
down Option Command C.
And what that allows me to do is copy all
of the styles associated with the object I
selected, which is the rectangle and then
I can paste those over to my new style new
object by clicking on this rectangle and then
hitting option Command V.
And it pastes those exact drop shadow values.
You notice that when I pasted it, it implemented
those new drop shadow values.
And that is much quicker than going in and
implementing the manually like I did, and
referencing screenshots.
So I didn't have to individually click on
each drop shadow property panel and then do
that one by one.
That's very annoying.
So with that being said, let's utilize That
approach now.
So here, we can just copy over, I'm command
clicking on all the command clicking to select
the rectangle specifically, and then holding
Shift Command click on all of these rectangles
here.
And basically what I'm doing is grabbing all
of these, and then I'm going to hold down
Option and drag these over to copy all of
them.
And you'll notice what we have here is all
of these elevation values, or effects, all
of these rectangles are attached to effects
styles.
But we don't want to do that we want to utilize
the method of creating drop shadows quickly
make copies of properties and pasting them.
And to do that, we need to go ahead and unlink
detach all these drop shadow styles.
So here we go, we're going to continue to
detach these styles, I'm just selecting each
one individually, as you can't bulk select
these and detach, unfortunately, for effect
styles.
But you can do that with color styles.
So now that we have that applied, I know that
these are all in sequential order or proper
order.
So it goes from one dip, elevation, 234-689-1216,
and 24.
So all I'm going to do is duplicate this real
quick.
And before I detach all these drop shadow
values, and I'm gonna duplicate that again,
and keep duplicating them on the rectangles
I have not created.
drop shadows for yet.
And you'll notice that they're all very flat,
which would mean that they're using the zero
dip elevation essentially.
And I'm just gonna go ahead and click on these
command options, option C, and then select
the object I want to paste the drop shadow
to and then click Command Option v.
And you'll notice that I am now just essentially
copying and pasting these effects style properties.
So holding down option, Command C, selecting
the new object and then do an option Command
V.
And I'm just grabbing all of these drop shadow
properties and pasting them very quickly.
And this is something you can use for colors
as well.
So if I change the color of this, it would
copy that color value, it still has the drop
shadow, but if I option Command C, and then
select my new object, and then option Command
V, it also copies over that fill value.
So it copies all the properties not just the
effect styles, which are the drop shadows
in our case.
So do take note of that object, Command C,
select menu object object, Command V, and
then do the same thing for the last set of
elevation.
And this is very important to note.
And now that we built all of this out, we
can go ahead and create effect styles out
of these.
And as you can see, we already have them created.
So we can go ahead and mimic a couple.
And I'm going to go ahead and this is our
zero to dip effect style.
So I'm gonna go ahead and click on my style
icon and click add new style.
And then I'm going to type in zero to dip.
And this is our new effect style.
And we now will have two variants of that.
And then it gets created and it's set at the
bottom.
The newest styles are then generated at the
bottom of this list in the effect styles and
the Properties panel, I can even go ahead
and just create another one, you'll notice
that this is now linked to a style.
And these aren't yet because I haven't created
the color styles.
I'm gonna go ahead and click on another one,
and click on the style icon and create new
style.
And this is my 24 dip elevation base value.
So I got 24 dip there, we'll click Create
style, I now have zero to dip and 24 dip created.
But this is solely to showcase you to showcase
to you how to create styles out of these elevation
values because you're going to reuse them
time and time again.
So I'm just gonna actually delete these since
we already have them in our file.
Now that you know how to create effect styles
in figma.
And with that being said, the only thing missing
from these effects styles is documentation.
And basically what I'm referencing is that
in these effects styles, we can go ahead and
label where this elevation would apply.
So I'm going to click on 24 dip and since
we have the table of default elevation values,
it tells me where what components use that
set of elevation.
So I can go ahead and click on this edit style
icon and add a description.
You and I can type in use for dialogue components
and I'm going to hit tab and it'll save that
change, I'm going to hit back, I'm going to
go ahead and select my 16 dip, the fix style,
click Edit style.
And I'm going to continue to add the description.
And currently met navigation drawer components
and modal bottom sheet.
And modal side sheet components use this default
elevation value.
So I'm going to actually go ahead and input
that used for these components and have been
the navigation drawer.
And modal bottom sheet and modal side sheet.
And now that I have that input, it will save
that and you can even go back into your, your
style and edit it and check to see if it saved
the description.
I'm going to going to continue to input the
description so that way when you publish this
and other designers start to use these styles,
they can go ahead and and click on this scription
understand where you would actually apply
this elevation style, which is great, useful
tool to communicate to your designer, especially
when you don't designers don't remember where
these styles are being utilized.
And here you can see that a lot of components
use the default elevation value of eight dips.
And I'm going to go ahead and pause this video
and I want you to go ahead and for the rest
of these for the eight dips 64321 dip melt
effects styles, I want you to go ahead and
reference this table here and input that into
the description like we just did for for the
following effects styles.
I'm going to pause this video and I'll catch
you when this is done.
So now I have completed inputting all the
descriptions for the rest of the elevation
values.
As you can see here, it's a direct reflection
of what is labeled in the table of default
elevation values and material design.
And again, I got these screenshots off of
the material design elevation page, which
is also a link here and exercise file if you
want to double check things, and also soak
in more information on on elevation itself.
Because this is not only applicable to material
designs design system, but great principles
for you to utilize as a foundation for implementing
new systems.
So that is also something important to take
into consideration.
And here again, if I go to the editing the
styles, I'm just double checking all my descriptions
here.
And everything is good to go.
Today, we're going to be talking about product
and system icons and talking about why they're
different.
And the distinctions between them.
And we'll go over also the principles around
how icons are made in material design, just
we're going to briefly go over that.
And then we're also going to be using a tool
that you'll use throughout the course where
if I go ahead and select on this link here
in our exercise file Material Design icons,
I can go ahead and click that checkbox and
click on the link.
And you'll notice that we have this resource
for actually accessing these icons.
So for in this exercise file, I've went ahead
and imported some but not all of the system
icons in material design.
And I did that on purpose, because I want
you to be able to do this yourself.
And not only do this yourself, but understand
how to utilize two ways of doing so.
So in your exercise files, you'll have a zip
folder called Material Design icons.
And in this folder, there is a set of icons
for Android, for developing for Android.
So if you're designing for Android, you have
these icons here available in their proper
format, as you can see in the dot XML file
format.
And also, we have the font base version of
these icons.
And then we have the iOS based versions.
And then we also have them exported as PNGs
at all sizes, all different sizes and from
18 dips, 2436 and 48 dips at 1x and 2x respective
to each size, as you can see there.
And this is very helpful.
But also this is a lot of material in this
file.
So if that seems to be too much for you, you
can actually go ahead and use this resource
here.
Again, this resource can be accessed by clicking
on this material design icons link in figma.
And opening that and it'll give you access
to this amazing resource that we'll both be
using as we build out components in this course
just in case we've missed some icons here
in figma.
From my initial export as you can see, I have
these icons categorized visually.
And not only that in the Layers panel they
are as they're exported.
These are the The names of each icon, which
is great, so we don't have to go ahead and
label those ourselves.
But we can also tweak the naming later on,
if we'd like to.
Maybe we want to get get rid of those underscores.
And we'll get to that when we actually publish
these components to utilize across our designs.
And here we have a set of 10 categories, user
actions, icon, font icons, icon specific to
devices.
So here, you can see that that this is definitely
heavily used in Android and iOS devices here
indicating the state of batteries, airplane
mode, whether it's on or off, or if you've
set alarms, or if your Bluetooth is enabled,
connected or disabled, and other things of
that nature.
And that is this device category.
And then we have some other categories, such
as some editor icons, which can see commonly
used and other Google products like Google
Docs, like some of these are options, when
you select text and edit them in terms of
alignment here, some alignment icons and whatnot.
Also some hardware icons, content, icons,
file icons, and some other icons such as communication
alert icons.
And again, this is only touching on the surface
of icons, because in this tool, there's an
important functionality.
Under this themes category.
And top left, you'll see that there are different
variants of all these icons.
So there's the filled version.
And there's the outline version there.
And you'll notice that the this filled version,
the is definitely different from the outline
version, you can utilize these two versions
of the same icon to indicate state.
And there's also a rounded version of these
icons where the corners are much more rounded,
as you can see here, compared to the outlined
variant, elements become more rounded, and
smooth, you could say, we also have this two
tone variant, you'll notice that there's this
second tone of color implemented, that is
a sort of light gray, as the background color
on several elements in the interface.
And then we have our sharp variant of icons,
where the corners are most definitely very
much sharp on the edges, and whatnot.
So with those variants in mind, we can also
toggle the categories specific specifically
actions or if I only want alerts to appear,
or only a V icons to appear, or only communication
icons to appear.
So basically have the ability to view all
of these icons individually or view all of
them at once as there are a ton of icons,
I recommend you kind of just skimming through
this understanding what you think you will
and won't use and why not would be a good
test, a meant to your understanding of material
design, and the icons needed when we develop
the component library moving forward.
And again, if we don't have these inner figma
file, don't worry about it.
If it's not here already, we can go ahead
and just create a new category here.
And of course, say I don't have icons in the
from the social category, as there are a lot
of social icons, it's as simple as just clicking
on this icon.
And then in the bottom left hand corner in
your browser, you'll notice that you have
the ability to actually export this icon.
And it tells you what size you would be exporting
it as and what format so this is the SVG based
format of this icon.
And I can also click on that, to open up this,
this panel.
And you can either download the SVG format,
or the PNG based format, we're going to be
sticking to the SVG based formats.
And there's also some instructions on how
to style your icons using CSS, it gives you
a little example here.
And you can also change the size, which you
download this, SVG will be downloading them
in 24 dips.
So and you can also get the black version
of the icon or the white version of the icon,
we're going to stick with the black version
of the icon.
As we'll be designing for light theme in our
content, such as typography, and icons will
be dark as opposed to light.
And you also can download the iOS based version,
the Android version of this.
And again, you have all these icons already
in your your file in your exercise files that
you've downloaded under, you can get them
under source or whatever device you are designing
for you have all of these icons here in all
formats, the outline round sharpen twotone
variants and the filled variant as well.
So with that being said, we can go ahead and
talk about now that we've talked all about
system icons, which is what we just covered,
we just covered all the system icons, again,
which is also in this documentation here which
will be accessible in the figma file as well.
I'll make sure that's in there.
So you can click on this link.
So basically, this symbolizes common actions
for files, devices and directories.
And the whole concept is to be simple, modern,
friendly, and sometimes quirky as each icon
is reduced to its minimal form expressing
essential characteristics for the action you're
trying to take with that design element the
icon is associated with.
And you can see, if you were to create your
own icons as well, it teaches you how to even
create icons with the proper parameters in
regards to the construction of the file, utilizing
the specifications of the grid and key line
shapes here, and how to use them on dense
layouts are, and just the layout of the icon
itself, which is really interesting.
And also just other specs as well in regards
to breaking down what an icon consists of,
and discussing color as well, and the states
for an icon.
And we have these icons, states on light backgrounds
specified here, which is great, and we can
incorporate that into our system moving forward.
And it talks about the variance as well.
The icon themes, which we had went over in
the tool here, the themes being filled, outlined,
rounded to tone and sharp.
And that is all discussed here in system icons.
And we have now we can also play with them
in figma.
If you'd like go ahead and click on them,
copy, paste them, throw them into components.
But we'll do that with much more attention
moving forward when we start building out
our component library.
And I recommend you going through this and
reading it taking notes as this will definitely
inform you on how to utilize icons in a systematic
way.
And also just up your game as a designer.
So with that being said, we can go ahead and
discuss product icons now.
So product icons are separate from system
icons.
Because these are this is the visual expression
of a brand's product and the services and
tools that they offer.
So for example, in Google Chrome, if you have
a Google account or Gmail account, you'll
notice that these are product icons, these
aren't system icons, like like, like in this
browser.
These are system icons, which are crafted
for common actions and items on an interface.
Whereas these product icons here represent
the product itself, the service or the tool.
So that is something important to to note
or to apply distinction to.
Because if we go back and talk about the product
icons, it talks about how it expresses that
product and how its associated to the company
it's made by so here you can see that being
spoken up here, where the icons in this regard
Gmail, Google Calendar, and and a couple other
icons communicate the core idea and intent
of a product and they simple, bold and friendly
way, while each icon is still distinct.
And all product icons for a brand should be
unified through those concepts and and in
its execution.
And here you can see the approach where they
actually view their design as material being
a physical quality, such as paper, where,
where each piece was cut, folded, and lit.
And that utilizes light as well in association
to the icon and represented in this digital
format, to really bring out those surfaces
to interact with light.
And you can see the subtle highlights here
and the consistent shadowing applied in these
product icons.
So if we go ahead and go back to Google's
suite of product icons here, you can see that
in the Gmail icon, and you can see the the
shadows being applied here on these edges,
and lighting really being implemented, executed
consistently in all product icons.
And you can get specifications on how these
icons are built and whatnot.
But this isn't super specific to what we'll
be doing but I highly recommend you go through
it.
If you ever want to develop your own icons
in the future, this is very helpful talks
about how to treat icons, and how they should
be flush with an element surface, etc, etc.
and how to apply proper attention to an icon
by not convoluting the icon with excessive
accordion folds.
For example in this scenario where you see
these accordion folds or it looks like this
papers folding or this icon is folding as
opposed to having too many accordion folds
utilize no more than two accordion folds or
just one.
Two really provide a clear focal point to
your icon.
And of course not distorting or transforming
your icons whether they are product or system
icons.
As that is is not an intended approach to
designing.
So that is pretty much all I have for you
today on product icons.
I recommend you just kind of practicing clicking
on one of these, downloading it as an SVG,
and then saving it in a folder somewhere that
makes sense for you.
And again, you already have these icons.
But I recommend getting into the habit of
this as well, because maybe I'm missing an
icon here.
And we can save that SVG, I can go ahead and
open up figma and access the Downloads folder,
my finder, and just drag this icon onto the
canvas.
And now that I have this icon, which is actually
already here, you'll notice that I have the
filled version of this icon, as it states
here.
So I got the 3d rotation icon at a frame size
of 24 by 24, the width and height the set
to 24 dips, or in this case pixels.
Or, as thigma calls it points, but not to
confuse you there, just call them dips here,
and reference material designs, measurement
terminology.
And that is it you just added you can add
it into your library and organize it accordingly.
And I will go ahead and continue to build
this library as well as we move forward in
this course.
But that is all I have for you when it comes
to talking about iconography.
Today, we're going to be talking about building
out the foundation and specifically going
over text legibility and how important that
really is to ensure we're using the proper
color values.
So in this tutorial, we'll be overviewing
the text legibility on material designs website.
So here, it discusses the legibility standards.
And in our previous in the previous video,
we went over the Leonardo color tool, and
we discussed briefly about the setting contrast
ratios, or utilizing this tool to get the
proper contrast ratios.
And we're going to talk about why that's important
in depth.
And here we have some very important article
that I recommend you reading.
And this relator article is on material designs
website covering accessibility in general,
I highly recommend we, you go through that,
and in its entirety.
So here talks about color contrast, can be
used to help users see and interpret apps
content and how it's used heavily across any
and every interface for applications you'll
be building.
And not only the color and contrast, but also
talking about the layout and typography as
well.
I recommend you reading through that on your
own.
And we'll be touching on the WCAG standards
and WCAG stands for the Web Content Accessibility
Guidelines.
And for those of you who do not know, this
requires double a compliance to be ca g double
a compliance for with a ratio 4.5 to one color
contrast between text and backgrounds on normal
typography, normal typography being your body
copy, such as the body copy in, in this website
that I'm highlighting.
And also, a ratio of three to one with utilizing
large texts, a large text could be these headers,
ensuring that they have a contrast ratio of
three to one.
And here you can see it's practically black
on a white background.
So those contrast ratios will be very, very
strong.
And we'll go ahead and just kind of go through
text on background since that's basically
what our typography will be on.
It'll be on a background on a variety of components.
As you can see here in this image, this text
is on a app bar, and it's on the app bars
background color.
And you'll notice as well, here we have a
notification banner of sorts, where typography
is overlaid on the background color of the
notification.
And one thing to cover that is very important
is talking about how the text Opacity is applied
in material design as they heavily rely on
it to indicate states.
So again, black text is recommended for use
on light backgrounds and white text on dark
backgrounds.
Which is important to note, especially if
you're building your app for a light theme
or dark theme.
Just make sure that the text is available
with proper contrast ratios as stated up here.
And we're going to go ahead and talk about
building some of this out some examples.
And now that we've kind of went over using
text opacity, or over how it's used in the
screenshot and how to avoid utilizing it.
Here you can see this typography doesn't change
the opacity of the text is color.
But here you can see that the opacity has
been modified, therefore, giving off an opaque
gray color, which isn't legible and very difficult
to see on colored surfaces, as you can see.
And next we'll talk about dark text on light
backgrounds.
So material utilizes these principles.
So for the, you could think of this as the
active state if you want to, or if you want
to apply a high emphasis on certain information,
maybe you want to apply high emphasis on headers,
for example, such as this website, utilize
the color black, with an 87% opacity.
And then if you want to apply medium emphasis,
which could be medium emphasis, such as typography,
or a default state for, for type higher fee
within a component, you utilize the color
black at a 60% opacity.
And then the disabled state utilizes an opacity
of 30 38% with the color black.
And we'll go ahead and talk about how to sparsely
use colored texts on top of backgrounds.
So colored text typically isn't used everywhere.
And it's used selectively to draw attention
and apply.
very selective emphasis is ideally color text
should be reserved for text elements such
as headlines, buttons, and links.
And here you can see cautious usage of, of
color.
Across the typography.
Here you can see yellow and black and this
Pink Purple background is just highly not
recommended.
I wouldn't even recommend this, as opposed
to being cautious.
Just be aware, if if you're questioning certain
design elements such as this, it's better
off not utilizing that, and sticking to standards.
And here you can see large headlines and short
tech snippets are best for color text.
And next we'll go ahead and talk about helper
text.
And helper text basically gives context about
a fields input, such as how the input will
be used, and it can adopt brand colors as
well but should be legible.
By all means, according to WCAG standards.
And again, it utilizes the same principles.
The only differences helper Tex utilizes a
60% opacity of the color black, and then error
text uses 100% opacity of the color red.
And you can see that hex value right there.
So where would you actually see this? Well,
you can see this in material designs text
input field.
So if we actually go to components here, and
go to whoops, and we search for text input.
Let's see if we can find that text field here
text fields.
And we can select the specs, you'll notice
that there is an error message here for this
image for this text input field, which is
utilizing the the error text here this this
color property applied to typography to give
context about that fields input, which is
right here.
So this was the wrong input by the user in
this example, and there's some error message
that appears.
And then in this text field, it has some helper
text that is indicated right there, which
is reflected right here.
And this text type this variant of helper
text, which is very important.
And we can also discuss selected text next,
so selected text can reflect your brand.
And it can utilize an accent of your primary
or secondary color in this should be legible
against the selection color and the selection
color should contrast the background color.
So that is something important to note here
you can see that material designs using the
primary variant color for the highlight for
the text selection color, highlighting all
the selected text.
And also, another important thing to note
is that icons and other symbols utilize the
same principles for for representing icons
and other symbols as typography.
And when I say typography, I am referring
to dark texts on light backgrounds and light
text on dark backgrounds utilizes the same
principles.
And it just adheres to a specific opacity
levels.
And they are the same opacity levels where
they all use the same color black at different
levels of opacity.
So the active state is a set to a black of
87% and active is 60%.
And the disabled state is 38%.
And one thing you might be asking yourself
as to how do you actually apply this state
to your typography.
So one thing we can do is grab these screenshots
here.
So I can grab a screenshot of this and then
go ahead and open up our exercise file.
Text legibility sudden they're gonna go ahead
and also reference the text types here.
And basically with all of these screenshots,
we're going to be justifying how many types
of color styles we'll need to provide the
proper emphasis in components as we create
them, and then build them out as color styles,
which will then publish later to reuse.
so here we can see, I said iterator before.
Both icons and symbols have the same principles
for dark text on light backgrounds and light
texts on dark backgrounds.
It's uses the same principles and levels of
opacity.
So, meaning we only need to actually create
three styles here.
It's the active, inactive and disabled for
icons and symbols, excuse me.
Also, just providing the high emphasis, medium
emphasis and disabled state for dark text
on light background.
So what we can do is let this all live under
a content section of color styles as well.
So we can go ahead and define that as extend
iconography.
So that is basically what is covered in all
three of these screenshots.
So what we can do is just create a textile.
So we can start off with this screenshot,
I'm gonna move these out of the ways, so I
don't confuse any of you.
Since there's a lot of information in that
area, I'm actually just going to grab a textile
and material design just uses Roboto.
It doesn't matter what the type settings are.
I'm just going to change that up real quick.
And
and now, all we're going to want to do is
define the color.
And this active state is set to 87%.
Currently, the color is set to 100.
So I'm just going to change that input field,
what we can do is just select that style icon.
And you'll notice that we can go ahead and
click on Create style.
And then I'm going to type in text, and iconography.
And this is going to be this naming convention
is going to be the header.
So we know how to utilize that in the color
panel.
So I'm going to just select active active
here.
And then you can also specify the percentage
if you want designers to be able to read that
right off the bat as they're looking at the
name of the color style, or you can remove
it, I'm just going to remove it and select
Create style, I've now created that text style,
which is exactly what I want for any active
icons or other symbols.
And then we're going to go ahead and duplicate
this.
And once that is duplicated, I'm going to
detach the style.
And just specify the inactive state, which
is very simple.
All we have to do is change the path city
once more to 60%.
And that represents the inactive state of
any icons or other symbols.
And I'm gonna go ahead and create another
style.
And again, I just labeled that text and iconography,
the category uses flash naming convention.
And now I am going to specify inactive.
And then we can also specify that this inactive
state is if I click on this edit style icon,
I can add a description and go ahead and state
that utilized for icons and other symbols
as specified here.
In case designers want to know what that color
style is for if they're not sure how to use
it.
That is very important.
You can go ahead and modify those properties
as well later on down the road as well.
I'm going to go ahead and duplicate this and
detach the style and set this to the opacity
of 38%.
And we now have the disabled state for our
not only icons and other symbols, but we have
the disabled state for our typography as well.
So I'm gonna go ahead and click style icon
again, create that style, and label it text
and iconography.
And now that we have that, we can go ahead
and label this disabled.
And now we have our three color styles.
If I go ahead and select some text again,
and I go to my color styles, you'll notice
that I have the text and iconography section
and hear it not only gives me the name of
that color style, but it'll also give me the
description if there is a description, as
you can see here in the tooltip, as you hover
over the color style, so you can understand
what the uses usage is, or description is
for that color style.
So that is awesome.
And now, now that we have this active state
here, it could be a matter of, we could do
a various, there are various decisions you
can make with your team as you're building
out your design system as nomenclature is
extremely important when you start implementing
these foundational elements in your design
system.
So one question that I am posing, and that
you might be asking yourself as well right
now is that if these are the same values,
same hex values, same opacity, and for everything,
here are dark text on light backgrounds and
icons and other symbols, should I recreate
other styles? Well, the answer is no, you
don't have to, what you could do is go ahead,
edit this and specify that this in the description,
you could specify that this is also high emphasis,
right.
So you could specify that that is high emphasis
for for dark text on light backgrounds.
Or, better yet, what we can do is, instead
of having users go to the description of the
color style to identify exactly what the usage
is, for this color style, I'm going to go
ahead and just modify the name of this.
So what I'm going to do is specify that this
is high emphasis.
And I'm going to go ahead and put in parentheses,
the active state, or you could do it vice
versa.
And then I'm just going to save that, now
that has been saved, that is high emphasis,
I'm going to go ahead and select the inactive
state and ensure that I edit the name as well.
And then specify medium emphasis.
And once I have specified that, I will save
that.
And now I'm going to go ahead and select this,
and disabled is just disabled.
So that is fantastic.
We don't actually have to rename that.
And these are important decisions to make
and to understand, as you can see that quickly
a design system could be very polluted in
terms of how you name things, not only in
your design system or designs, but also in
development, it's very important to really
sync with your engineers and understand what
they've implemented in their in their color
palette, or that wherever that that CSS file
is that sass less file, wherever that color
palette is in react for examples, that's a
very popular framework right now, really trying
to understand where those hex values lie.
If they even are hex values or the RGBA.
Base.
These are very important questions to ask
your developers if you haven't already, and
to really start aligning your system with
what is currently in development to really
enhance the workflow amongst designers and
engineers and really start to solidify and
create a unified language across design and
engineering.
So that is all for the dark text on light
backgrounds and icons and other symbols.
Next, we're going to go ahead and talk about
the the text types.
So one thing we did miss is that we've labeled
this medium emphasis and inactive for that
for this state here, medium emphasis.
And inactive, we can also specify in the scription
that this is utilized for helper text.
So I can go ahead and specify that there.
And that solves my problem.
And then we can the last text color style
we need is the error text.
So we need to go ahead and duplicate this.
Detach the style, set the opacity back to
100%.
And then go ahead and set that color to red.
And now that we have the color set to read,
we are good to go.
All we have to do is click on the style icon
Click Create style, and then ensure that it
is under the same category as the rest of
the color styles and type in air, text and
create style.
And we are rocking and rolling folks, we have
created all the color styles that we'll need
to utilize as we continue to build out the
foundation of our material design system.
So if we go ahead and check these color styles
out locally, and say I pull out like a rectangle,
and go and look at my color palette.
It all lives under text and iconography and
my color Styles panel And drag that over.
And you can see that now I have this text,
high emphasis, color style, the medium emphasis,
which is also the inactive state.
We also have the high emphasis, which is the
active state for icons and symbols and high
emphasis pertaining to the dark text on light
backgrounds.
So we're ensuring that all of this content
is reused and simplified.
So there's no duplication of color styles,
which is not necessary, nor Is that necessary
in development either, if you can solidify
that and simplify it, and we have our error
text as well, and our disabled text, which
is all covered here, and that is all I have
for you in the text legibility.
And I do recommend that you go over the web
content accessibility guidelines to really
just understand this, I know a lot of information.
But the more you read this and take notes
on it, the more it'll pay off and give you
an edge as a designer, as accessibility is
extremely important.
We're going to be covering States under the
interaction portion of this section in the
foundation.
As we continue to build our foundation, we're
going to go over viewing states, if you go
ahead and click on this link in this exercise
file to open up a link and give you access
to these states here.
And once you have that page visible, you can
see that states are visual representations
used to communicate the status of a component
or an interactive element.
And we're going to be covering the we're going
to overview of the contents within this page
and how that translates into figma.
That is translated here.
And then we're going to cover the usage of
states and when to apply them, get an understanding
of that.
And we're going to go over all the type of
states as well.
And then we're going to break down the anatomy
of a state and understand the usage and some
foundational guidelines to follow along.
And also, again, implementing states and figma,
and how they're utilized as color styles or
Yes, color styles in figma.
And I'll go over in these examples I've created
for you how to implement them.
And we'll go ahead and build those a few of
those out as well.
And without any further ado, let's get started
on the usage of states.
So states communicate the status of UI elements.
Here, you can see a hover state on this component,
which is a row of tabs.
Here, you can see the pressed state on a button
here.
And here you can see the drag state of a chip
component.
And here you can see the focus state of a
button.
And here you can see the selected state of
a line item.
And there are other states, of course here
as well.
And again, this communicates status UI elements
to the user.
And each status state should be visually similar
and not drastically alter a component, but
must have clear affordances that distinguish
it from other states and the surrounding layout.
So with that in mind with to accomplish that
the material design adheres to these three
principles distinction, ensuring that these
states are have an additive principle to it,
where states occur at once, such as selection
and hover.
And both state indicators are displayed when
taking those actions, whether it's a selection
or hover.
And of course, consistency is another principle
where states should be applied consistently
across components in order to increase usability.
And of course, they states are distinct, or
they have clear affordances, distinguishing
them from one another.
In regards to the surrounding UI, it is associated
with emphasizing according to their level,
their priority levels.
And now we're going to cover all the these
type of states.
So here you can see that there is an enabled
state.
And it's utilizing a button example for the
first four states where an enabled state communicates
an interactive component or element.
So essentially, an enabled state is just the
default state of a component.
So you can think of enabled as default.
Just communicate stuff, this is a button that
you can click.
And the disabled here is a disabled state
of a button, which just states that a it's
a non interactive component or element, so
you can't actually click on it as it is disabled.
And here, we have a hover state for a button.
And that communicates when a user has placed
a cursor above an interactive element.
And we also have a focus state where it communicates
when a user has highlighted an element using
an input method such as a keyboard or voice.
So if I hit tab, you'll notice that I can
tab through this interface here.
I'm tabbing to this this anchor link and I'm
tabbing To this button here, that is the focus
state on this button.
So that is an example of that.
If we go back here to the type of states whoops,
one second.
So if we go back to these type of states,
here, we have the selected state, which communicates
a user's choice where they selected a, a line
item, or you call that a list item as well.
And here, we have an activated state, which
communicates a highlight a destination, whether
initiated by the user or by default.
And here we have a press state which communicates
a user's tap.
And you can see a ripple effect, which is
what that circle is called a ripple, which
is created when you use when you press a button
or an element.
And a press state, it just communicates a
user's click or tap.
And here we have a drag state, which communicates
when a user presses and moves in element.
And we also have the on state, which is typically
used for buttons, checkboxes, and radios,
or switches, radios and checkboxes, excuse
me.
And that on state communicates a toggle between
two options, which is and the two options
are on and off.
And off is the other state, which just communicate
to toggle between two options here, you can
see that the off state is indicated in the
switch, radio and checkbox component.
And also, we have error states.
And the air state communicates a user or system
mistake, as you can see, which is indicated
with the color red.
And the label in this icon, this informative
icon and the red underline of this text input
field and also some helper texts to indicate
the air whether a user created made the air
or the system had created a mistake.
So how are these states communicated? That
is an important question.
Now that we've went over all the type of states,
we're going to break down the anatomy.
So states in figma, are communicated through
an overlay.
So you can see these states here.
And in this section, it represents states
for content on the surface on surface color.
And also states inherited from content.
And it's essentially an overlay is just a
semi transparent covering on an element that
indicates its state.
And the overlays provide a systematic approach
to visualizing states by using opacity.
So here, you can see that this state utilizes
a black overlay.
And this is the focus state.
And it gives you the the overlays, percentage
base value, the opacity, and it uses the color
black here for this focus state overlay for
content on the surface.
And the structure of the overlay lives right
in between the container, which you could
just think of as the surface.
So this is the surface here.
And then the overlay lives right in between
the content and the container.
So it starts off with the content being on
top, and then the overlay, which is where
the state is represented, which is right in
the middle.
And then at the very bottom is the container
in which both the Overlay and content lie
upon.
So that is important to note.
And that that same structure in this diagram
is applied throughout the rest of these containers.
Here you can see the surface container states,
whether it's on primary content, what that
state would look like, and what that state
looks like inherited from content, and then
the surface itself and what that state would
look like when it's selected.
And you'll notice that in the disabled state.
Despite the surface container, whether it's
on the primary surface, or on the generic
surface, the white surface, you'll notice
that the content, the content being the typography
is the state that is actually manipulated,
not the backgrounds itself in the disabled
state.
So in for that, that text is set to disabled.
And again, just to continue to break down
the anatomy of the overlay which represents
the state in our designs.
It it provides a systematic approach to visualizing
states by using opacity and can be applied
to an entire element or in a circular shape.
As you can see here, it's applied in the circular
shape the state when being pressed, and the
overlay color matches the color of the text
or icon on the element that it's applied to.
So here you can see in the third example that
the radio list that is selected is utilizing
the primary color which is set to a blue purple
and then The state associated with it is a
no uses the same color, but an opaque opaque
value of that color.
And as you can see that here as well in figma,
where the state layer uses the primary overlay
the primary color as an overlay, and uses
different opacities to indicate the hovered
focused press dragged and selected states
of that color.
And you can see that the depending on the
type of component and state, so in this line
item, the selected checkbox is using the primary
color.
And you'll notice that the selected state
of this line item also uses that color, but
an opaque value of that color.
So that is important to know.
And you'll notice the same exact thing in
this checkbox, where this is using the the
outline of the checkbox itself and the enabled
state is set to black.
And then the hover state of that checkbox
uses an opaque value of black.
And you can see that here in figma, where
on hover that uses an overlay of 4%, which
is just a black overlay on hover, which is
what we're seeing here in this checkbox.
Which is very important to note, and only
one state layer is applied at a time.
As you can see here, for example, if an element
is first focus and then hovered, the hover
state layer will be shown only until the hover
is complete, then returning to the focus state
layer if the element is still focused, so
you can't do two things at once or two states
at once.
And with that being said, there are also overlay
opacity values applied here, which we can
implement ourselves in figma.
So I could even redo the surfaces, go to figma
paste the screenshot.
And with the screenshot, I can actually recreate
the states as layers here, I can go ahead
and create a rectangle for example.
And I know that the hover state is utilizing
a the the color black set to 4% opacity, so
I can go ahead and apply the color black,
which is a hex value of 0000, set the opacity
of 4%.
I can then turn this into a frame and label
this the hover state the on surface hover
state.
And that rectangle represents exactly that.
Maybe I can ungroup that frame actually and
apply that name to the rectangle itself, we
have that we can add some text here, just
type in hover, go ahead and increase the size
of that.
And once that is all done, I can go ahead
and actually just group that into a frame.
Again, vertically align this text and go ahead
and specify the opacity and I could specify
the hex value as well, just so no one gets
confused.
So users will know that this is an overlay
state hover state, but what is the actual
color first, designers would actually have
to click on the the rectangle shape to understand
the hex value and the Opacity applied to it.
Or we could specify it here.
And just have it labeled as such, if you'd
like.
And I'm going to go ahead and stretch this
out.
So that is a good example.
Here.
That is one example of how you could indicate
your states, I can go ahead and even duplicate
this, change that to the focus state and then
add the 12% Overlay and utilizes the same
color of black again.
And then there's a selected state.
So I can even do the selected state where
the utilizes the on primary color value, the
primary color value, but I'm gonna detach
this style.
And it only uses 8% opacity of the primary
color value as you can see there.
And I might, I'm going to want to copy that.
Paste that hex value in right here.
And you'll start to see that we're specifying
the states here in our system, which is Fantastic.
And then we can go ahead and do the same thing
for the activated state.
So you're starting to see how we create exactly
our states for our components here in figma,
which is great.
No, getting you into the habit.
So the activated state, I can go ahead and
change the opacity to 12%, slightly darker
shade.
And I can even go ahead and represent the
press state, which is actually a ripple effect.
So what we can do for the ripple effect is
just create a circle.
So on the prostate, the color is just set
to, to white at 100% opacity.
But the, we're going to use the, we're going
to create a circle here, and ellipse to represent,
I'm going to put that behind the typography
here and ensure that lives in this layer,
I'm going to clip the content so that the
circle doesn't go outside of the frames bounds.
It's hidden, if it exceeds the frames bounds.
And with that circle, I'm going to just go
ahead and change that color to black, and
then set the opacity to 12%.
And here we have our pressed state, which
is awesome.
And then we can even do a drag to state where
the drag state utilizes an 8% overlay.
Whereas the focus and hover states have different
hover, use a 4% overlay in the focus, use
a 12% overlay.
I'm going to go ahead and create that dragged
overlay, change the opacity to 8%.
Hit Enter and is now a darker shade.
And I'm just going to specify that make sure
it's accurate in the text here.
And I've now created all my states.
And the next thing you'll want to do is actually
command clicks to deep select and select the
triangle with the actual state you're trying
to create.
You can go to the style icon and click Create
style.
And what you would want to do is ensure that
you're properly labeling these.
And you can either check this documentation
ensure that you're creating the right state.
Or you can reference how I've already built
out all of these states.
So you'll notice it starts with states.
And then it uses the slash naming convention
to categorize these states accordingly.
And it has the these black states labeled
as black overlay.
And then it has these primary states which
are purple, labeled as primary overlays.
And then we have the white overlays for when
you're using when you're creating states on
top of pri on primary content, which utilizes
the purple background.
So that is important to note, which is where
these white overlay states are utilized.
And I recommend you going ahead and building
up the rest of these states in exercise, I'm
going to pause this video and create them
myself.
And I challenge you to create them for yourself
as well.
Note that I am missing the enabled state.
So go ahead and add that enabled state here
for this one.
And then for the on primary as well for this
section, creating those as well.
And pause this video and I'm going to create
them and I'll see you when I'm done.
So now I that I created all these states for
when you're on when your content is on the
on primary surface utilizing this color here
of 62 double zero double e x phi, which is
just like this purple variant as color of
purple.
And anyways, point being is that you'll notice
what I what I ended up doing.
If you achieve a similar result actually end
up copying all these and then pasting them
right over here, I added a background to represent
what that looks like on the on primary surface.
And once I did that, all I had to do was actually
change these values to white and you'll notice
a couple things that are are different in
the system when it comes to utilizing the
opacity for states on the on primary surface
as opposed to the on a surface, which is just
a white background on surface being the white
background on primary using this purple color
that the opacities are much stronger when
it comes to the activated state in the on
primary states for activated impressed and
also the drag state you'll notice that there
I've doubled here and the drag state from
8% opacity to 16 utilizing a white color overlay
as opposed to a black one and is set to 32%
here And 24% there, which is something important
to note.
And that is pretty much it, I ended up creating
these this color styles here, I challenge
you to create those color styles by selecting
these rectangles and clicking on style, create
style.
And then the naming convention, you'll use
a state's and then space slash space.
And then this is a white overlay.
And the the type of white overlay it is as
the focus state.
So I could just hit focus, hit Create style,
and I've created the focus state style, I'm
actually going to right click and delete that
style from my local styles, which will appear
at the very bottom since it's a new style
created.
And that appears in that order from based
on when it was created.
Right click and delete it, since I already
have it.
And again, you have these styles to reference
I recommend you going in and making these
and then creating them as needed.
We're gonna be going over selection, this
should be brief, we're mainly just going to
be discussing and overlooking examples of
material designs website, because the selection
will be discussed heavily once we start talking
about states, which is our next video in the
interaction portion of the foundation section
of this course.
So if we go ahead and click on in our exercise
file selection, it is a link that we can access.
And essentially in selection, it just talks
about how it refers to how users indicate
specific items they intend to take action
on.
And when they're taking action on item, there
are several ways to take an action on an item.
And we'll cover that deeply in the states
portion, which is the next video in this course,
that you'll be watching next.
So we're just going to be doing a brief overview
right now.
And you'll notice that a lot of this documentation
covers interaction on mobile devices, but
we're specifically going to be talking about
the desktop portion.
But I will in in figma when we develop when
we create our components.
But here you'll notice I touch on both talking
about selection in mobile and on desktop.
And I would heavily pay attention to the desktop
portion, although the mobile portion is just
as important if not more important.
And anyways, let's get started.
So on touch devices, select items require
you to either do a long press touch on your
device or a two finger touch.
Or you can utilize a selection shortcut if
that is available, such as tapping an avatar.
And on desktop items with checkbox.
checkboxes shouldn't display their checkboxes
by default, or permanently unless the item
selection is the primary activity in the UI.
Instead, these checkboxes should only be displayed
on hover as a single checkbox for that item,
or upon selection of the first item after
which checks boxes are displayed for remaining
items in that set.
so here we can see that the user is tapping,
and then they do a, they're tapping to select
an item.
As you can see here, they were selecting that
first item here.
And they were entering a selection mode, where
they selected an item enter selection mode.
And then was then tapped again to exit out
of that mode.
And here's some other examples as well.
It's just the user selecting multiple cards.
And once each item is selected, they can tap
them to toggle it selection state.
So the user selects all the cards individually,
one at a time.
And then they select them again, to then D
select those items.
So those are all selections.
And then that is another example here we can
see another example of selection where users
are long pressing and dragging across multiple
items to quickly select several items at once.
And you'll notice that they're selecting several
items, because in the top left hand corner
and the app bar, it is then updating the selection
as the user is utilizing the selection.
By long pressing and dragging across multiple
items, the items being photos, and this example
here.
So that is a great example.
And then on desktop, which is very important.
It where you will see much more complicated
variants of states, you'll see that the user
is making a selection on and you'll see that
on hover, it'll reveal that checkbox.
So he there now D selecting and you'll notice
that when the user hovers again, that the
item reveals a checkbox, and the check checkbox
can then be clicked and clicked once again
to D select that row, that line item.
And that is very important to note and we
can also see that there are other variants
of of this here documented.
This is a short and sweet article.
I highly recommend you reading through all
of it just briefly Understand selection.
Today we're going to be talking about understanding
layout in material design.
And we're going to go over some very simple
principles that we're going to be using throughout
the entirety of this course moving forward.
And we're going to go over some examples and
components.
And here I have a couple links.
So we're gonna start off by going ahead and
opening this link, if you'd like to read through
the information, or you can just follow along
with me, I already have these links open,
and essentially material design in order to
ensure consistency across all the platforms
or environments, and screen sizes that they
designed for, they adhere to three simple
principles.
Ensuring that when you are implementing a
layout that is predictable, consistent and
responsive across all those platforms, and
here, you can see those definitions.
So they ensure that they are predictable by
using intuitive and predictable layouts with
consistent UI regions and spatial organization
by using these measurements here, and of course,
consistent layouts, while using the grids,
key lines, and padding.
So we'll heavily be using grids, and padding,
of course, and of course, ensuring that these
layouts are adaptive.
And they react to input from a user, whether
it's a device, or some other screen elements.
So here you can see some of the baseline measurements,
material uses and materials line layouts are
visually balanced.
And to achieve that balance, most of their
measurements are components when they're designed,
aligned to an eight dip grid that is applied,
which aligns both spacing, and it aligns to
the overall layout as well.
And smaller components, such as icons, or
typography can align to a four dip grid.
And also think of that as four pixels.
So what is that exactly? So if we go to figma,
we can go ahead and build a frame, maybe we
want to choose a generic MacBook Pro screen
layouts, I just choose the macro pro pro screen
layout, I'm gonna go ahead and add a grid.
And typically most of the content aligns to
an eight pixel grid or eight dip grid.
So I can do that by just choosing having this
grid type here for my lab grid and set that
size to eight.
And that is my eight.
That's my baseline grid grid here set to eight
dips, or eight pixels, you could say.
So there's an eight, here's your eight pixel
grid here, and you can start designing your
whatever it is to the grid, which is very
essential.
And we will use that as needed.
And of course, when you're designing several
elements, so we have some text here, this
is very low level and not accurate, just this
is just to give you a general idea, this typography
of will of course aligned to the grid here.
And then I can ensure to space it by eight
pixels, as you can see here.
And then if I duplicate into that space by
eight pixels, and notice that when you're
designing and you break down the spacing,
and as you design components, it will always
be divisible by eight or four.
So here, we have some measurements here starting
from zero, and, and then incrementing by four
dips every time.
So 04 812, all the way to 80.
And more often than not, you're going to be
using the spacing up here in the top spacing,
which is either set to 816 20 430-240-4856
647 to an ad, and every now and then you'll
probably use for when you need to apply tighter
spacing to smaller components such as icons
or typography.
So with that being covered, we'll go ahead
and talk about those measurements in the in
the next page.
But right before that, we're gonna talk about
the responsive login route.
So mature designs responsive layout grid is
an overarching guide to the placement of components
and elements so that they adapt to screen
sizes and orientation, ensuring consistency
across layouts.
And the three things that they implement in
their responsive grid layout is of course,
columns gutters and margins.
So here, you can see that margins are to the
very far right and very far left of the screen
in this in this green color here.
And then we have our columns, which are this
shade of red here that's not red, I must be
colorblind, so I apologize.
And that is our column label there.
And then our gutters, of course, is the spacing
between the columns, which are on the far
right far left of the screen, which are the
of course margin.
So I'm gonna actually build an example of
that out in figma here really quick, so we
have this eight dip baseline grid here, so
I'm just gonna label that frame.
So we have the eight dip baseline grid, and
then I'm gonna go ahead and duplicate that.
It's on a Mac Book.
Pro screen.
And I'm going to go ahead and create a responsive
grid layout, I'm going to remove this, I could
keep this if I wanted to add another grid
layout, and change that to columns.
And what we can do is ensure that this type
of grid is set to stretch because that means
it will be a responsive layout grid or you
could call it adaptive.
Or you could say fluid.
That is another common term.
I'm going to add 12 columns here, or we could
check how many columns were implemented in
this grid 368 columns, when it looks like
they're potentially designing for a tablet,
here we have a grids, you'll notice that all
the columns here are set to read.
And I can change the opacity of that to really
point that out.
So we have eight columns here, but we don't
actually have margins yet this, what we're
trying to achieve here is add these margins,
which are labeled in green here.
And we'll set that to 24 pixels, we have the
margin parameter and figma there.
So I've set that 24 pixels.
And you'll notice that it kind of squished
those columns in so I squish those columns
in.
And now I'm going to change this gutter from
the default 20 pixels or points to 16.
Because that is commonly used as well.
And it also perfectly aligns with our our
grid are eight pixel baseline grid as well.
So that is an example of how to build this
out.
But now, I'm going to actually stretch the
screen because this is responsive.
So you'll notice as I move this frame, essentially,
the components you design that will be attached
on the screen, and adhering to the column
layout or the grid layout on the screen will
also be responsive as you as you start to
stretch it around.
Because as you all know, we have web browsers
and we can stretch those around and it becomes
responsive figma itself, the tool is responsive,
as you can see.
But that is an example there a responsive
grid layout.
So now that we have that specified, that is
fantastic.
We'll go ahead and start to see how the measurements
are implemented in components.
So in our in our exercise file, if we click
on app bar components, we can go ahead and
open that link, which will open a a material
design page.
And if you go ahead and follow me and click
on the specs here in the contents category,
you'll see that we have a bunch of bottom
app bars, which are mobile only components.
And what the important thing to get out of
this is that we're seeing a bunch of specs
provided on how to design these elements.
So here you can see that this is this hamburger
menu is wrapped in a 24 by 24 frame.
And we have a floating action button that
is set to 56 by 56, dips in width and height,
which utilizes elevation on the Z index to
rise above this bottom app bar as you can
see here, and then you can see the spacing
between these icons as well is such 24 dips,
and then it has some padding or you could
say margins on the right set to 16 dips.
And it the height of the of these elements,
which are these icons are centered within
this bottom app bar.
And the height of that is set to 24 dips.
So there's some measurements there.
And you can continue to scroll down and view
other variations of this floating action button.
As you can see here, there are other variations
with more specifications provided here.
So there's eight dips between this floating
action button and the whitespace there to
the bottom app bar background.
Again, more, notice that all of this is divisible
by eight or four.
So understanding that this is all very consistent
at a very low level.
So it all starts from the ground up.
Or you could say very primitive level, as
these are primitive, such as icons, everything
is divisible by eight or four.
And also the spacing amongst all these elements
And as well as the sizing of other components
that are overlaid on top of this bottom app
bar, which is fantastic and a great source
of information for you to soak through.
And we'll be getting into this very much soon.
And that is all I have for you and understanding
layouts.
We're going to be talking about pixel density.
And what that is exactly.
So we're going to have an overview of that
and then understand pixel density across different
platforms such as iOS, Android, and for the
web.
And what that means for each platform.
And I have the resource here, we can click
on this link and just open it up.
And once you have it opened up, you'll notice
that it takes you to material designs documentation.
And we're just going to be reading through
this and I'll be explaining this to you and
certain scenarios in which you would need
to understand this and also just to all broaden
your horizons as a designer if you already
don't understand pixel density.
So once you have to design for specific platform,
you know exactly how to communicate measurements,
for example.
So say, communicating measurements for Android
is completely different than communicating
measurements for developers on the web, you
know, or iOS, or Android.
So understanding how to do conversions, for
example, you may have, say, for example, I
was building a Splunk.
product for, which is the company I worked
for, and this products already been released.
And it was a application shipping for iOS.
And I, myself had been a designer for the
web.
And I was not aware of how to translate pixel
density from the web to iOS at the time.
And essentially, that is a scenario where
you would need to understand this.
So I was providing that example.
So let's, let's dive in.
And we'll get into the rest later.
So what is Hanks pixel density, screen pixel
density and resolution vary depending on the
platform and pixel density is just the number
of pixels that fit into an inch is referred
to as pixel density.
So it's the pixels per inch, how many pixels
per inch.
So you may have seen, if you've printed paper
out before, or printed out some graphics or
something, it asks you in the settings before
you print to specify how many pixels per inch,
you want that to be printed at.
So the lower the amount of pixels per inch,
the lower the density is.
And the more pixels per inch, the higher the
density is, when you see that printed, or
if when you see on a display, and they give
you here in this documentation, a basically
a formula on how to calculate pixel density.
And it's just this equation where your screen
density equals the screen width or height
and pixels divided by the screen width or
height in inches.
And if you do that, you'll get your pixel
density.
So there's an example here visually, which
is a really good example where this high density
display has more pixels per inch than the
low density display here, and it zooms in
on it.
And you'll notice that the you this UI element,
as pixel dimensions appear larger on low density
screens, and smaller on high density screens.
So the more pixels you have, the smaller it'll
appear on high density screens.
And the lower that the pixel dimensions are,
the larger it'll appear.
So with that being said, we can jump on to
talking about density independence, which
refers to the uniform display of UI elements,
on screens with different densities, and density
independence.
In material design is commonly pronounced
as dips, which is the abbreviation dp here
written as dp, and pronounces Dibs, they're
flexible units that scale to have uniform
dimensions on any screen.
And they can provide a flexible way to accommodate
a design across platforms.
So for example, Material Design not only designs
for the web, but also Android and iOS.
So they use this terminology dips, which is
their way to have a common language in design
and engineering to accommodate designs across
several platforms.
And material, UI wise, use of density independent
pixels, is to display elements consistently
across screens, with different densities on
those different platforms.
So here, you can see a low density screen
displayed with density independence here,
where the low density makes it much more apparent,
where you can see all these pixels here, which
are all the squares, it's much more apparent
on low density.
And it is less, it is still apparent, but
it is harder to see on high density, all the
squares due to the high density screen displayed.
And we now we can start to talk about the
pixel density on it on a per platform basis
where this pixel density on Android when you're
developing on Android, or designing for Android
use dips to display elements uniformly on
screens with different densities.
So that's how you would measure it.
And it dip is, is equal to one physical pixel
on a screen with a density of 160.
And essentially what that and there's the
equation here, again, being utilized.
So essentially, a dip is one dip is one pixel.
So don't let me confuse you.
You could think of it as simple as that.
One dip is one pixel.
But dips are used for measuring on Android.
So that is important to note.
And also scalable pixels.
The abbreviation for that as SP serves the
same function as density independent pixels
which are dips.
But for fonts, the default value of a scalable
pixel is the same as the default value for
a dip.
But for fonts, the primary difference between
a scalable pixel and a density independent
pixel is that scale will pixels preserve a
user's font setting, which is super important.
users who have larger text settings for accessibility
will see font sizes match their text size
preferences.
And again, pixel density on iOS.
The iOS based platform determines density
using logical resolution, which means it just
measures its units in points as opposed to
pixels or dips, it uses points for measurement.
And here, with their logical resolution, the
points are scaled using a native scale factor,
which is some technical knowledge for you
to understand if you like, which just maps
to a device's native resolution.
So for example, if you're designing for the
iPhone x, you would design for a logical resolution
of 375 points by 112 points.
And when it's rendered elements are processed
by the graphics hardware.
Now using this native scale factor functionality
to fill in the iPhone Xs, dimensions, since
the screen is much bigger.
So it has the capabilities of understanding
those points and scaling them accordingly
to the device it's being displayed on.
And units, again, for iOS use points, which
remember that and then, of course, pixel density
on the web scales to the devices, screen resolution,
but when you're designing for the web, replace
dips with pixels.
So you can when you're designing products
on the web, unless specified otherwise, by
say engineers you work with and whatnot, you
can just measure things in pixels.
We're gonna go over some spacing methods,
once more in material design, hear how they
approach spacing, their elements, and they
use terminology that is very useful that we're
going to go over in the documentation.
And in our exercise file here, we can go ahead
and click on this link and figma, where we'll
have access to opening the spacing methods
page in figma.
And we're going to go over everything in the
contents here.
And spacing methods are essentially just the
use of baseline grids, key lines, padding,
and incremental spacing to adjust certain
ratios, containers and touch targets.
A lot of this is very important.
I know, it might be slightly boring.
But this is very, this is a great resource
for us learning, not only spacing for materials
design system, but also applying this to any
other systems we create or products we get
to design moving forward.
And here we have our baseline grid, where
it just discusses how all components align
to an eight dip square baseline grid for mobile
tablet, and desktop.
So we can go ahead and replicate that here.
So here, you can see that the square is eight
by eight dips, which is essentially just eight
by eight pixels.
If you were to design for the web, and here
in figma, we're going to go ahead and create
a screen that is set to the size of a MacBook
Pro screen.
And I'm just going to label this a div baseline
grid.
So and then I'm gonna apply a layout grid.
So and then set the size to eight here and
I now have a eight dip baseline grid that
I can always that I can utilize to measure
my elements here on this frame.
So that is very important to note.
And it's great to have.
So that is a direct translation of how that
is written out in the documentation, how to
create that in figma.
And we also have a four dip grid, where that
is utilized in more dense areas such as icons
type, and some elements with components that
can align to a four dip grid.
And if we wanted to create a four dip grid,
honestly, all we have to do is duplicate this
one, I can rename that to four dips.
And then from there, I would need to Whoops,
I had that set to 18 that should be at eight.
So now that said eight, my apologies.
And now that that's set to eight, I can go
ahead and change this one to four.
And now we have a four dip baseline grid and
the eight to baseline grid.
And the usages for those for those are specified
here.
So typography aligns to the four digit baseline
grid.
And this typography can be placed outside
of the four dip grid when it's centered within
a component, such as a button or list item.
When it's placed outside of the grid, but
centered within a component text can still
appear vertically center aligned.
As in this scenario, you can see that as well,
it is a vertically aligned in the center of
this list item right here.
All although the type is placed outside of
the four dip grid, so that is something important
to note there.
And then we're going to talk about some terminology
that we'll be using frequently throughout
the course when we build these components
from scratch.
So they're using these buttons as examples.
So the spacing methods are more granular than
the responsive grid layout, where it is a
set of rules around how to place elements
within layouts and components.
So padding refers to the spacing here, between
elements within a component.
So you can see that there's padding to the
left and right on this icon, and there's padding
to the left and right of this button on the
right.
And that and that it is has alignment that
is vertically centered within this button,
which is expressed in this example.
And this alignment spacing method example
where the button with the plus icon is vertically
aligned to the center within the button component.
And of course, we have two mesh dimensions,
which we'll be going over very much soon,
where it describes the width and height of
the components elements.
So we'll know exactly how to size our components
and the elements within them accordingly,
by utilizing the dimensions, and then now
it talks about specifically padding, and how
it refers to the space between UI elements
and how it is an alternative spacing method
to key lines and as measured in increments
of eight dips, or four.
So again, you'll notice that it's always divisible
by eight or four.
And padding can be measured both vertically
and horizontally, and does not need to span
the whole height of the layout.
And of course, we have the dimension specified
here for the component, the height here is
set at eight as you can see, and it gives
you the specs for the height of the app bar,
which is set to 56 dips, and then the status
bar height is set to 24 dips.
And of course this list items at 88 dips.
So this is important to refer to when we really
need to ensure that our elements are pixel
perfect, or in this case density independent
pixel perfect.
And then, of course, we have the alignment,
which is the placement of elements in here,
it's just giving you examples of elements
being highlighted and discussing how they
are centered.
So that is great.
And then we also have key lines.
And it's a tool that enables consistent placement
of elements outside of a layout grid.
And they are vertical lines that show where
elements are placed when they don't align
to the grid key lines help you determine the
distance between elements from the edge of
the screen.
And you can also measure in increments of
eight and then also move helps you a lot in
figma.
So if I open up figma, and I create some text
here.
And once I have that text created, I can go
ahead and even create a rectangle.
Here, if I hold down Option, you'll notice
that key lines appear.
And I see that this is 240 pixels away to
the left and this text.
And I can measure from the edges of the screen.
From the top edge, the distance between and
the left edge and the bottom edge and even
the very far right edge, as well as this two
by just holding down option.
Or Alt on Windows option on Mac.
And those are my key lines that helps me specify
the distance between elements.
And we're going to be using this shortcut
key all the time we're building components
to ensure they're pixel perfect.
So that is what key lines are.
And you can also use rulers in figma.
If I hit Shift R, you'll notice that in the
canvas this, these set of rulers appear and
you can measure to the distance between the
rulers as well.
And you can create a vertical or horizontal
by just dragging from within the ruler and
onto the canvas.
And you can measure the distance between as
long as you hold option hover over that read
that ruler line or key lines, we could call
it and you can hide them by hitting shift
R.
And those are how we'll use key lines.
And next we'll talk about containers and ratios.
And essentially containers a term that refers
to an enclosed area.
And essentially containers are composed of
UI elements, such as images, icons or surfaces.
So here we have an image container.
Here we have an icon container and we have
of course a surface container, which encapsulates
a button and containers can Be rigid and restrict
the size of, or cropping of elements within
them.
So you can utilize containers to crop images
if they were in an image container, or even
an icon container.
But that, but it's typically utilized more
often with image containers where you'll need
to crop an image.
But they can be flexible and grow to support
the size of the content that it holds.
As you can see, in these examples, we have
a rigid image container, an example number
one, which crops the original size of the
image, or we have a flexible image container.
And example number two, that holds the original
image size as it scales.
And then there are some important things to
understand here where we talked about aspect
ratios where the aspect ratio is a proportion
of an element, its width to its height.
And its aspect ratio is written as such width
to height.
And to maintain consistency, and your layout
material design uses a consistent set of aspect
ratios on elements like images, surfaces and
screen sizes.
And it is recommended for us to use this these
set of aspect ratios across our UI.
And you can see them here.
So you can see some landscape formats where
this ratio is graded.
And then some some portrait formats as well.
And it talks about flexible ratios, which
is determined by the layout grid, where the
container width is determined by the screen
layout and grows to fill the maximum space
available.
So it's just referring to a responsive screen.
And a container height is determined by the
height of the image in the container with
these flexible ratio principles, and you can
use a flexible ratio to allow content form
determine the height of the container, which
is very common.
And one of the most important things to understand
is touch targets, and how touch targets apply
to any device that receives both touch and
non touch input.
And this is these principles are used to balance
information density and usability all in one.
And touch targets should at least be a size
of 48 by 48 dips, or 48 by 48 pixels with
at least eight dips of space between each
target.
So you see that the dimension specified here.
Although see this icon container is set to
40.
By 40 dips, the tap target is set to 48 by
48 dips.
So that is very important.
And if you were to have another icon container
next to it or any or a button, for example,
it would have to be at least eight dips of
space between the target so I can go ahead
and do that.
So say I had an icon here set to 40 by 40.
I can I can specify this I can create a frame
and then hold on option command to scale this
to 48 by 48.
And then I can center this and you'll notice
that I'll change the background here to white,
maybe a little slight red.
And that red ref references the tap target.
And the icon here is this circle and the tap
target set to 48 or 48.
But the icon itself is 40 by 40.
So those are the dimensions for the tap target.
And then if you were to create another element
next to it, you would at least have to have
a spacing of eight dips.
So that is essentially what this is referencing
here.
And you can see that this button has a height
of 36 dips, but the tap targets height is
set to 48 tips.
So that's very important.
And you can see in the second example that
there's an icon set to 24 by 24 dips, but
the tap target is set to 48 by 48 dips.
So that is a standard principle for accessibility,
just to ensure that you can actually tap these
elements on the interface correctly, and adheres
to not only balancing information on your
screen and usability, especially for impaired
users, but it just allows for a more cohesive
design.
Today, we're going to go over the responsive
grid layouts in material design.
And we're going to be creating those in figma
and as styles so that we can systematically
reuse them across all our designs as needed
and implementing them into our system.
So here you can see that I've taken some screenshots
off of material designs website, which references
all of the the breakpoints, so it discusses
the breakpoint system here and also the breakpoints
for how they designed for iOS devices.
And we'll be going over not only creating
Those istyles and figma.
But before we jump into that, we're going
to be talking about some key concepts and
stuff to apply to our mental model and creating
grids and designing.
And some of those things being columns, margins
and gutters when you're creating your grid,
which we already know and have covered.
And we'll go over that, again, to reiterate
that, and ingrain that in your brain, and
also some ways to customize the grid, whether
it's horizontally or vertically, customize
on the grid layout on those accesses, and
discussing what you can and can't do, or at
least some good best practices and not so
good practices.
And then of course, creating the styles, understanding
grid behavior, mainly the differences between
a fixed grid layout and a responsive grid
layout, and then discussing UI regions.
And what those are some examples on their
web page, and then what white frames are,
so we can go ahead and click on this resource
here, open the link, and it will open up this
responsive layout grid page on material designs
website.
And essentially, this responsive layout grid
allows our designs to adapt to several screen
sizes and orientations, ensuring consistency
across all the layouts.
And the general diagram describes what a responsive
grid layout or just a grid layout in general
it consists of.
and it consists of columns, as you can see
here, and gutters which are which are the
which is the spacing between columns.
And then the margins, which are on the very
far left and far right of the screen laid
out in green here.
Those are the margins.
And it talks in depth about columns, and how
the content is placed in the areas of the
screen that contained column.
So you'll notice that generally, when you're
designing on a grid layout that your designs
or your components, snap to these columns.
So as you can see, here, it snaps to the left
and right edges of these two columns.
So this, you could say this card takes up
two columns, as well as the one to the right
of it.
And it utilizes that spacing in between, and
the gutters to provide that consistent spacing.
And so things are categorized in an organized
fashion.
So column width is defined using percentages
rather than fixed values, which allows content
to flexibly adapt to any screen size.
So you'll notice when we create up create
these grids here in figma, they're going to
be very responsive.
And the number of columns displayed in the
grid is determined by the break point range.
And the break point range here is specified.
So from zero dips to 359 tips, or you could
call those pixels if you're designing for
the web.
And you can see that we have ranges all the
way for mobile devices here all the way to
massive screens.
And we'll be creating all of these.
And here, we'll be creating all of these iOS
grid layouts as well.
And that is that for columns, and here are
some examples on mobile at a 360 dip breakpoint
using a four column grid layout here, as you
can see four columns, Scott scoters, and margin
specified as well.
And you can see that on a tablet at a breakpoint
of 600 dips wide, it uses a layout grid of
eight columns.
So as this screen expands, it goes from four
columns to eight columns, which also allows
for more content to be implemented on that
screen.
So you can see that this row only has two
cards.
And then when expands to a wider screen size,
which is 600 dips in this example, it goes
from two cards to four cards on that row.
And here where it discusses gutters, and those
are the spaces between the columns as it's
highlighted here, and they help separate content.
And those gutter widths are fixed values at
each breakpoint.
And to better adapt to the screen size.
gutter width can change at different breakpoints.
So wider gutters are more appropriate for
larger screens as they create more whitespace
between columns.
So that way, information on the screen isn't
as isn't as dense and cluttered as it can
be if there are not wide enough gutters that
larger screen sizes.
So here you can see on a on mobile device
at the breakpoint of 360 dips.
This layout grid uses 16 dip gutters and on
tablet on the breakpoint 600 dips wide.
The layout grid uses 24 dip gutters specified
here, and it's using those 24 dip gutters
to separate the content.
And now we can discuss margins which is a
space between the content on the left and
right edges of the screen as highlighted in
green here on the left and right and these
margin widths are defined as fixed values
at each break.
point.
And this allows you to better adapt to the
screen and the margin width can change at
different breakpoints.
Wider margins are more appropriate for larger
screens as they create more whitespace around
the perimeter of the content, as you can see
here.
So here's an example of margins on mobile
on a small device using a layout grid of 16,
dip margins.
And then on a tablet at on a lot slightly
larger device, the mobile, you'll notice that
the margin increases from 16 to 24, dips here
on the left and right margins.
And now we can go ahead and talk about the
customization of the grid and ways you can
customize it, which allows you to meet the
needs of both your product and the various
device sizes you're designing for.
So sometimes, you might need to customize
gutters to have more space between content
to create more to just to create more consistency.
If spacing gets too tight at times, or, or
if there's too much spacing, as you can see
here, in this lab grid, it's using eight dip
gutters here, very tight spacing, the tighter
spacing may suggest images are closely related
to one another so that they're perceived as
a part of a collection.
And here you can see that this layout grid
uses much larger gutters set to 32 dips to
create more separation between columns.
And that extra space helps the album be perceived
as individual entities within a collection.
And one thing you shouldn't do that is recommended
is to not make gutters too large, such as
the same width as the columns too much space
doesn't leave enough room for content and
prevents it from appearing unified, and it
just looks weird.
All the spacing is just way too much.
And also you can customize margins, margins
can be adjusted to create more or less space
between content.
And the edge of the screen margins use a fixed
value for each breakpoint.
And it gives an example of typography here
text, the ideal length for body copy is 40
to 60 characters per line.
So if you're going beyond that many characters
per line, it could be an indication of you
having to add more depth to your margins,
increasing the margin space.
And don't make margins so large that there
isn't sufficient room for content.
So you have to find that balance.
So here's an example on mobile on a mobile
breakpoint size 64 dip margins to limit the
width and the content still looks proportionate,
but doesn't doesn't overwhelm the user.
Whereas this is very dense and thin, just
not good use of whitespace and too much space
in the margins.
That example.
And here, we can talk about also the utilization
of horizontal grids where Material Design
layout grids can be customized for touch you
eyes that scroll horizontally.
So if you're for example, looking through
a photo album or just scrolling on a browser
on a tablet, or mobile device, columns, gutters
and margins are laid out from left to right,
rather than top to bottom, when you're creating
a horizontal layout grid.
In here, you can see that the margins are
at the top and bottom of the horizontal grid
layout, and the columns here set to four columns
with a 400 height in depth 400 dips in height,
which is great, we got that specified.
And then we have the gutters as well, those
same principles just a different orientation.
And horizontal grids can be positioned to
accommodate different heights allowing space
for app bars and other UI regions or other
content that is fixed on the screen to begin
with.
So you can squeeze that in there.
And now that we've discussed all that, we're
going to be talking about building breakpoints
in figma.
At the very end, a couple more things to cover
are UI regions.
And essentially, UI regions are a layout,
which is made of several UI regions such as
side navigation that is fixed.
So UI regions are typically fixed content,
like the side navigation, the content area,
and this app bar.
These regions can display actions, content
or navigation destinations.
And these UI regions should be consistent
across devices.
And you'll notice that it gives you an example
of that as it scales down.
So it starts to like a desktop layout, and
then a tablet layout, and then a mobile layout,
and it talks about it shows you how it isolates
the UI regions as it scales down, which is
very important to increase familiarity of
how this is done across devices as you scale
up and down.
When you're designing so you can ensure that
you're properly adapting to different breakpoints
have different screen sizes.
And, again, I'll be touching upon how these
UI regions are fixed.
You can think of them as permanent UI regions
that can be displayed outside of the responsive
grid as well, like navigation drawer, where
these regions cannot be collapsed.
As you can see here, in this example above.
And then we have persistent UI regions that
can be displayed upon a command such as a
hamburger menu where a menu slides in when
you press it, and they can remain visible,
or they can be toggled on or off to appear
disappear.
And when they appear, they condense both content.
They condense both content and the grid.
So you'll notice that it condenses that grid
once that persistent UI region is toggled
on, user presses it in this example, and then
the content gets condensed.
And which adheres to the grid, which is why
the content is condensed.
And then there's temporary UI regions, which
do not affect the responsive grid.
So this is an overlay example, when it's visible,
they can be hidden by tapping an item in the
region, or any space outside of the region.
So this temporary region only appears temporarily
and does not affect the responsive grid.
And then we have this concept of white frames,
which are structured layouts that provide
a consistent approach to layout, and layering
and shadows.
And it's a great starting point meant to be
modified to meet the specific needs of a product.
So for example, you could think of this as
a template.
So you don't have to design the entire bare
bones structure of a design, you can just
grab a white frame to get started.
Or this just gives you a really good start
to designing your product, as opposed to building
out all of this from scratch.
So here you can see a mobile example of a
white frame, which you can think of as a template,
where you can then go in and plug in what
you need into that interface.
It's already built out for you from from the
bare bones structure, and also a desktop example
of that.
So now with all that being said, and allows
a lot to cover, we can go ahead and open up
figma and start creating these these grid
styles.
So we can start by, I can grab this screenshot,
and we'll do a couple together.
And then the rest of this exercise, you'll
be implementing these on your own as well.
So here we have the first breakpoint, which
is set from zero to 359, dips, I'm going to
create a frame specify that the width is set
to 359, which is really thin size is set to
portrait.
And I don't really care about the height right
now, because this is the we're just developing
the grid layout for this width, not the height.
So I'm going to click on Create style here,
this grid style, click on that layout grid
settings icon and change that to columns.
And you can see that it's set to four columns.
And the margins and gutters are set to 16.
And it is going to be responsive.
So I'm going to set that type to stretch.
So I'm going to set the margin to 16.
And notice that my margins have now increased,
there are now margins and then change the
gutters to 16 as well which thickening the
columns and tighten the spacing between content
when we align it on this grid lab.
So now we have this grid layout for this breakpoint
range.
And I can go ahead and now I can actually
turn this into a style.
So with that this lab group created, I can
click on this style icon and click on the
Create style.
And what I can do is specify that this is
an extra small grid layout.
And I can even specify extra small at zero
to 359 dip.
And I can even specify I can categorize this
because here you can see that we have a range
of screen sizes from extra small in this column
to small to medium to large.
So I'm going to specify this as extra small
x small is a slash naming convention to categorize
this.
And now I can go ahead and name this as as
such, so now it's extra small, and it's the
first breakpoint from zero to 359 dips.
This is what the grid will look like I can
create that style.
I can even go in edit and add a description
and discuss that this is used for small hands
sets.
And yeah, that's all the information I really
need to communicate to designers who are needing
to understand what this grid layouts used
for.
So now I have that grid layout applied.
Now I'm going to duplicate this frame and
remove this layout grid and ensure that I
have this set to 360 pixels or so I can have
a frame any wide, anywhere from 360 to 399
dips.
So I can even just change this from 359 to
360.
And width, or I can just increase it to 399
doesn't matter as long as it's within that
range.
And because since this is a fluid layout,
it will automatically maintain and calculate
the four columns between this bait breakpoint
range and ensure that these margins and gutters
are set to 16 at all times, and also four
columns for this breakpoint range.
So I can go ahead and create another layout
grid style, click on the grid settings, specify
the column, select the columns, ensure that
there's four, I can even change the color
of this, if I wanted to, I could change that
to a blue and ensure that the type is set
to stretch at 16.
pixels are 16 dips to my margin and gutters
and I now have that specified.
And I can go ahead and close that out and
create this as another grid style under the
extra small category using that slash naming
convention.
And then from there, I'm going to go ahead
and specify the break point range which is
360 to 399.
And I'm going to write dp.
So people understand that this is the format
for material design, which is dips, density
independent pixels, I'm going to create that
style, I now have two grid styles here.
And I'm going to go ahead and create one more
with you.
And then I'm going to challenge you to make
another one the rest by yourself.
So I'm going to duplicate this and detach
this style, create one from scratch, change
this two columns.
And here, I need to specify the width anywhere
from 400 dips to form 79.
So I'm just going to select 479 lipsi 479
on the width.
Now that I have 479 specified, I'm gonna click
on my grid settings, and ensure that there
are four columns, change the color of this
grid again, to another shade of blue, just
because I like blue, and then change the margin
of 16 and the gutters to 16 as well.
And it is set to stretch.
So it will be responsive.
And now I can turn this into a grid style,
and specify that this is an extra small, whoops,
extra small grid style.
And then I can specify the breakpoint range.
So it's 400 dips to 479.
And quick, great stop.
And I can even go ahead and add a description.
So this one's typically used for large handsets,
meaning large devices, large handset.
And then now that I have that description
there, I have my three styles.
And now I challenge you to go ahead and make
the rest of these styles here from 480 dips
downward.
And I'm going to make pause this video and
make them myself.
So I'll be right back.
Alright, so now that I've created all the
styles, you can compare what you've created
with me, compared to the grid styles.
Here, I have all of the format specified here
in this screenshot.
And all these breakpoint ranges are clearly
being reflected directly in the single file
as grid styles, you can see that all these
breakpoints are split by window size.
So we have four extra small breakpoint sizes
specified as grid sizes with the proper columns
and margins.
And of course, this is already in the exercise
file for you to to view.
And if you didn't make them from scratch,
I highly recommend you do it's a great way
to practice building grid styles.
And I can almost guarantee you that by the
time you finish creating this many grid styles,
you'll know how to do that.
And it'll be just something very, very simple
for you to do and you have that skill as a
designer from here on out which is very useful.
You know, it's like the back of your hand.
And as you can see here, I have all these
styles all the way up to the extra large size
wishes for any breakpoints at the size, the
width of nine 1920 pixels or wider.
And we have all of those examples specified
here in this file.
And as a bonus exercise, you can go ahead
and even create all the iOS breakpoints, if
you like, as those are specified here.
And one tip is if you create a frame, and
you go to frames, you have all sorts of formats
for your iPhone formats here.
So you can just select an iPhone format, and
then implement a grid layout.
And just selecting your column layout, specifying
how many columns are necessary, the majority
of them utilize four columns for the for this
compact version here are just for the the
first three set of sets of iPhones are the
first for both.
In portrait and landscape, you'll notice that
the orientations are different.
So you would probably you'll need to create
a grid for a horizontal landscape as well.
So do take that into consideration where you'll
not use columns, but you'll use rows to specify
your grids.
So that is very important to take into consideration.
As you're building these, I recommend you
challenging yourself, and doing that and creating
those styles as well.
So you could even go ahead and create that
grid style.
And you can specify that this is an iOS grid
layout by providing that naming convention,
they're using the slash to categorize them
as grid styles for the iOS breakpoint.
And then you can just specify iPhone portrait.
And you now have that iOS variant grid style.
So if I go in and create a frame, and I go
to my grid styles, you'll notice that I've
categorized them, I have extra small grids
have small grid styles, choose from medium
grid cells, and large ones, and extra large
and of course, an iOS one.
So you can go ahead and build those out as
well, which is very helpful.
good exercise for you.
And you'll notice to some of you may have
question, Why make so many grid styles.
If, say, for example, all these small extra
small formats, all use the same amount of
columns and gut margins and gutters.
That's a great question.
And since this is a responsive layout, technically,
you don't even need to make all four of these,
I was solely making all four of them to replicate
the preciseness of this break point system
in this table specified by material design.
So if you want to go ahead and actually consolidate
these to the minimum amount of grid styles
necessary, you can go ahead and do that.
And in reality, you would actually only need
three grid styles, you would need the extra
small and the small.
Actually, you'll need three grid style.
So you would need the grid style that is for
these breakpoints for these first four breakpoints
here, these extra smalls with the four columns,
and margin and gutter set to 16 dips.
And then you'd have a second one for the small
breakpoint for the small tablet where the
it's set to eight columns and 16 margin and
gutters.
And then you have a third one set to breakpoint
for large tablets where the columns are eight.
But the margins of gutters are set to 24.
And then for every other device, you would
have 12 columns and 24 dip margin and gutters.
So essentially, you only have 1234 grid styles,
you could consolidate those, and even go in
and if you consolidated them, you could write
a description for what breakpoints they applied
to, which is also a great exercise, I recommend
you doing that as well.
Today, we're going to be building out all
of the variants for the app bar, specifically
the bottom portion of the app bar, which is
where you can think of as some bottom navigation.
And we have a link to the description of this.
And it's a bottom map, app bar, which displays
navigation and key actions at the bottom of
the mobile screens.
And since you've been getting the hang of
actually building this out with me, and even
by yourself, I hope so you already have I
hope you already have this down by now.
That'd be awesome.
If not, we're going to go through this.
You'll notice that we have four variations
of this app bar.
This bottom app bar, we have labeled as there's
one with no floating action button.
It's just a bunch of icons to access the different
actions and we have the floating action buttons
centered and you'll notice that there's some
spacing here some intricate spacing there
that will help to accommodate for newer designs.
You And then we also have the floating action
buttons center over the bottom app bar and
those actions.
So what we'll do is in figma, have all the
screenshots, what we're going to do is create
this one.
And I'm going to challenge you to create these
two as it's very simple.
We're going to create this one, get all the
spacing, right, and then I want you to, I'm
going to pause the video, build these up by
myself, and then have you build those out,
challenge yourself to understand the, the
specs here to build those out.
And then we'll go over that.
And then we're going to build out the center
cut variant together as this might be challenging.
But nothing is too challenging for us as we
will be fig maestro's once this course is
complete.
So let's get started with creating this variant
that the floating action buttons centered.
So for those of you who don't know, this,
this is probably this is generally designed
for Android as this is materials design system.
And the specs are set to 360.
Width by 640.
But essentially, you don't have to worry about
the actual size of the background, where you
do need to understand in your head have the
mental model of responsiveness.
So it will adhere to this spacing and whatnot,
as it is being expanded in regards to width
as you can see here.
Just as an example, interactive example there.
So let's get started by specifying the height
of the background for this center, this app
bar, so I'm going to go ahead and now that
we have the height of this, the width of the
Android device specified, I can go ahead and
change the height to 56.
Now that we have that set of 56, I'm going
to change the background color.
One thing we need to do not forget is enable
our material design system library.
And with that specified, go to my background
colors and select on primary.
And we need our icons now.
So if we go to our assets panel, we can either
search for them or type in hamburger, no results
for hamburger, that's disappointing.
Go to our material design system, check out
our icons, and we can look for them.
So there's the icon I need there, it's called
reorder apparently, I can go ahead and click
on this frame, hit Command V and it will paste
it, what we need to do is remove this fill
color, detach the style, select the style
icon and apply the proper color, which is
content on primary.
And then I'm going to hold on option A on
this once I have this icon selected, Option
A will snap it to the left of the frame.
And then I'm going to apply the proper spacing,
it's set to 24 there.
So I'm just going to move this over a couple
times.
Now that spacing set 24 centered.
And I can even just duplicate this icon to
slowly showcase the the usage of placeholders.
As you can see, if I go ahead, set that set
to 16.
I've not duplicated it again.
And I'll ensure the spacing is set to 16,
again, between these two icons.
So we have those set to eight to the right,
which we want to set to 16.
So I push that over.
And we're good to go.
We have our icon grants, if you want to be
particular by our icons, you can search for
them, we can look for them as well, in this
library, I'm gonna pause this and find those
icons for you real quick.
If you can't find icons, you can either search
and the material design icons tool for the
icon.
So I downloaded all those individually as
svgs just by clicking on them and then selecting
download, but I've already downloaded them
for you and they're in this exercise file.
So we can actually in your folder, so if you
go to the proper section or components, so
2.1, you will have that that will be accessible.
And what we can do is open up our finder and
drag all three of these components onto the
canvas.
And we can go ahead and add the appropriate
components now.
But before I do that, I'm going to change
those colors, remove that fill there, go to
selection colors, click on the style icon
and set these to content on primary.
And we'll be good to go.
So I can go ahead and actually replace these
two.
So what I can do is individually drag these
into the canvas shift click on this.
And you'll notice that with the famous smart
selection, I can hold down Option W and it'll
snap this layer to the top and then I can
swap them which is very helpful.
So I can so I don't have to do all that resizing
again there.
The resizing is maintained.
I can go ahead and drag these two Under the
canvas, and individually swap these as well,
I'm going to hit option w so that the spacing
is not there, and they both align on that
axis.
And then I'm going to switch them, then delete.
And just, I'm going to center this one Shift,
click it, and then I'm going to swap those.
Now I have all the desired icons that are
reflected here.
And we can go ahead and even pull in our neck
our, our floating action button.
And we want the regular one, which is this
one and it's bigger and the thumbnail, as
you can see, we can actually go ahead and
drag this in onto our canvas.
And with that done, what we're going to want
to do is make sure that it's snapped, and
it's horizontally centered here.
So if we group it into our frame and, and
then what we're going to want to do is click
clip, uncheck clip content, click this and
then hold down Option H.
And that will center this because it was not
centered option h now centered.
We have these icons properly implemented.
And we want these icons to have constraints
that snap to the right and center vertically,
because they are on the right side of this
bottom app bar.
And I'm going to set this to instead of left
and top left and center it vertically on the
axis.
So that way, when I resize this, the back
the elements are, are vertically staying proportional
in size, with the background, so it's all
balanced, the icons are horizontally, proportionate,
the sizing is there, and then vertically,
it will stay proportionate as well as it scales
in height.
And then we have this one action button.
The specs are all good, because we already
built this component.
And since it's part of our library, we just
use the assets panel and drag it in build
the component, which is super convenient.
And we know that it's a part of this component,
because I'm actually clicking on the parent
layer, holding down Command Shift H and hiding
everything.
So everything that's hiding is associated
with the parent layer selected, which lets
me know that this is an icon that I want.
I mean, the component I want and it's layered
accordingly.
And again, these should all actually be icons.
So what I can do is copy these go to my material
design system, I can paste them in my system
as needed.
I'm and then I can just apply this generic
default color as the fill, so I can type in
gray one.
If you needed to long story short, this should
just be set to I could just set it to that.
And what I'm essentially trying to get at
is making sure that these are all main components,
individually, publishing that to this library,
can see I've added these three new icons click
publish, I'll organize them later.
And we're going to actually swap those out.
With these, these components, I'm gonna show
you a trick here.
So if I go ahead and type search, there's
my search icon.
And if I hold down, up, if I go ahead and
make all of these components, create multiple
components.
And I go to my assets panel again, drag this
Hold OPTION command, it should swap it in
place, but it's not.
So we'll go ahead and manually do that my
apologies.
So just grabbing all these icons here.
And then once we have everything, we'll go
ahead and drag these into the canvas and do
the same exact operation.
Once these have all been swapped, we would
be good to go.
Okay, so now that that's all done, just apply
the proper colors again, set the content on
surface and we're good to go.
So now we just need to name this layer accordingly.
It is it falls under the app bars category.
So there's a couple of categories here at
bars, space slash space and then it falls
under the bottom category of app bar.
And this is the app bar with a floating action
button, the bottom app bar with a floating
action button that is centered.
So once that is done, we are good to go, we
can even apply constraints here to the right.
So that always stays centered.
Or actually, we want that to center horizontally.
So it'll always stay center when we stretch
the width.
So now we have the width stretching, what
we need to do is apply the constraints again
to right and center vertically, and then left
and center vertically.
So now, when this element selected, and it
stretches, it is stretching accordingly.
And generally, the height won't stretch, since
we have those specs set perfectly or properly.
And then when we adjust the width, everything
constraints accordingly, as if it were an
app responsive layout.
So we can go ahead and make this a main component.
That's good to go.
Now, I'm going to pause this video, and I
challenge you to make these two components
here, it's actually really easy.
Don't make them from scratch, just duplicate
this layer, and detach the instance and then
start removing and adding what's necessary
for these two variants.
And I'll be right back.
Okay, so now that I've created these, one,
a couple things to point out is that you already
have this in the exercise file, so you can
check these and get up to speed or and just
pay attention to the constraints.
If you build it from scratch.
Notice that this floating action buttons constraints
at the top and right so it'll move accordingly.
And then these are set to left and center
vertically on this, all these icons on the
left here these actions so that they are constrained
proportionally.
And then we have the bottom app bar with no
floating action button.
And we'll want to ensure that the constraints
are set properly.
So for example, if I click on this set of
icons here, and set those to right and center,
those will scale accordingly, horizontally
and vertically.
As well as this, this menu or hamburger menu
actions.
So those are the two I hope you enjoyed building
by yourself.
And last but not least, we'll go ahead and
build out the bottom app bar with a floating
action button that has the center cut.
So it has this round cut in the middle of
the background.
And that's actually really easy to replicate,
all we have to do is create an ellipse that's
set to 72 by 72.
Once that's once you specify those settings,
ensure that it has the right background color,
so surfaces on background but not for the
stroke whoops, so that for the background
itself of the fill.
And then what I did was I just ensured that
I created a proper rectangle for the background
color, which was set to primary.
And I set the proper dimensions to the width
of an Android device and the proper height
of this bottom app bar.
And what I did was I just grouped them.
And since they're grouped, and this is overlaid
above, what we can do is utilize the subtract
selection.
So when I click subtract, it will create the
proper spacing here.
And the reason this ellipse is set to 72 is
because it provides that eight pixel padding
all the way around this white space right
here, the swipe space is eight pixels all
the way around.
And so when we go ahead and build this, now
I have this background.
And I already have, what I did was I duplicated
this component here and just attached it,
it almost has all the same icons, except for
the heart, which will swap later.
Well, I can go ahead and do is remove the
bill and actually add in a rectangle because
we have the background color applied to the
frame.
But in this scenario, we can actually apply
that subtract selection to the frame.
So what we're going to go ahead and do is
add this into the parent layer.
So now it's a part of that frame, I can just
go ahead and hit option A and W to snap option
s Whoops, I need to undo real quick, I need
to select my background.
Center, I'm gonna leave all that center cut
background.
And I'm gonna hold down Command left bracket
and that'll push all the way down to the bottom
and hit option s and option W and that will
snap it accordingly.
And I now have the achieved look as needed.
And we can go ahead and double check that
set the pixels which it is the width is set
to eight.
So that is awesome.
We have the proper spacing set all the way
around.
And that is how we create our center cut floating
action with the floating action button for
our bottom app bar.
And just ensure that all of this is grouped
properly, ensure that this spacing is correct.
And our can straights are applied properly.
And you'll notice that that background now
needs to have constraints set properly.
So if I go ahead and stretch this now, it
will maintain that spacing.
But with that center cut, it will be much
easier for you to communicate in development,
what is actually going on with that background.
So, that is something important to note, what
we can do is, since this is a selection, we
can make sure that centered horizontally and
slick that rectangle mixture that's stretches
to the left and right at all time.
So now, when we go ahead and move this around,
it will actually move in alignment with the
floating action button, which is awesome.
And now that that is done, we have just, all
we need to do is name this properly.
So rename that fab center cut, and make that
a main component.
And we're good to go folks, everything's scaling
properly, we just need to add that heart icon,
we can go ahead and check that to see if we
actually have that inner library, I don't.
But again, we can just use the material design
tool, icons, tool, materials, icons tool.
And it's as simple as just typing in heart,
I can go ahead and click that you already
have this in your finder accessible.
So with that, I'm going to go open up figma,
open up my Finder.
And we have that favorite, I'm going to add
this to my icon library could have my icons
over here.
And I'll organize this later with that favorite,
they're going to make that a main component,
publish.
And actually, since I didn't, if I type in
favorite, actually already have this in the
library, my apologies.
So I have the favorite icon.
I'm gonna drag it in there, detach style,
add the new on surface, content style content
on primary, drag this into my component here,
make sure it's vertically centered shift click
and you smart selection to swap them quickly.
And I have now replicated this exact screenshot.
So we can go ahead and now organize all these.
So with that said, I'm just going to organize
all these components and pause this video.
organized everything I am good to go.
I hope you enjoyed watching this video and
understanding constraints more and again,
later on in the auto layout section of this
course, we will actually implement auto layout
on the components as necessary.
And I'll show you how to define and figure
that out.
We're gonna be talking about how to build
out the top app bar component variants.
So we'll have two of these in to be specific.
And if we go ahead and click on the exercise
file, here, we have the access to the documentation
if you open that link, and once you open that
link, and you'll notice that I'm already there.
And what this is used for is providing content
actions related to the current screen, and
also a great moment for utilizing your branding,
screen titles navigation actions, which can
then transform into a contextual action bar,
which is just another set of actions.
Based on what you're interacting on.
In that screen.
Pan, there's two types of AP bars we're going
to be creating.
And we're not going to build these from scratch,
we're actually going to reference what we
have already created, which are the bottom
app bar buttons.
And we can go ahead and end this exercise
file.
If you save it, you can go ahead and I publish
this already.
And if you grab this exercise file, you will
have to enable the material design system
library once more.
And once you have that enabled, we can go
ahead and just search for app bars.
And we have all the app bars.
So we can go ahead and be a little more specific
about what type of app bar we need.
We clearly need the bottom app bar with no
floating action buttons.
And now that we have this, we have all the
proper color styles as this puts us ahead
I'm just going to detach this style.
I've detached this instance My apologies I
attached it from the main component.
And what we have is a great starting point.
And we have the page title here.
And we got all the specs.
So this menu is set at 24 pixels in the left,
the height of this is set to 56.
And you'll notice that there's also this little
top portion what this is referencing is the
system UI bar and We won't need to design
for that that is solely a placeholder in this
screenshot.
So when we when engineers actually build this
out, these components will just be snapped
to the top, just below the system UI bar.
So ignore that, which is why the specs are
specified here 256, and not taking into consideration
the height of the system, UI bar, just for
some context there.
And we got three icons here, got that more
vertical icon, the search icon, this Share
icon, I believe it is the title, this the
page title, and then we got the Menu icon.
So I can go ahead and delete that fourth icon
because we're not going to need it.
And I'm going to rename this.
So I don't get confused, because this is another
set of app bars.
But instead of being on the bottom, it's on
the top, and we're creating the regular, we're
just going to label this regular, as we already
know, this is the regular top app bar.
And with that being said, we need to go ahead
and grab the prop the page style, understand
what textile that's using, and we're going
to just type in page obscures me, page title,
add the proper style.
So if I go ahead and select headers, we have
variation of headers and subtitles.
And we probably going to have to reference
the documentation, I'm gonna go ahead and
click on the fill, apply the on primary content
color, ensure that the resizing is set to
auto width there, and vertically align that
to the canvas, I don't have the right color,
style, or font style.
So I'm going to reference the documentation
to find that exact font size of the typography
here to gain a Joe, get a general idea of
what that is, you'll notice if you pay close
attention is that this type Pog Rafi is smaller.
And in this extended top app bar variant,
it is a little bigger.
So with that being said, we need to do some
snooping.
And there we have it, we have our category,
the font size is set to h six in that scenario.
We have the typography referenced again, stating
that it's set to h six, h six right there,
there's a bunch of examples.
It's again, giving us the example of the H
six.
So that is very important.
Now that we have that we can go ahead and
just we have this as a color style.
So I can go ahead and just select that, go
to our textiles and select h six.
So we have our h6 here.
And we'll go ahead and center this.
And this is set to 30 pixels to the left of
this menu bar icon.
So now that's set to 32.
And we have it set to 16.
On the left, I believe it's set to 24 currently,
so I'm going to shift click on the text and
the I'm going to click on this shift click
on the menu icon, move this over one, I have
my nudge amount and my preferences set to
eight on the small nudge and one on the big
nudge.
So I can just quickly move things by increments
of eight efficient effectively, as those are
the measurement principles of this material
design system.
So now I have that page title set right here.
And I'm just going to focus on the alignment
here, make sure that padding to the right
set to 16.
And the spacing between the icons is 24, which
it is.
So if I go ahead and check that set to 24.
And I select these it's set to 16.
On the right, the padding, the constraints
are good to go, I can go ahead and apply the
proper constraints to this typography by setting
the vertical axis to center.
And this icon already has left and center.
So we're good to go.
So if I were to scale this, it would all maintain
its position or as the height increases, it
would maintain that position on the y axis.
So we have this variant built out.
The only thing missing are the proper icons,
which you can go ahead and add yourself.
I'm going to pause this and add them.
So I've identified all the proper icons.
And I was missing one icon it was the share
icon which falls under the actions category.
So I just went to the material design icons
tool, typed in share and I found it and I
clicked on it saved it as an SVG, I saved
you that step by just giving that to you in
the exercise files.
So you can drag that into your canvas and
figma publish it to your material design system
library, which is exactly what I did.
I just published it, added it here made it
a main component, published it and once I
published it i was i since I have that library
enabled in this exercise file, I was able
to pull it from the assets panel here, and
then I just swapped those accordingly.
So now that all those specs are good to go,
you could double check the spacing and whatnot
if you needed to and ensure the constraints
are set properly.
And now we can go ahead and just check our
layer, and it's labeled correctly.
And I'm going to make this a main component.
So now that this is a whoops, I'm going to
select the top parent frame, and make that
a main component, we now have our main component.
Once that's there, we can go ahead and even
duplicate this.
And with that duplicated, I'm gonna detach
it.
And we're going to specify the height of this
element to be set to 128.
But before I do that, I'm gonna intentionally
set some constraints.
So the constraints are going to be applied
to all the icons.
So I'm going to Command click on all these
icons, which allows you to click these individually
and maintain selection of the previous icon.
So I have all these selected, and I'm going
to set this to top, because I don't want these
to move when I set the height.
And what I'm gonna do is set this to bottom,
and I'm gonna shift click on this constraint
to remove it and make sure that text is set
to bottom.
So what's going to happen is that, when I
change the height of this element, the icons
stick to the top, and the text will stick
to the bottom.
So I'm going to change the height to 128.
And it did exactly that.
So now that that has been created, what I
want to do is ensure that the baseline spacing
is set accordingly.
And you can see that they're specifying the
baseline of the text, which is different from
the bounding box of the text, it's set to
28 pixels.
And we can easily do that by hitting shift
our adding a red line to the baseline of the
typography.
And holding, we can hold down Option here,
we can click the text, it's set to 16 here,
but if we go ahead and create a textbox will
notice that the height of this is set to 21.
So what we also need to ensure is that we're
using the right text style for this extended
top app bar.
So how do we do that, let's go ahead and reference
our documentation on the top app bar.
And you'll notice that the typography just
reference that this was an H six.
If we scroll down some more, this headline
is an H six.
But what about the extended top app bar, it's
different, it's a different font.
So we can go ahead and Google top app bar
text size.
So we can go ahead and continue to figure
out what the size of the typography is by
just Google searching, if you ever confused
but if not actually going to open that page
up again, once that's open, we might want
to be able to access the developer guidelines
and kind of snoop around there.
And it'll give us access to the code.
But what we want is access to this here.
And understanding the topography.
So the text appearance, and we're just reading
some properties here.
And what we really want to do is understand
the textile being applied.
So I'm gonna pause this and look for that
value.
So I was not able to identify the actual title
by by snooping through this typography, or
at least the print the code here, don't get
confused.
Again, this practice I just went through this
little exercise of searching for a specific
attribute is a common practice, I'd recommend
for you to start understanding because it
will really help you try to dissect and understand
how to identify certain elements of a design
by going through different sets of documentation,
which is a great skill to have, and will improve
your implementation of design as you can better
articulate it to developers, as well as you
continue to dive deeper into these types of
Google searches and trying to understand how
it's implemented.
So I kind of just referenced the developer
documentation and access that component page
where it talks about top app bars.
And I'm kind of looking through the structure
of this code.
So androids written in this format called
XML.
That's the language in which they write their
they write their code, or for the UI implementing
implementing their UI.
And I'm looking at the prominent top app bar.
And with that prominent top app bar, I'm going
and scrolling down and I found a set of properties
that were communicated.
And it talks about the title attributes that
they use.
So I went ahead and was looking for the top
app bar, anything related to the top app bar
attribute to see if I can then identify the
size.
So there's a bunch of other settings here
as well, that are communicated.
But specifically, we're looking for the type
title attributes.
So that utilizes a title.
And the material toolbar title is set to an
age six, which we've specified.
And then the material subtitle is set to subtitle
one, and they also have a collapse title variant.
And then they also have an expanded title,
as you can see here, but we're gonna go ahead
and just maintain the title we currently have.
Again, if you know what that style is, do,
please do go ahead and refine that.
So I'm going to go ahead and just I'm going
to change that to subtitle since that is the
one I was trying to identify.
And if we go ahead and ensure that the baseline
set to 28, we should be good to go.
So I'm gonna increase this rectangle to 28
pixels, push this slightly up, so the baseline
is aligned now.
So when I do my red lines, the baseline of
the topography is now 28 pixels away from
the bottom, which is what is specified in
the extended top app bar, right here, 28 pixels,
this green horizontal line.
So now we are good to go.
And all of the spacing is correct already
on the icons above.
And we just set constraints so that it would
stay that way.
So with that page title set there, I'm going
to make sure that the constraint set to left
as well.
So when we type in a new title, we're good
to go.
And with that said, I'm just going to ensure
that my spacing is set to on the left is set
accordingly.
So it's set to 72.
We're good to go.
And we're going to go ahead and name this
extended, because it's our extended top app
bar variant.
And now that all the constraints are set,
and we're good to go long, I'm going to go
ahead and make this a main component.
And you can go ahead and organize this in
this frame.
And that is how we build out the top app our
components.
Today, we're going to be making some backdrop
So we'll be building out the backdrop components
over viewing them first building them out
applying the proper constraints, and really
going to need to understand and consume these
components first.
So if we go ahead and click on the backdrop
documentation there, that'll open up in your
default browser.
And a backdrop appears behind all other surfaces
in an app displaying contextual and actionable
content.
And one thing no currently, as of the date
of this recording, September 10 2020, Thursday,
this is currently in beta.
Therefore, for developers referencing this.
Currently, there is no status around when
this will be developed for the following platforms
Android, iOS web and the flutter framework.
So that is important to note.
And also, the backdrop is composed of two
surfaces, right, so we have the back layer,
which is the the blue looking layer there,
right here, this top bar element, which is
what essentially looks like and then the front
layer, which is that has this white background
and utilizes a little bit of elevation, whether
you can see it or not.
And the back layer displays actions and context
and these control and inform the front layers
content.
So whatever is on the background dictates
the front layers content.
And that is important to note there.
And it also utilizes an optional divider under
the subtitle right there as we continue to
analyze this backdrop component.
And here's the anatomy breakdown of this backdrop
component.
It consists of a back layer, the front layer,
and an optional sub header and divider there
as you can see, and either the back layer
or the front layer can be active at a time.
So only one thing can be active, either the
back layer or the front layer.
And when the back layer is active, this this
front layer drops down, utilizing motion.
So here you can see that it's a fixed area,
or at least, that's an optional way to utilize
the sub header as a fixed area with content
to scroll through and whatnot.
And I highly recommend going through the rest
of this and reading it and understanding the
behavior.
Right here.
You can see that the front layer, as the back
layer just lies on the surface and the front
layer, utilize elevation, it's one dip on
the Z index.
one pixel on the Z index is also another way
to reference it on the web.
So that is important to note for our front
layer there.
And I've already grabbed these screenshots
for what, for designing the specs here, and
you'll notice that it utilizes some list items
in this example, which we'll go ahead and
kind of build.
So what we can do is go into figma here, what
these screenshots reference, we'll, we'll
go ahead and create this generic example.
Right, so we have is, we can search for app
bar in our system, make sure your library
is enabled the material design system library,
and then you can search for app bar, and we
have all these variants, right? So the variant
we're gonna want to use is more than likely
this one with page title, and you see that
it has these other actions as well.
And what I wanted to actually do is place
this on a parent frame, and that parent frame
is going to be the utilize the dimensions
of the Android phone.
So and I'm going to rename this Android phone.
So I'm gonna go ahead and drag this in here
and snap this to the top and left of the parent
frame.
So great, we have what we need to start.
And it also indicates that the background
set to blue still, so what we can do is add
a primary background color to represent that
in our example.
And Android, Android phone backdrop, I'm just
going to rename that real quick to be precise.
And what we can do is that this backdrop appears
all the way to the top of this, this frame
here.
So I'm going to go ahead and add a ruler here
in figma.
that aligns with this selection here.
Get that pixel perfect there.
And now with that ruler specified, I can go
ahead and create another frame.
And in this frame, is going to set the width
to I'm going to set this to surfaces surface,
the background color and the width to span
the entire body of the of the screen, which
is 360 dips, I'm going to snap this to the
top.
And I'm gonna go ahead and select independent
corners and ensure that the top and left are
set to 16 pixels rounded.
So we're achieving that same look here, as
you can see, right there, and it utilizes
a subtitle that has a baseline of 32 dips
from from the top of the front layer.
So I'm going to label this layer, this frame
front layer, because that is the background
and there's going to be some text that lives
within it.
And I'm going to ensure I have the proper
textile specified and that is sub title.
And I'm gonna ensure that the resizing set
to auto width.
To keep that clear and concise, I can snap
that to the top and left at 16 pixels 16 dips
to the left.
And I can push this down.
And what I want to do is ensure that the baseline
is set to 32 digits right there.
So I can go ahead and do is grab, whoops,
grab a rectangle, grab a rectangle, specify
32 tips there.
And then I'm going to push this content up
so that it aligns the baselines aligned.
And I can justify that double check with a
ruler.
And we are good to go.
That baseline is there.
And one thing this optionally utilizes is
a divider.
So we'll go ahead and add that from the get
go.
I'm gonna go ahead and searched for divider
in my assets.
And then I can go ahead and pull this divider
in from my system.
And the divider is approximately 12 pixels
12 dips down from the subtitle.
And what I'm going to want to do is I'm holding
option command and shrinking this so that
it's set to has a padding of 16 dips on the
left and right of this other sub header which
is reflective in in our examples up above,
as you can see here.
it aligns right there, that divider.
So that's great that that is consistent.
So now we have that and our textiles attached.
And everything looks good.
We're good to go.
We can do now is just specify this as our
bare bones layout because designers will then
go ahead and add in the actual The items necessary
to this component.
So we have this this front layer here, if
I go ahead and shrink this front layer expanded,
and we now have a canvas for designer start
adding content onto.
So that's super important to note.
So this in and of itself could be its very
own component, what I'm going to do is ensure
that this color style specified to active
with our high emphasis also known as high
emphasis, and ensure it has the proper elevation
set to one dip.
So we can slightly see that elevation being
utilized now.
And with this, I'm going to go ahead and make
this a main component as this is one variation
that designers could use this barebones layout,
copy it, and then start adding their own elements
on top of it, I can go ahead and specify the
constraints because right now when I stretch
it, this doesn't necessarily stick properly,
it's always nice to specify that.
So I got to set the constraints left and right,
so now when I stretch this, it will stretch
properly, the divider that is, so now we have
our front layer expanded, and you can kind
of see the elevation being utilized here.
One thing that might be kind of confusing
at first, creating this front layer that's
expanded is that it's a blank canvas, right,
so when a designer goes in and uses it, I'm
gonna align this here.
So when a designer goes and uses this, it
might be kind of misleading at first.
So because what a designer is going to need
to do is copy this.
Whoops, I'm going to kind of a swap, I put
the instance here.
But that's okay.
We can do is go ahead and move that master
now to this frame, front layer expanded.
So that's, so with that expanded, we can go
ahead and create the the concealed variant.
And what I was trying to get at first is designers
will copy that, copy this subtitle, and go
ahead and add other elements onto it.
So for example, the list items we created
in the last video, I can go ahead, maybe I
want to add into this component, right, I
just need to ensure the proper spacing is
specified.
So what I want to do is, I'm going to have
to wrap this into a frame, right.
So it's going to be my front front layer,
expanded with content, so you're gonna have
to wrap it into a frame, ensure that everything
is aligning accordingly.
And I'm going to stretch this out to span
the full width of this.
And then what you can do is, then just continue
to duplicate these items as needed.
So that's great, and ensure that clip content
is specified.
And with clip content specified, you now have
an example with content, just make sure that
the proper padding is set to the top there.
So we can go ahead and check that to see what
that padding specified to right here from
this list to the top of that divider.
And what we can do is always reference our
specs.
So with our specs referenced, it looks like
there's some spacing here.
It's not necessarily specified.
But we can go ahead and eyeball it roughly
looks like 24 pixels there.
And with that, we can go ahead and make sure
that's set to 24, which it almost is entirely,
I will just need to move this content down
one more pixel.
And we should be good to go.
There.
And we have our example.
So as you can see, if we look at this frame,
it wraps the front layer, which is the background
with all these list elements added on top
of it.
As there may be several scenarios and how
you want to use the the expanded front layer,
you may want to add other type of content
onto this expanded front layer on this backdrop.
So we'll give you the bare bones layout and
give you the freedom to add stuff on top of
it.
And you can just do that by grouping and as
a frame of that content.
And we'll go ahead and go check out the the
concealed version and the concealed version
refers to this, this front layer now being
minimized, which is what I mean by concealed
Material Design calls it concealed and the
whole This is set to, let's see 48.
So the height set to 48, we can go ahead and
specify that here and snap that to the bottom,
we now have that set to 48.
And I'm still using the same version I just
stripped it.
So I'm going to do is detach this and label
this front layer concealed.
Remove that top constraint, set that to bottom
left and right.
So that stretches respectively.
And there won't be a need for divider in this
in this version, what there will need to be
is an action, which is that carrot and I have
one of those here, the up arrow, up keyboard
arrow, so I'm going to select that paste it
and sure that that is centered here centered.
And we have the padding set to 16 dips on
the right, so we're good to go, we now have
our concealed front layer variant, I'm gonna
go ahead and make that a main component.
And duplicate this, grab the main component
and drag it into our our canvas there.
And it's still utilizing the the one dip elevation.
So that's important to note.
And we can even throw it in as it's, as you
can see, it's now an example here.
And what we haven't specified here is the
content for this.
So I'm just renaming that.
And essentially what you could do is create
add whatever content you need here.
So when this is concealed, there, the backdrop,
the back layers being utilized.
So if we go ahead and pay attention to Material
Design documentation again.
And we look at the anatomy of this backdrop,
it has that back layer, right.
And the backdrop has a has the original actions.
And the front layer has actions respective
to the actions on this back layer.
So we're going to we can go ahead and make
examples here.
So we can go ahead and create these list items
I can, I'm going to go ahead and pull.
I'm going to go ahead and change.
Let's see this to app name.
And I'm going to hide these icons here.
And I can even go ahead and swap out this
icon to an X.
So I could find that exit icon.
Or better yet, it's probably labeled close.
Here we have that close icon.
And we want to double check to see if we already
have that here, which we do.
So it's actually called clear.
So I'm going to look for clear here, my material
design library.
And I'm going to drag this here and hold down
Option command and hover over this icon and
it'll swap it.
And I'll change that to the the active on
primary color, since this is on the primary
surface there.
And we're good to go to remove this hidden
or turned off filler.
So we have that specified.
And what we want to go ahead and do now is
we can bring in some some list items here,
we can bring in the list item that utilizes
a icon, this one line variant, right.
And what we can even do is remove the background,
we can change the color of the text to a content
on primary surface.
And now we have the ability to to we have
the ability now to make push this content
up a couple.
So now this directly snaps to the top app
bar.
And we have the ability to swap the icons
now.
So instead of using that placeholder, we can
use for example male, I can go ahead and swap
that icon in here.
Add the proper color to on primary.
And as you can see we have our items now.
And I want to actually make sure that that
state is set to inactive My apologies.
So that would be the the it should be utilizing
the medium emphasis which isn't a color style
right now which we can go ahead and specify
in our library.
So if we if we detach the style and hit 68
there, we now have our media emphasis color
style.
So if I go ahead and specify that content
on primary, medium emphasis that could be
our new color style there, which would be
associated with the others.
And long story short, now that we have this
created, we need to change the height of this
list item to 40.
So you're noticing how I'm starting to combine
elements in our design system to to be utilized
on top of other components such as these backdrops,
which are like, which you can think of as
these base layers, right.
So I'm gonna go ahead and just continue to
duplicate this and we have now replicated
our, our backdrop with the concealed front
layer.
So this front layer is concealed there, we
can even go ahead and make this a component
as well.
Because more often than not, designers may
be using this and if we make this a component,
designers can go ahead and just swap these
elements as needed and rename the text I these
list items and whatnot, as mess deem necessary.
So or we can give them the we can also offer
we can offer both variants essentially right
so we have the, the front layer conceal which
they can just drag and drop onto onto a design
as needed or we can give them this whole this
whole example which I'm going to go ahead
and create.
So I'm going to I'm going to rename this so
concealed, concealed.
I'm going to label this as concealed and then
this is just the front layer concealed.
So now that that is good to go, it is a master
component, and we are good to go and that
is how you build out the backdrop variants
for material design.
Today we're going to be building out banner
components.
And the only further ado, the overviews is
going to be discussing how to use these components
by checking out the documentation.
And then we'll be creating them ourselves,
applying the proper naming convention, and
even adding the proper constraints and maybe
a little bit of auto layout, but will actually
save that auto layout and in depth video on
auto layout, for the next section of the course
will recover auto layout for all the components
we've created in this section of the course.
But with constraints, the only difference
will be that the components already made and
we'll be implementing auto layout on them
in the next section of the course.
So without any further ado, let's check out
this banner documentation resource and once
that opens in your browser, go ahead and click
on that will check box doesn't show up again
for this website, as you'll be checking it
out frequently.
And here you can see that our got I got this
little too zoomed in.
Whoops.
And with that, banners display opponent message
and related optional actions.
So here we have that prominent prominent message
appearing at the top and then we have related
optional actions to take based upon what is
said in that prominent message.
And you can go ahead and understand the usage
here.
And it also discusses similar similar components,
and based on the priority of the message being
conveyed conveyed, you can utilize a certain
type of components.
So for banners, typically when there is a
prominent or our medium level type of priority
based on the level of severity, if that priority
is prominent or medium, it is typically you
typically use a banner, and they will banners
remain until dismiss by the user or if the
state that caused the banner is resolved.
And there's some differences described here
with snack bars, and then the dialog component
as well.
And banner displays importance.
Importance succinct message and provides actions
for users to address or dismiss that banner
requires a user action to be dismissed.
And they should be displayed at the top of
the screen below the top app bar.
And they are persistent and non modal, allowing
the user to either ignore them or interact
with them at any time, only one banner should
be shown at the time.
Here are some principles and the anatomy of
one of the most complex banner.
As you can see, the most complex banner has
a container with a supporting illustration,
which you can also reference as the leading
icon or an informative icon.
Those are also common terms used.
So the supporting illustration.
And then here we have that container in encapsulating
all of these elements in this design, and
then we have the text, of course.
And then we have the buttons are optional,
I mean our supporting actions.
And here are some examples of how to use it
and how to not use it, only one banner should
be shown at a time, any banner appears above
content and below that bar.
So here's the content right here below those
images, the collection of those images.
And then here we have the top app bar, and
it fits right in between.
So you can always you can think of it as always
below the top app bar is where it would appear.
And here's some more usages I recommend you
going through to really understand the placement
and behavior is that is very important.
And then I have these screenshots on the specs
on how to implement this.
And we'll go ahead and reference the textile
that we need.
And the textile we need, as you can see here
is the body to textile.
And we'll go ahead and go into figma now and
start building these out.
And the first thing we're going to want to
do is enable our material design system.
So to start pulling in certain components
that we've already built, so we built this
text button.
And with that said, let's go ahead and build
that.
So we have a frame.
And in this exercise file, I've already created
the the naming convention on how we want to
categorize these banners.
As you can see, there are mobile and desktop
berets.
So we'll go ahead and create all these, I'm
going to go ahead and create a, a one or two
in each section.
And then I'll pause the video and have you
test your skills and build them out by yourself
in a systematized manner.
So utilizing as many of the assets we've created
already in our material design system here.
So without further ado, let's get started.
So we have this mobile variant, right, so
we have the text and the action inline, meaning
that they're both on the same level.
They're not stacked on top of each other.
They're horizontally in line, right, they're
both on the same axis, the x axis was just
horizontal.
And what that said, we can go ahead and just
create a frame and I'm going to rename this
and since I've copied that naming convention
in that, in that file, my layer will now be
labeled it live under the mobile category
as a one line list, which has a text and action,
and it is in line, it's not stacked.
This is stacked.
But this is a two line example.
As you can see with the tech stack, the text
is above those actions.
And what we're going to need first off is
our text button.
So we just type in text, we can find that
text button there.
And our assets panel, we can drag that in
here, we can go ahead and re name this to
action.
And you'll notice that we already have auto
layout applied to this button.
So we're not to manually resize it, which
is very convenient.
And we'll leave that off to the side for now.
And let's justify the width here, set that
to 360, which adheres to mobile principles
for Android as material design was created
for Android in the beginning.
So with that specified, let's go ahead and
specify the height to fit four pixels.
Now that we have the height specified, one
thing we will also need later on is the divider.
So if I go in my assets panel and look for
the divider that we've already created, I
can drag that in here, and we already have
the width specified, and it has the proper
color style that we need, I can just remove,
I'm gonna go to the main component real quick
and detach this unnecessary turned off textile,
fill style, fill color.
And I'm gonna go ahead and publish this.
And we'll be good to go.
Add real variance.
So, so now that that's published, and it's
successfully published, I can go ahead and
update the component here, as you can see,
it's now updated, doesn't contain that, that
background layer that fill, because it's unnecessary,
we utilize a stroke here.
And we can just go ahead and as you if you
pay attention closely to the designs, you
may or may not need this banner, to have a
divider, as you can see, there's a divider
being communicated right there between the
content and the top that bar right there.
So just keep that in mind.
And what we can do is we can offer this, and
then designers can copy this component and
then turn it off if if need be.
So we can offer that.
So I'm gonna, that's the first thing I'm going
to add to all of them, I've just snapped that
to the bottom of this frame, by holding down
Command S, option s skews me, since that is
a child element of the parent frame, I can
easily snap this as needed to the top or the
bottom.
So now that I have that set there, I'm gonna
set the constraints are bottom left and right.
So that way, if this were to ever be stretched,
that divider will will stretch with.
But we have this defined here, and we won't
really need to, we won't need to modify that
as we are developing the system for Android
in this scenario.
So with that said, I'm gonna go ahead and
drag in this button here snapped to the left,
and it's eight pixels from the right and it
is centered vertically on the y axis here.
So that is set accordingly.
And then I'm going to add the constraint to
the right of the parent frame to the constraint
will stick to the right of its parent frame
and then it will be centered vertically.
So whenever it is stretched, it will always
stay center in relation to the height either
decreasing or increasing.
And then we'll go ahead and specify the text.
So the text again is using, we're going to
add color style here first text and iconography
and use the high emphasis text color style.
And then we'll go ahead and specify body to
for this typography.
And then if we just type in one line, just
mimic what is written there, and that spec
one line string with one action websi can't
type here with one action, we should be good
to go.
So with that specified, I'm gonna go ahead
and center this here, snap this to the left
with my shortcut key option A and option B
to center vertically.
And I'm gonna move this over to 16.
So the padding is set to 16 dips, right there,
and that is center.
And with that centered, our content is good
to go.
And you can see that material design specifies
that the textbox is specifically 30 has a
spacing of 36 pixels right here.
So what we can do is we right now it's set
to 48.
From the text button itself, that so we can
go ahead and hold down Command and stretch
out that text box to be set to so the spacing
is set to 36.
So now it's set to 36.
Here, the spacing we're going to need to do
to ensure that that is fixed is that we can
go ahead with constraints and set this to
left and right.
So those constraints are maintained if this
were to ever be stretched, and we don't necessarily
have to worry about that right now.
I'm going to set the typography also to be
centered vertically on the y axis so that
is in alignment with the action that is in
line to the right of it.
So if designers ever have a need for expanding
this, that won't mess up their designs.
So with that specify we are good to go.
I'm not showing you autolab because I will
show you that in the next section of the course,
that will that will be its own focus, where
you will master that I really want you to
understand the concepts of constraints in
this section of the course.
And just the the general construction of these
components, as well as adding autolayout into
the mix can can be very taxing confusing,
on top of all of this dense knowledge you're
learning currently.
So with this, all with the typography all
specified and attached to their proper color
styles and everything utilizing instances,
we now need to go into the background of this
frame and specify the color.
So the color is utilizing is the surface background,
we can specify that as surface surface or
surface background there was that that to
surface surface surfaces surface, there we
go, as that as the surface that is overlaid
on top of the background, it's not the initial
background for the entire page, it's just
the the surface for that for that banner component.
So now that we've created this, we're going
to go ahead and duplicate it.
And then we're gonna make this a component.
So a main component, now we have our main
component, we have our first parent created.
And let's go ahead and build out the this
two line variant with actions.
So one thing to note is that we have to probably
modify the line height of our text elements,
because in the beginning when I created these
textiles in our system, which I did intentionally
for us to modify, and pay attention to, to
the line height of our typography, to ensure
that it's done correctly, because if it's
not done correctly, the spacing of our typography
will be off in in components that are to line
variants and whatnot.
So let's go ahead and create when I move this
screenshot over, create a new one.
So I'm going to go ahead and copy this, that
naming convention.
And when it grab, I'm going to create this
from scratch a new frame, set to a width of
360 and a height of 112.
Then I'm gonna paste in the naming convention,
we have the mobile version of the two line
with text and actions, banner variant, which
is great.
And now this uses a textile body to but I'm
going to go ahead and copy this, this action
button, paste it and hold down Option s, option
D, and that'll snap to the bottom and right
and then move that up until the padding is
set to eight on the bottom.
And right.
Now I'm going to duplicate this and ensure
that padding is set to eight there to the
right from that element.
And we have both of these elements here sticking
to the right.
And we want them to stick to the bottom as
well of this component.
So if it were ever to be stretched out, it
would stick to that bottom and right spacing
respectively respective of its parent, which
is the background.
And while we're at it, let's go ahead and
change the fill to surfaces surface that background
color.
And now we got to go in and just justify the
proper spacing for how our typography will
fit.
So I'm gonna create this text box here, select
the body to color style.
And then I'm going to just kind of mimic what
is in.
In this component, the text in that component.
One to two lines is favorable on mobile, and
tablet.
Okay, great.
So we have the text we need.
Now we need to kind of specify a couple of
things.
So what we need to specify is that the baseline
of the first line of text in this two line
text is set to 36 dips, and this padding left
is set to 16.
As well as the padding on the right is set
to we can say 16 here in this scenario.
So let's go ahead and snap that to the left
there, push this content down slightly.
So we got that set to 16.
And I'm gonna go ahead and push this over
and sure that that's set to 16.
On the right there, set the constraint to
left and right and the top and bottom.
And then we're going to need to justify the
spacing here between these buttons and the
text there, which is where we'll start to
modify the line height potentially.
So let's go ahead and pull out our rulers
here, shift R, and then I'm going to create
a 36 pixel high rectangle to just reference
where the baseline needs to be for this text.
So I'm going to push this content down And
essentially, it is right now currently stated
that the text box has a padding on the top
of 22 dips to achieve that three, six, dip
baseline there from the top.
As you can see, and with that, we can even
adjust this text box to ensure that it does
not overlap or interfere with the actions
below it.
And it showcases that there's a spacing of
12 pixels from the baseline to the top of
the button.
So let's go ahead and double check that.
And if that isn't the case, that is an indication
of potentially our line height being off on
the typestyle.
So go ahead and create this set that to 12,
we are very close, there was one pixel off
the baselines one pixel off.
So essentially what we could do is go into
our textile and modify that.
So it's set to 20.
So I go in and modify, go to the definition
style, modify it to 20.
And then publish that to my library, publish,
successfully published and then I can update
this, once I update it pay attention to the
text here dropping down one pixel, and it
actually dropped down more than one pixel.
So I'm gonna go ahead and undo that style.
And reference my body to textile, ensure that
that's there, I'm going to republish that
change, and just ensure that that updates
again, so that stays there.
And I'm going to live with that just one pixel
off there, although I do think it's correct.
Um, and with that, achieved, look and feel
and you have all the spacing set properly.
And that proper color style on the text, with
the high emphasis textile applied, we should
be good to go.
So all like I can even hide my rulers or just
remove them specifically from this layer,
one thing we are missing is a divider.
So I'm going to copy this divider here, and
then paste it and then hit option s and that
will snap to the bottom of this element.
And it has this has the constraints from the
previous component we built.
And then once I've built that out, we can
test the constraints there.
And you'll notice that the constraints are
maintained and that spacing when I stretch
out this element, and the divider sticks to
where it needs to be.
And once I'm satisfied with the responsiveness
of this component, I am good to go.
If you want to really be clear, concise, you
can create the reordered the the elements
in your component, which is a great thing
to do is that will be easier to consume the
components.
And I'm gonna go ahead and make this a, we
can make that a master component, I'm going
to duplicate it and pause this video and build
out the the third variant for the mobile version.
So what you can do is modify this as needed,
you can drag in a placeholder icon.
So we can type in placeholder.
And we have that placeholder.
And we can round out the edges.
So you could now that we have that round icon,
and you have a you know a head start there,
and a clue.
So I'll be right back.
Now created that third variant, I just had
to increase the height to 120.
Add in that 40 by 40 dip icon, set that padding
perspective in relation to what is indicated
in the spec here.
And I kind of just it was very simple and
straightforward.
Nothing, nothing difficult there, I just ensure
I have those right constraints set.
And I and you should be good to go.
And with that said, I'm going to go ahead
and make this a main component.
And we're going to go ahead and create the
desktop version.
So with this one line variant here, we can
go ahead and specify the height and I just
duplicated, this first version that we created
on mobile because it's essentially the same
exact thing.
But for desktop, the width is specified at
a much larger, it's much larger the width
there.
And what we can do is set that width to 720.
Now, and the nice thing about this is our
constraints will adapt accordingly.
So still have that spacing there needed.
So the texts can fill up a good majority of
this message here, and we have the divider
there for designers to utilize if need be
to really make that message Such distinct.
And our typography properties stay the same
or action still there with the same spacing
on those elements, it's just that the width
is now change.
And I need to change this to the naming convention
of this component as well.
So it's desktop.
It's a one line, text and action in line for
the desktop area, so I can go ahead and just
change that to desktop, there's rename that,
and we are good to go.
So with that, go ahead and make that a main
component.
And we'll create the other one from scratch,
here, so we have, we don't, the width for
this three line element looks like it may
be set to 80 pixels, it's not actually giving
me that specified height, we're just going
to throw them out.
So I'm going to reference that documentation
again.
Yeah, it's cut off, it's hard to read, but
I'm gonna, I'm pretty sure it's at as that
is divisible by eight.
So for this three line list, let's go ahead
and create a new frame.
And click, apply the proper surfaces surface
color stuff in the background, I'm gonna go
ahead and grab this naming convention they're
in well organized and publish these components.
So I've got that naming convention set.
And I'm gonna go ahead and specify the width
to 720.
And grab a divider, as that will grab up,
put up, get all the generic things out of
the way, specify that width to 720.
Set the constraints bottom left and right,
that just use my shortcut keys to snap it
to the very bottom, as you can see here.
And that's good to go.
And we just need to double check the height
here, set that to 80.
And that divider still sticks stays there
as need be.
And we can go ahead and add these two actions,
get those out of the way.
So I'm going to copy this text button, paste
it, snap it to the bottom and right and then
move it up.
So the padding on the bottom right set to
eight, duplicate this and ensure that that
is eight pixels away from the button to the
right, apply the proper constraints here.
And we should be good to go the action buttons.
Now we just needed to find our three line
list of our three line text string.
So I'm gonna go ahead and create that select
the body to textile.
And what we need, I'm going to go ahead and
pause this video, copy this text real quick.
I wrote out the exact word for word, banner
message here.
And I use the right textile.
And I need to actually hold down Command and
ensure that this textile is wrapping the entirety
of this message and then vertically center
it and then check the spacing on the left
here set to 24 dips.
So I have 25 right now push that over one
dip, and we're good to go.
And the spacing between here and here.
And the and the text box is 90 dips.
So what I can do is stretch this out so that
it's set to 90.
Right now I have 90 to push that over a couple.
That's not what 94 so now I've moved that
over, it's set to 90.
Now we have that spacing of 90 between the
text bounding box and the actions which is
super important.
So now that we have that we're good to go,
we've now defined that.
And I'm gonna go ahead and create this component.
And I'm going to challenge you to building
out this last desktop banner message by yourself.
So just follow those specs, the height here
says 72, just because that's cut off into
that might be difficult.
And then the baseline of this text here is
20 pixels from the bottom, but just it's actually
just eight.
So same specs as we've been doing here for
those actual buttons.
Anyways, I'm gonna pause the video and make
this and I hope you enjoyed this exercise.
Now created that third desktop variant for
the banner message and we are good to go.
So now we have this component that designers
can now go ahead and duplicate and then start
replacing the imagery as needed for the icon
placeholder modifying the typography with
the proper text bounding box.
Apply specified there for this component and
then also the proper placement for these buttons
as well to Add and modify the text which is
great.
Today we're going to be going over building
out the bottom navigation and there are only
two variants on the bottom navigation and
it is the portrait version and the landscape.
version for the, we're going to be designing
that for the Android based format.
And we have the resource to the documentation,
so you can open up that link.
And if we go ahead and click on it, clearly
at the bottom navigation allows movement between
primary destinations and an application.
This is crucial and very common.
And it's used in every application, whether
you're using Facebook mobile on your phone,
whether it's iOS, or Android, or you're using
YouTube, or you're using some sort of Google
application within the Google suite.
And I highly recommend you just reading through
all the contents, just like every other video
to really understand in depth what these components
do everything associated with those elements,
and also the research behind that.
And also understanding the states and how
you interact with this.
So in figma, I've taken screenshots of the
specs.
And one thing to note that's very important
is that the minimum width of the container
for each button is set to 80 dips, and the
maximum width is set to 168 dips in width.
So you'll notice that they're both utilizing
the the minimum width specified here, 80,
dips wide.
And on the portrait version, portrait being
if we create a frame, and I go ahead and select
Android, I now have my android version.
So I'm just going to type in, I'm going to
label this properly.
So I'm going to go ahead and type in bottom
navigation space slash base, portrait.
Once you've labeled that properly, I'm going
to also duplicate that and set this type in
landscape.
And once you specify landscape now that landscapes,
this is landscape, so we're gonna design for
landscape here.
And we're gonna go ahead and start by kicking
off this party by specifying the height of
this set to 56 pixels, and it has this bottom
app bar the elevation in the diagram, you
can look at it yourself to verify if you don't
believe me, but the elevation by default set
to eight dips.
So what you'll notice is that say I had another
frame here, and I detach that, and I just
went and re specified that this was the material
design sized frame.
And I went ahead and just Android just labeled
that Android portrait.
And you'll notice that this is the bottom
navigation set to portrait here, and that
the content is clipped.
Now because the parent frame has that checked,
you won't see the drop shadow on the other
sides.
So now we need to go ahead and start adding
in the content.
So what do we have we have these three icons
here, but those will live inside a specific
containers.
So these icons are set to 24 dips wide and
in height and are centered on the axis here.
So if I go ahead and select these three, I
can go ahead and ensure that these are horizontally
centered, and then space them accordingly.
And what you can do to ensure that is that
it's it's centered within 120 pixel frame
120 dip wide frame.
So what we can do if you're confused, is,
since this is 363 60 divided by three is 120
dips.
So all we have to do is wrap a frame around
each of these icons, set the width to 120
and the height to 56.
And what we want to do is I hit option W and
a to snap it to the top and left.
And then if I hit Enter, and hit option V
and H it will center that perfectly on the
screen.
And then we can do the same exact thing for
this one as well.
So I can actually detach that now that it's
centered, it's positioned with padding of
48 to the left and vertically on the y axis.
So all we got to do is wrap this in a frame,
set that to 120 pixels wide, and the height
to 56.
I'm going to hit option w so the snaps to
the top, and then I'm going to act going to
horizontally center this and then hit enter
and hit option D and H to center that within
this frame.
So you'll notice that this is 120 pixels wide
and so is the section to the left of it.
And what we can do is now that that's centered
it I can ungroup that frame.
And I could even apply just the spacing here,
just to double check.
Or I could wrap this in a frame.
Again, if you're not that confident want to
be extremely precise, set the width to 120,
the height to 56, and then hit option D, so
the snaps to the left hand, option W, so it
snaps to the top of the parent frame that
I'm going to enter.
Now I have my icon selected, hit option D,
and then H.
Now that is centered within the 120 dips wide
frame, and is 48 pixels away from the next
icon.
And I can ungroup that now my Layers panel,
and now everything is centered accordingly.
So now I have my icons properly centered in
the bottom navigation.
So one thing we're missing, of course, is
this typography.
So we can go ahead and reference the documentation
once more.
And it shows you that this type, we can check
the typography in the theming.
And it uses the caption style.
So with that caption being used, the the baseline
is 12 dips away from the bottom of the icon
frame, which is a great thing for us to reference.
So if we go ahead and now create a textile,
I'm going to go ahead and create this textile
and label that whoops.
I'm just going to type in featured set that
resizing to auto width, apply the textile
caption.
And ensure the fill is set to on primary and
ensure that is in all caps.
And I'm going to double check whoops, it's
not all caps.
And I wrote the wrong thing, excuse me, it's
labeled favorites done should be paying attention
here.
And essentially what I'm gonna do is with
this line height set.
With this baseline, I'm going to just center
this in the center of this by moving it you'll
see that it snaps gives me that red arrow
indication, I'm going to move this up and
see I have this red line here that I'm going
to apply to the bottom of the frame.
And I need the baseline to be set to 12 pixels
right now.
It's set to a 11 on the baseline or our baseline
set to 11.
So if we need to push that down one pixel,
which leaves a pixel gap on the top of the
icons, outer bounding box.
So now we have the baseline set to 12.
So that is fantastic.
And we can also reference a given hour, our
typography here, what we're going to need
to do is actually select this icon.
And we can go ahead and group this and then
I can hold option v.
and this will actually center that content.
And then I'm going to ungroup it again.
And what I want to do is make sure that this
a lot, the alignment of the text is at the
center.
So whenever a user renames it, it just is
automatically centered in that component.
So they don't have to deal with messing with
alignment and whatnot, that could be very
irritating.
So now that that is specified, we are good
to go.
And you'll notice that when the text is applied,
it pushes up the icon.
And the icons that aren't currently active
stay vertical, vertically centered on the
axis with that text being applied, takes that
into consideration and calculates it, and
then centers that vertically with icon plus
text.
So now that we have that variant created,
we can go ahead and just create that as a
main component.
Now we have a our landscape or portrait main
component.
So we can go ahead and actually duplicate
this, throw this into our landscape variant,
I'm going to rename this to landscape and
detach this instance with the shortcut key
option command B.
And what we can do is ensure that we have
proper constraints applied to this.
So with this example, it's utilizing the entire
width of the landscape version of the Android
phone here in the six frame in this example.
So what we can do is manually ensure that
this is correctly being applied.
And by doing that, we need to make sure that
these we have three boxes set to 168 dips
wide or if you have some other better way
of calculating it.
Please do so.
As this is the best way.
I know Everything's vertically centered, as
you can see, but what I'm gonna do is the
same approach we do with the portrait version.
So I'm gonna set the width to 168 dips for
the height 256 and snap that to the top and
to the right, and select my icon, hold that
option v h, make sure that's centered.
So we have this implemented correctly, I'm
going to do the same exact thing for for this
next one, and I'm going to separate the top
and horizontally align it to the center.
So now, I just need to do that with the icon
as well.
Now that that's applied, we can say we want
to snap this, we want the edges of each of
these frames to snap next to each other, because
it's centered within the middle of this within
the middle of this landscape variant, doing
the same exact thing.
Tree applying these values, I'm going to make
sure that this text and his favorites and
icon are grouped as well, and center that
within this frame.
And then I'm going to snap this to the top,
and then push this over until it snaps to
see that red line.
Now I have all three elements aligned accordingly.
And I can go ahead and ungroup these properties
as needed.
So I'm going to ungroup those frames.
So just utilize this to measure this perfectly
or properly.
And with that said, we now have all of this
aligned properly, and we are good to go.
All we need to do is ensure that we make this
a main component.
So that is our main component.
And now all we want to do is go ahead we can
even throw this frame in here is an example
of each format.
Or you could just actually, we just want to
go ahead and throw this in there as is.
Today, we're going to be talking about how
to build out components.
And it's going to be real simple, we're going
to start off by in this file going to our
team library, you can hold down Option three.
And turning on that library, the library you're
going to want to access is labeled as material
design system, ignore the one that is enabled
above labeled material design, we want the
material design system.
And I'm just going to turn that off so you
do not get confused.
So now that we have this library enabled,
it will have materializes some library unable
to access in our assets panel.
And the first thing we're going to see is
you can go ahead and click on the documentation
here, this is a link in figma.
So you can go ahead and open up the the component
page on material designs website to understand
what this component actually does.
There's a lot of in depth information here
that I totally recommend you consuming as
this will only benefit you as a designer.
And you'll notice that we have this interactive
floating action button that we're actually
going to be building out ourselves.
There's a default version, and there's a mini
version set to 40 dips, the default set to
56 dips, and it's 56 dips in width and height
as well as the mini ones set to 40 dips in
width and height as well.
And then we have an extended variant of this
floating action button that either comes with
or without an icon.
And we're going to be creating the majority
of these components today.
And what I did was I grabbed the screenshots
from the specs.
And this tells you actually how to construct
these in figma.
And we'll turn them into main components to
then publish into our library.
And it talks about placement.
And again, this is really important, because
this will definitely teach you how to differentiate
certain types of buttons as we create several
types of buttons.
And this is only one set of those buttons.
These are a floating action button.
And as you can see, there are variants of
this, we have one two, the leading and text
variant.
And then we have two variants of the regular
floating action buttons.
So we have a total of four variants there.
And now, you can view this as you wish to
refer to.
And we're gonna go ahead and check our figma
file.
And I have this exercise file set up with
the screenshots for us to reference.
And the first thing we're going to need now
that we've been able to library is the icon.
So that is a plus icon.
So if I type in plus, maybe we can just click
on that and continue to search for that icon.
And if it's not appearing in your assets panel,
you could also just extend all of the icons
here and you can search by category as well.
If this is just too overwhelming for you,
you'll notice that I'm slowly showing you
this to show Guess the functionality.
And again, we can keep searching through this
if we want.
But again, this is actually very tedious and
not good for our design process.
So the best way to go about this is directly
going to the file where all these components
live.
So you can go ahead and drag any of those
components into your canvas.
And if you drag that in, you could then go
click on Go to main component, and that'll
take you directly toward those master components
live.
And since all of our components live in the
same location, we're going to go ahead and
search for it ourselves.
This, we're going to look for that plus icon,
and it should live under our action category.
I know even here, it may be difficult to parse
and find.
So I'm going to pause and look for this real
quick.
Since I can't find this icon, it's actually
not in our library.
And again, this is our library where I intentionally
didn't put all the icons here, although over
time it will.
And I did that because I actually want us
to utilize the icon tool.
So I'm going to type in online on the internet
Material Design icons tool.
And basically, this tool is a resource to
download specific icons that we need.
And we can also search for categories, like
I had discussed in the previous video.
And we can either look for it by scrolling
through, although that may be difficult, or
I can filter it by the name and I can just
type in plus.
And you'll notice that under the actions category,
these are all the plus variants of the icon.
So I kept I typed in plus.
And what I was actually looking for was the
Add icon.
So if I can double check by going back to
my library, and searching for add, and my
icons, and you'll notice that it is there,
it was just difficult for me to find as this
is all very dense.
Oh, there it is.
Let me see, sometimes you can get overwhelmed
by that content.
So I can go ahead and copy this.
And it's called content add.
And I'll go ahead and search that as an example
content.
And if I type in slash add, it will even further
compartmentalize that.
And again, we're good to go, I can drag this
onto the canvas, I now have the proper dimensions
for this icon, I'm just double checking that
the width and height of this icon is set to
24 by 24.
dips in this case.
So you see that that's specified here in the
Properties panel.
And all of these variants of the floating
action button, all use a width of 24 by 24,
width and height of 24 dips.
I'm here for the icon.
And we're going to go ahead and create the
regular variant first.
So what we're gonna do is, now that we have
this icon, I'm actually going to hold down
Option Command G to create a frame.
And we're going to label this buttons, slash
space slash space, floating action.
Whoops, action button, regular.
This is the regular variant of the floating
action button.
And it lives under the category of buttons
and under the category floating action button,
and it is the regular variant.
So that is important to note that we get that
naming convention set from the get go, it'll
make our lives a lot easier.
And you'll know what I mean when we start
to publish these components to the library.
And Okay, so now what I want to do is hold
an option, imagine you turn this into a frame
again, well, this is the frame.
And what I'm going to do is hold down Shift
Option as I drag on the frame and ensure that
that's set to 56 by 56.
And if not, if you don't want to do it that
way, this is much quicker, you just set these
to 56 by 56.
You'll notice that the icon set to top and
left.
By default, as I scale that out, what I'm
going to do is in the Layers panel, click
on that icon, hold down Option V and then
H and that will center my icon perfectly as
needed for my floating action button in order
to create that.
So now that I've created that, you'll notice
that the spacing on the left and the right
of the icon should be set to 16.
So the padding should be set to 16 dips on
the left and right which it is on this frame.
And it might be hard for you to see because
by default that that fill was off turned off
and I'm holding down option to get these breadline
measurements.
So you'll see that those specs are set properly.
And it is already vertically centered and
horizontally centered as needed.
The frame size is correct.
And what I do need to do before I forget is
ensure that the color of this icon is going
to turn off that build icon and the selection
color, which is the color applied to the icon
here needs to be set properly.
So it needs to be set to content on primary.
And you can't see it right now but that's
fine.
Because we're going to specify the background
color of this fill by clicking style, going
to our content.
And then we're going to select on should be
on background or on surface.
They're all the same color value.
And again, if there's ever any confusion on
what color to apply, we can always reference
the documentation here and in material design,
to understand the behavior better and get
clues or hints on how to better construct
these elements.
But now that I know what that is, I'm going
to ensure that this component has rounded
corners.
So I'm going to change the corner radius here
and round that out.
You'll notice that it's now rounded out when
I set this to 32 dips 32 on the corner radius,
I now have my rounded circle.
And we have the desired colors applied.
And with this icon implemented as well, I,
the last thing I need to do is add an effect
style to this button.
And remember, when we worked on elevation,
and I created a diagram of the elevation,
one thing we can do is reference documentation
again, and go to elevation on the material
design website.
If we go to our components, or if we go to
design, and we select the environment and
select elevation, and we go to elevation hierarchy,
or whoops, that's what's a default depicting
elevation, I'm trying to find the good example
of elevation and where it lies on a floating
action button.
So a floating action button.
Let's find the example here.
Okay, so here we have, it's right here.
So you see this floating action button right
here, the floating action button lies on when
it raises to 12 dips in elevation.
And you'll notice that it lives in between
four and eight dips on this axis here.
And it lives on the six dips on the y axis.
So that's where the floating action button
is at by default.
So if we go ahead and actually go to our styles,
go to effects and apply the six dip, which
is it's already labeled to in a color system
in the description, which is awesome, we have
now created our floating our regular floating
action button.
And once you've created the desired component
as needed, we can go ahead and turn this into
a main component.
And you can either click the Create component
in the toolbar right there in the center.
But the I always use the shortcut key to create
a main component and that's option command
K.
If you pay attention your Layers panel, once
I hit that shortcut key, I will now have a
main component.
So that is awesome.
And what we need now is a mini floating action
button, which is the which is what's FA B
stands for, and all we actually have to do
is we can go ahead and duplicate this, because
essentially what this is, is a smaller version
of the regular, it's just shrink shrunk down.
And what we are going to need to do is detach
this element, I'm going to do option command
B, I'm not attached that is a regular frame,
or you can right click and click detach instance,
which detaches it from the main component.
And what we'll need to do is now specify the
spacing and tighten it.
So you'll notice that the padding all around
is set to 16 dips.
And all you have to do is set the height and
width of this to 40 dips here as specified
in the specs, I can go ahead and hit this
constraint proportions, type in 40.
And it will do that and what I can do is select
the icon hit option V and then option H, I
just hold down Option then hit D then H and
then it will automatically center that in
the within the parent frame.
So everything is now set to eight dips on
the top, left, bottom and right specified
here.
And we're good to go.
The only thing we need to do is actually go
ahead and rename this and we're going to call
it the mini fab instead of regular.
So we don't have to change the naming convention
to the left of this layer, just the rightmost
portion of it, which is regular.
So change that to mini fHb.
You can once you've done that, you can turn
this into a master component, right click
Create component or main component, I apologize.
And now we have those two variants.
Great, we're good to go.
And the next step is we're going to need to
create another button and it's an extended
floating action button.
And this is our last element that we'll need
to create here.
And with this created, we're going to go ahead
and reference this mini bind.
I'm going to duplicate this button and I'm
going to detach it, detach this instance.
And I'm gonna go ahead and set the name convention.
And it's a long one.
So I'm going to type in x dented FA B.
So extended floating action button.
Now that we have that name properly, I'm going
to go ahead and ensure that we specify the
parent frame, we're going to utilize the parent
frame to set the parameters of the button.
So all I did was I grabbed the right edge,
held down command and stretched out this element.
And I need to make sure that I have my constraints
set properly, maybe I want my constraints
to center on the y axis.
So if I didn't center this, it set the top
and left on constraints, this would just stick
there.
And I don't want that because I need to set
this height to 48.
And I still need this icon to be aligned centered
vertically, I could just apply that property,
go ahead and change the height to 48.
And that stays centered, you'll notice that
it's what sets what pixels on the top and
bottom proportionately.
And you can see how powerful utilizing the
principles material design is specified.
Things will always be divisible by four or
eight.
And now that I have that height specified,
I need to set the spacing to 12 instead of
eight on the left.
So now I have that set to 12.
So that spacing is now proportionate.
And I actually need to create some text.
And we have the color style already, because
we enabled our library for the button color
style.
And I'm going to specify, I'm going to create
some text here, hit t on my keyboard, create
the text tool.
And I'm going to type into create.
And I'm going to ensure that I have the content,
color style set properly.
So I have content on primary.
So on primary, you'll notice that it's using
the Roboto mano, so does not look like this
textile yet, but we need to apply a style.
So with that text selected, I can click on
the textiles icon.
And then go ahead and select button.
And I now have create set.
And with that created, I can go ahead and
so one sec, once that's specified, I can go
ahead and and specify what I'm going to need
to do with this color style is ensure that
I'm holding down command and grabbing the
the edge of this text here.
And I can go ahead and center this.
So option v to vertically center this, my
spacing set to 12 here and I need the spacing
on the right to be set to 20.
Because that that is what specified, the text
is centered as it's pointing here, through
the content being the icon and the text is
centered in this floating action button that
is extended.
And I've now centered that here.
And we need to set the spacing to 20 here,
so I can go ahead and click on this, I can
hold down Option here, which will allow me
to see the spacing and I hold down Command
and push this to the left to see if I'm getting
the right spacing, I was off by one pixel.
So now it's set to 20 there.
And I have now created the extended floating
action button with all the proper properties.
So we can go ahead and double check that by
just pulling this next to it.
And what we can see is that we have the icon
set to 24 by 24 dips as specified here, the
spacing set to the 12 on the left and right
of the left of the edge of the button and
the right of the text.
And it's vertically centered.
And the height of the button itself is set
to 48 dips.
And the text has padding to the left set to
12 and spacing of padding to the right set
to 20 dips.
And we're good to go.
That is our floating button floating action.
Floating extended floating action button sorry,
a lot of words that are going on confusing
myself.
So I'm going to create that as a main component.
And one thing you'll notice is that if I type
into this component, I don't have essentially
what I need, which is auto layout, because
it will automatically adapt what I type and
implement the proper spacing as needed as
I type.
So what we're going to do is turn this into
an auto layout component.
And the next section of the course will will
go over specifically auto layout for implementing
these components, which needs to be covered
separately, I believe, because it's a lot
of content to consume.
And understanding, providing the nomenclature
here for this component by layering it accordingly
naming it in the Layers panel accordingly.
And then also utilizing the tips and tricks
to create the components themselves may take
some time.
So we're going to specifically focus on that
and constraints as needed.
So I'm going to actually center this and ensure
that this sticks to the left and right but
again, remember that when we finalize publishing
these components, we're going to Use auto
layout.
And we won't be using these constraints are
solely using constraints for the practice
of understanding constraints, which you'll
be masters at once we build out all these
components interactively together.
So that is all I have.
The last thing is organizing and publishing
this so.
So now that we have all of this organized
and published, well, now we need to organize
it since we have these main components.
So what we can do is, with this regular floating
action button here, we can go ahead and specify
that make sure it's aligned accordingly, we
can change, excuse me, the spacing as needed.
Whoops, I'm going to go ahead and drag this
over here.
Got that set to 16.
spacing between the types set to 72.
And I'm going to go ahead and drag this one
last button here and change this make sure
that's set to 16.
And we now have our three button variants
here for the floating action buttons, as directed
here from the specs specified on the material
design website.
So that is what we just created.
And you can go ahead and read the contents
of this web page, which is accessible in our
exercise file right here at the bottom, you
just click on that link, select Open link.
And it'll open that page for you.
And you'll be good to go.
And again, I'm going to keep this here short
and sweet.
Thank you so much for watching.
In the other videos, you'll notice that we'll
actually publish these in the, to our material
design system file as a whole.
But I'm going to save that for the end.
So we can do that all together in one go.
So that way, you're not your heads, not context
switching between the types, the two separate
processes, which is building out these components,
and then organizing and publishing the components.
Today, we're gonna be talking about building
just some generic buttons.
And if you click on the link here in our resources,
we can go ahead and access the buttons documentation,
I totally recommend going through all this
in depth, but we're primarily going to be
mostly focusing on constructing these buttons.
And what you'll notice is that we also have
another interactive field here, nice little
playground for us to see what we're going
to be building.
And also we're going to be talking about,
we got the different variants.
Here, we got the contained button, we got
the outline button, and we got the text button.
And all of these buttons also have a leading
icon.
So they all have that type as well.
So we have three, three regular variants.
So we're going to create well there.
And then we also have each of these variants
with a leading icon.
So we're going to be creating six types of
buttons today.
And as you can see, they're also states associated
with that, which we'll cover later in the
different section of the course.
And what we can do is just, we have all of
the specs here.
So we can go ahead and check specs to see
the dimensions of how to actually construct
these buttons.
And one screen Yep, I got all the screenshots
here, got all five variants.
And note that all of these variants have one
with a leading icon, which will take into
consideration, which is why we check the documentation.
As you can see here, they also have leading
icons.
So I can go ahead and just screenshot this
as well if I wanted to.
And I can go ahead and paste this to my canvas,
and click on each type and just screenshot
all these and for all of you Mac users out
there.
If you hold down Ctrl Shift command for it
will allow you to take a quick screenshot
of your interface, and then you can paste
it into the canvas and figma.
And now I have all those variants.
And we're gonna go ahead and start with the
contained button.
And since auto layout was super easy to implement
with these buttons, we'll go ahead and cover
this.
But auto layout will be its own section of
the course as well as creating these, these
creating these components with just the sole
understanding of how to construct them and
utilize the color styles and whatnot is time
consuming in and of itself is why there is
a another section in the course for just auto
layout and adding auto layout to these components
we're currently building.
So now we can start with a generic frame.
I'm gonna go ahead and hit that.
So the frame has a height of 36 dips.
So I'll change that to 36.
And now that we have the height set to 36
steps, I'm going to go ahead and make sure
that the on primary background colors specified
if we go to effects and go to fill, hit the
style icon.
And one thing we need to do that I forgot
is that since these are individual exercise
files, we'll have to re enable the library
and we need to re enable the material design
system library to access those color styles.
So now that we have that specified, I can
go to my Phil and I have that library here
viewable material design system.
And I'm going to go ahead and click On the
primary color, which is the color of background
color button, and again, we're going to need
to double check the corner radius of this
button, I can go, there's a few ways you could
actually do this.
And the border radius, I just checked the
code, the border radius is set to four pixels
there.
So I can go ahead and change the corner radius
here to four pixels.
Now that that's set, you'll notice that we
need to add some text to this, once we add
the text will adjust the width of this component.
So if I type in, apply the proper color style,
go to content, and then select content on
primary which is content from the on the primary
surface.
So if I type in button, or apply the proper
color style, I mean textile, select the button
textile, I now have button.
And one thing I noticed with this style is
that we had the click on the type Details
button and to ensure that auto width is selected
for the resizing, which is what we want.
And one thing I can do is hold down Option
V and H which will center this horizontally
and vertically.
But this won't really matter once we add auto
layout.
So that's just a trick I frequently use to
center items within the parent frame, horizontally
vertically, which is Option A v.
So now that we have the coast selected for
both the background and the text, I can go
ahead and add auto layout.
So how do you do that? Well, I don't know
it needs to be applied to both elements.
And what are those both? What are the two
elements I'm referring to? Well, the two elements
are the the text layer here and this frame,
and I'm going to name this buttons.
Space slash space, and then label this contained
button because this is our contained button.
And now that I have that properly labeled,
I'm going to hit shift a, what that just did
is that that just added auto layout.
And what I'm going to want to do is that by
default, auto layout ads, horizontal and vertical
padding by default, and we don't want that
because we want this to stay vertically centered.
So I just hit option B again to vertically
center it, and then ensure that this auto
layout set to horizontal.
And then I'm going to select the parent layer
and add auto layout to that as well.
And I just hit shift a to do that.
Or you notice that you can click on this frame,
right click and select Add auto layout, or
you can do it from the canvas as well.
I click on that right click and select Add
auto layout.
And you'll notice that we have this set to
vertical.
So what does vertical do if I type it it's
some just the vertical parameter allows you
to resize this vertically.
Whereas if I set this horizontally, I would
be changing the I would be resizing this horizontally,
I mean vertically, sorry for the confusion
there.
So if I set this auto out to vertical, you'll
notice that I'm only able to actually resize
the width on the horizontal axis.
And if I select horizontal, I'm actually only
able to specify modifying the heights.
But that doesn't matter.
We already have our height specified.
And recognize that and apply the proper vertical
padding so that it was consistent and with
the text there, so the Texas center.
And now all I need to do is ensure that the
padding horizontal padding is not set to 162,
which it is, as you can see there.
And it's set to 16.
So I got to just change that to 16.
Now what does autolayout do, I have this button
now.
And if I use this button, if I type hello
and just keep typing, it automatically adjusts
the padding.
So that's what we need, it'll save you a lot
of time as as the designer, it's a very helpful
feature.
So with that created, the only thing missing
if you pay attention closely, there is some
elevation data these buttons, and we can go
ahead and reference material design documentation
once more.
And what we need to do is go ahead and access
the environment, good elevation, and click
on depicting elevation to scroll down a bit.
And we're going to go ahead and look for this
diagram.
And what you'll see is that we need to find
our buttons and our contained button lives
on the two dips axis for the elevation, and
when it is pressed, it rises to the eight
dips, or eight pixels and the elevation axis.
So we can go ahead and apply the two dips
effect style, which is right here.
Got the two dip set.
There.
So now we have the proper elevation set for
this button.
And we are good to go with this button.
And we can go ahead and even create this as
a main component.
Now we have this main component set.
Now we can create the other main component,
which is a contained button with a leading
icon.
And you'll notice that this icon is set to
18 by 18 pixels.
But we can also double check for go to our
buttons, click on leading icon, we can inspect
the code received in command, shift C, to
view this button, I can break this down and
try to view the specs of this button.
But if it's too hard for you, then don't do
it.
But that's one way of looking at those specs.
But we already have that already.
So I hope I didn't confuse you, just providing
some technical tips and tricks on how to analyze
things if you are suspicious of them not being
done properly.
So I've now removed the auto layout and the
detached the instance.
So I can go ahead and resize this component
accordingly.
So I need eight pixels in between my icon
and the text.
So what I can do is actually use constraints
here, set that to right, and center on the
vertical axis right on the horizontal.
And I can stretch this out, and it will maintain
that proper spacing on the right to 16.
And it's still centered, and it gives me some
room to add in the new icon.
And all we actually need is a placeholder
icon.
So we can go ahead and click on our assets.
You could literally type whatever you want,
I just typed in star.
It can be anything like it could be the Add
button, like we did in the floating Actions
button.
And what we can do is one remove this fill
layer because it's inactive, there's no purpose
for that.
So that's just confusing.
And we can click on content and select on
primary.
And if it's going to be on our on primary
color style surface, that background.
And now, what we had to do is scale this down
to 18.
By 18, all I did was I held Option Shift,
which will proportionately scale this down
as I drag the handles downward, I can plop
this into my layer and ensure that this is
vertically aligned by holding down Option
v.
Since I know this isn't it's in the parent
frame.
And just double check the spacing set to 12
dips there.
So now I can go ahead and move that over one
pixel.
And what I could do is turn this into an auto
layout as well.
And the parent frame into an auto layout.
And we can start to specify the spacing between
items.
So what we can do here is remove that initial
padding set by auto layout always adds one
extra pixel horizontal and vertically, which
is annoying.
And we want to make sure this is set to 12
on the left.
This might be tricky with auto layout, because
it's not allowing us to specify each edge
on on this layout here.
So that can be tricky.
And again, we can cover that in the next video.
If this is too hard for you.
What I'm going to do actually, since we're
only focused on the construction of this component,
and not autolayout is just disregard that
so we get the specs perfect.
And we can focus on that in the next section
of the course.
So we have that set of 12.
And I'm gonna move this over, make sure it's
set to eight.
And make sure the padding to the right of
this button is set to 16.
So now that that's set to 16, and in the parent
frame is set to eight from the right and left
12 on the left.
This button has been constructed properly.
So once that's constructed properly, I'm going
to just imply that this is a contained button
with an icon.
So what we can do is specify that right there
contain button with icon and make that a main
component.
Now we have two components here specified.
And we're going to go ahead and create the
outline version of both of these.
So I'm actually going to save us some time
duplicate these two Once these two are duplicated,
we know that these don't use elevation, so
we can remove that.
And what we're gonna do is hold down Option
command B, which will detach those styles.
And notice one of them has auto layout, which
is this one.
So I'm going to hit Option Shift a to detach
that from auto layout.
So it's just a frame, which is what we want.
We know that the heights are set properly.
And what we need is an outline of a border
around this button.
So if I go ahead and type in, outlined button,
I'm going to go ahead, do the same thing for
this one.
And I just specify the spacing on this, make
sure it's set to 16, I should be good to go,
all we had to really do is modify the color
and add a stroke.
So with that said, One thing to double check
is the height on this button, the height has
been modified.
So I'm going to change that to 36.
Again, to make sure that this content is still
centered.
So that's one thing we should always look
out for as we're building these elements is
making sure that they're they're centered
accordingly.
And as we implement these things, so I'm gonna
ungroup that there that shouldn't be grouped,
that should definitely be centered on our
canvas, still set to eight, everything, this,
this button has a frame because we add an
auto layout.
So when I detach those things I forgot to
add to remove this frame.
So that's why that occurred.
So now it's ensuring that pixels are perfect
there.
So we're good to go.
And now I can go ahead and remove the bill
style from both of these.
And what we're going to want to do is add
a stroke and leave it at one pixel.
And for the color of this, we need to go ahead
and actually view this outline button.
And you'll notice that the outline button
is set to the on primary colors.
But in the specs, we we have a different color
specified, but that's alright, so for the
sole purpose of constructing these elements,
we'll leave that outline to the on primary
color, although that may not be the case at
all times.
So we go ahead and click on the stroke, go
to the style, select on primary, and we'll
go and double check this button and the color
style is set to on primary as well.
So I can Command click on that text and Command
Shift click on the second set of text, and
then go ahead and select on primary color
style.
And I can do the same thing with this leading
icon here, ensure that it's set to on primer
as opposed to on surface.
So now we have those two button variants and
just ensure that the spacing set to 16.
And it's vertically centered, which it is
by holding down option.
And we can go ahead and rename this from contained
button to outline button.
And now that we have that we're good to go.
And we can make that a main component.
You'll notice that this still resizes with
all the proper parameters, which is great.
But to make that a main component by holding
an option, command K.
And we are good to go with this component
as well.
I'm gonna go ahead and hold down Option command
K.
So we have those two variants.
And we only have three more button components
to make next.
So we have our contained variants and our
outline variants.
So we could even delete that screen.
We can't delete the screenshot.
But now we have our text button.
So our button is essentially just text, but
not to confuse you.
For those of you questioning why we shouldn't
just use text for this button.
Well, when you utilize the states of this
button, like when you hover on this button,
it actually has some parameters around it.
So that's why we need to make this that's
why this isn't just a actual text button.
It actually has transparent parameters around
it.
So when you hover on it, those colors appear
and you can see that it's actually encapsulated
in a rectangle.
So if we go back to figma we can create that
variant and I'm just going to duplicate this
button here.
No need to worry created from scratch that'll
make your lives harder, no need to make your
life harder or work smarter, not harder.
And then we'll detach the style because it
doesn't utilize elevation, and will actually
just remove the back the fill color, which
is the background and will Command click on
the text and set that text to on primary color
style.
And we now have our text button, I'm going
to label that as text button.
And the only difference is, we need to change
the auto layout horizontal padding from 16
to eight, because there's less padding, so
if we click on this, it's set to eight on
the left and right the horizontal padding,
and the text is centered vertically, and the
height of this is set to 36.
And the mid the minimum width of a button
in terms of its width can be set to 64 pixels.
So this would it work a button labeled A so
because the minimum width of it as specified
in the documentation is needs to have a min
width of 64 bits, which is just 64 pixels.
In this scenario, we have one set to 100 tendons,
so we're good to go.
And that is the construction out of our our
text button.
And what I'm going to do is I need to actually
detach this.
And I'm going to rename it text button.
So we have text button, I'm going to option
command K to make that a main component.
And we are good to go.
only thing missing is another text button
with a leading icon.
As you can see here is a text button with
a leading icon.
So what I can do is duplicate this button
here, this outline button with a leading icon,
leading meaning that it's in front of the
text here in terms of left to write.
And I'm going to detach this instance as it
is a part of a different family.
And attach the instance and ensure that the
padding is set to eight on the left and right.
Once that's done, I need to be very careful
about my frames here and make sure this is
nice and clean.
Just ungroup those frames there.
So we're good to go.
What I need to do is the padding here set
to 12.
And that's set to 16.
So I can shrink that down.
But we can also reference the code here.
So here, you can clearly see that the padding
still set to 12.
I mean eight on the right and left the left
of this icon, set eight and right with buttons
at eight.
And then it still maintains that spacing in
between the icon and text as you can see.
So by just kind of tried to inspect that code
there, it could give me a general idea of
the spacing of the elements.
So the padding stayed there.
And we're good to go, let's, I'm going to
just specify that as text button, gonna shrink
by holding down Come in, shrink that to fourth
set to eight.
And then this button is set to its proper
parameters.
So now that it's good to go, we just need
to rename it.
So it is a text button with icon and make
that a main component.
And we are good to go.
The last buttons we need to create our is
this toggle buttons variant.
So with that said, Okay, so now with this
toggle button, what we're going to do is we
have three sections here, these there's three
buttons and this toggle button.
And they're all boxes set to 48 by 48 dips.
And then there's a stroke in between, we could
call this the stroke and these two strokes
here set to one pixel.
And then it also has a border around it as
well, which is a stroke.
So we'll take that into consideration.
As we build this.
I'm going to go ahead and create a frame so
we can just do the math.
So 48 times three is 144, we can specify that
width to 144 and ensure that the height set
to 48.
So we have that and make sure the background
color of this fill is set to surfaces.
surface.
And once that's set to surface, we can go
ahead and grab the we can grab placeholder
icons right now we don't know if you want
to get into the specifics and find those.
Now we you can by accessing your library of
icons.
And actually yeah, we can go ahead and do
that since it's free.
easy to find in our library.
And we have all of the format's needed to
select for this example.
So I just went into our materials and system
library, which is also enabled here.
And I pasted these three, and what I need
to do is add the proper color style.
So add remove the fill that's turned off,
that's hidden.
And now I can go to surfaces content, and
then on on surface, since the background is
set to surface, and they're already set to
24 by 24.
And what I need to do is set the corner radius
as well.
So generally the core radius set.
For this scenario, it's set to two.
And with that set to two, we can go ahead
and plop these in accordingly.
So this icon, I'm going to center vertically,
since the heights proper, please set already,
it's just padding is set to 12 pixels from
the left here and 12 pixels from the right
of this one pixel stroke here.
And one thing we need to do is add a border.
So what we can do is add a stroke and set
that to triple E, hit Enter.
And it's already set to one pixel and we want
it set to inside.
Because if we set it to the inside, that is
the proper basting we want or else it'll set
it in, it'll set it inside the frame, if we
set it to outside the stroke is now outside
of our frame.
We want that set to inside since that's what's
specified here.
Now that set inside, I'm going to create a
line that's one pixel in the hex values Triple
E or six E's, the x value, then just set that
to 48.
And one thing I'm going to do is flatten this
by hitting command or Command Shift O, and
then I'm going to hit option W and that will
align it.
And then I'm just going to make sure the padding
set to 12.
So now this icons got padding on the left
and right at 12 and top and bottom.
And we can drag this in here, I can center
that vertically, I can go ahead and duplicate
this.
Make sure that's set to 12 as well.
So now set to 12 on the left and right.
And then all we have to do is drag this in
here and make sure it's set to 12 as well.
So now it's set to 12 on the left.
And right one thing that isn't correct here
is this last icon spacings padding of 10 on
the left, make that 12.
And then we can stretch out this button by
holding down command on the right handle,
move it out twice.
And now that's set to 12 proportionately.
So now these are all good to go.
What we can do is go ahead and label this
properly.
So we can label this if we rename this layer
buttons, space slash space, label that toggle
buttons.
Enter, we are good to go.
We can even make this a main component by
just hitting option command K, and we are
good to go.
And now we have all of our button variants.
Now we can just go ahead and add them into
our file as needed.
And that is everything you need to have covered
in this course.
Or for this video, excuse me.
So now I'm just dragging these.
So I'm gonna pause and organize these now
bareback.
So now I have all of these organized in my
buttons layer.
And they're named accordingly.
Today we're going to be going over building
card components.
And and we're going to get an overview and
understanding of the usage for the usage and
need for cards, when to use them and how to
build these cards out utilizing the components
we've already made.
So we can go ahead and start off by opening
up our team library modal here, and we need
to turn on our material design system.
And then we have access to the cars documentation
here in this exercise file.
So if we go ahead and open that link, what
you'll see is that cards contain content actions
about a single subject.
And here we have a great interactive demo,
showcasing the types of cards.
There are several options for the elevated
card, and then there's also an outline card
and in our figma file.
We're going to go ahead and build out Four
variants, three of them are elevated.
So the elevated type here you can see, within
this there is a drop shadow being utilized
here on this elevated variant.
And then on the outline variant, it's literally
just an outline as opposed to using drop shadow.
So those are the differences between the two
cards types.
And both those two card types, the elevated
type and the outline type, have options with
media supportive text, and buttons, and you
can mix and match them go ahead and mess around
with those get familiar with what's possible
with these types of cards.
And there's a lot of great context around
how to use cards and cards are technically
surfaces that display content and actions
on a single topic.
And they should be easy to scan for relevant
and actionable information, elements like
text and images.
As you can see, in the interactive demo, there's
the text and the image example.
And we have some actions to some buttons are
specifically about that single topic in the
card.
And here are some principles where this card
is contained.
They're identified as a single contained unit,
it is independent and can stand alone without
relying on surrounding elements for context.
And it is individual, a card cannot merge
with another card or divided into multiple
cards.
And here we have a breakdown of the anatomy.
And here, as you can see, the only the the
card container is the only required element
in a card.
All other elements shown are optional.
So this container here is the holds all the
cart elements.
And that is actually the only required element.
So what this indicates is that card layouts
are very to support the types of content they
contain.
And it's really specific on your needs when
when building out cards.
So when you try to implement this as a system
in figma, all these optional variants should
actually be their own elements when you publish
them.
So you can then start to build out your into
your own card individually.
So it has all the defined functionality.
Because if you just create these specific
cards, maybe there are certain things you
don't need from it, which you will need to
remove, therefore, needing to create your
own from scratch, which is why we want to
build it from the ground up utilizing elements
as opposed to refactoring one that's already
been built.
It's more modular in that sense.
Here's some great, you know, breakdown of
behavior usage and whatnot.
And I grabbed these screenshots of the specs.
And what I really like about the specs is
that it states for cards, is that the section
should not be read as prescriptive, or, or
exhaustive, or also definite, these cards
have no singular layout, type of graphic or
image size.
So and So none of this is extremely specified.
So what they're trying to state is that it
is designed to meet the needs of the content
they present.
So, so the content the designer is trying
to present.
So it is flexible in that sense that you can
build out a card to your needs.
And it shows a variety of layouts that help
showcase how flexible It really is.
So we'll go ahead with that said, jump into
figma.
And now that we're in figma, we're gonna go
ahead and create the first card type.
And one thing important about this is that
the elevation for the rest of state of a car
is set to one dip.
So in under my under the under elevation here
in the material design guidelines, there's
a table of default values, which have already
gone over a few times before, and it shows
that the card at the rested state is set to
one dip on the right there.
And when it is picked up, when this card is
being interacted with or picked up, it utilizes
the eight dip default elevation value.
So just just a side note there, because we
will need to know that to implement the elevated
portion of the cards we build up.
So with that said, let's go ahead and get
to cracking on this elevated card yours.
So we have is a title.
But we're gonna go ahead and define the frame
here.
So we have the background color style of surfaces
surface here, so it's just white, and the
rounded corners are set to four are actually
that set to eight.
And we're gonna go ahead and copy the name
of this.
So I've already named these.
So these cards live under the elevated category
and this has a title, some copy, body copy,
and image and actions, which is all stated
there.
So I'm gonna click on that rename this layer,
or frame minaret.
And now we can go ahead and specify the width
and height of this search set to 344 dips
in terms of width 148 dips and height.
Now that we have that specified the The more
I look at these Quarter this quarter as it
should be set to four.
Now that we're good to go, it just looked
different when we didn't resize it to its
proper dimensions, which is fine.
So now what we know is that this utilizes
two buttons.
And we can pull in a placeholder image from
our assets.
To figure out what with our material design
system library enable, we can go ahead and
search in our assets panel for QA type, and
I can just type in placeholder and there we
go.
I can also use this icon placeholder as an
image placeholder.
So if I drag this in here, I can set the width
and height there to add dips.
And then I can ensure that I am positioning
this properly, by 16, dips on top on the top
and right, and I'm going to sure set the constraints
to top and right so that it sticks, it stays
it maintains that spacing on the top and right
when resized.
Now we can go ahead in our assets panel and
search for buttons.
And here we have the text button variant,
all we can do is label this action one.
And I can select this again and just set the
spacing properly.
So this spacing is set to 16 from the beginning
of this text.
So what that means is I pull out my rulers
and I moved this over 16 pixels.
Right now it's 16 pixels to the left or dips
to the left of of the frame.
But it wants the typography to be the beginning
of the text to be 16 dips away.
So what I can do with this space properly,
in regards to the bounding box of the button,
I can add this ruler here.
And with that ruler, I can go ahead and push
this text inward.
So now that text is 16 dips to the left of
the of the of the parent frame there.
And then I can go ahead and just duplicate
this and it is set to eight dips to the right,
the second action here the second button,
or we label that action too.
And we should be good.
And now we just need to add in our body copy
and a title.
So what I'm going to pull out my text here,
ensure that that's set to text and text and
iconography color style, which has had a high
emphasis and I'm going to label this title
whoops, I'm going to select the proper textile.
And that should be set to one let's see here,
subtitle one I currently have specified.
So title goes here.
And with that specified, I'm gonna make sure
the type in the type details the resizing
is set to auto width, so it snaps accordingly,
and adheres to the proper line height specified
in our type system.
And I'm gonna use my shortcut keys option
w n A to snap to the top and left, and then
push this over twice, and down twice.
So I have, so I have padding top and left
set to 16 because I've modified my nudge amount
to eight on the small nudge as opposed to
my big nudge.
So I've reversed this, I highly recommend
you modifying your judgment to that so you
don't have to move it incremented by one all
the time.
Since this system is divisible by eight, I
can just move it in increments of eight every
time I use the arrow keys, which is very efficient.
So I'm going to duplicate this style here.
And what we have what we're seeing here is
our textbox should, let's specify the body
to body one there wo two, body two, and text
to body two and then go ahead and apply medium
emphasis to the color style.
And with that media emphasis applied, I'm
going to just copy what's written in this
spec component, secondary line text lorem
ipsum.
De lor, sit omit.
Not sure if that's actually a word.
That's all right.
And now that I have that specified, I'm gonna
push this up eight pixels.
And what I want to ensure is that the text
box is 16 pixels to the right of the image
right now it's set to 21.
So I can go ahead and increase that by five.
And now it's set to 16.
When I can do is set the constraints to top
left and right and bottom if need be.
And then as you can see here, our buttons
are eight dips from the top of this bount
text bounding box and everything is divisible
has the proper measurements and whatnot so
that is fantastic.
Now all we have to do is just double check
our parameters here, things are set to 16.
And we are good to go, we have now created
our first card, actually, the last thing we
need to do is go ahead and go to our effects
and apply that elevation.
So that to one dip.
And now we're good to go.
So we've created our first card.
And we can kind of double check some things
and see if this utilizes a different Subtitle
by referencing materials documentation.
So if we go to our specs and just scroll up
a bit, it'll tell you it, the title actually
uses an h6 and it uses body one.
So if I say if I selected body one, whoops.
But that's for a certain theme.
So just take note of that, that we should
adhere to the styles being used and referenced
if, even though the properties may be different
in another theme, it's still using those those
styles.
So now I'm going to go ahead and change the
subtitle to an age six.
And that is good to go.
I now have everything attached accordingly.
And yeah, we're good.
So apparently, this just uses Body Body one
and met it for metadata, it uses body two.
So let's go ahead and modify this accordingly.
And now that we have modified that our card
should be good to go.
But it actually doesn't look like that's a
proper textile, that should be smaller, the
font, so we'll leave it as is.
And we're going to go all the constraints
and measurements are properly set.
And we can go ahead and duplicate this and
publish this as a main component.
So we now have our first component created.
And we can even go ahead and create another
version of this where it's actually an outline
card.
So for the outline card, what we can do is
we're going to want to do first is remove
this elevation style, add a stroke, and it's
set to one pixel as one dip, as you can see
here, one dip, and the color set to undersurfaces
surface overlay.
And that is the outline of the the card.
As you can see, there's zoomed in.
And with that a lot of these properties are
actually the same, but the height of our card
is is is taller.
And one thing I did mess up on this card is
that that the spacing below these two buttons
should be set to eight dips instead of 16
dips.
So I'm gonna go ahead and click on this Hold
COMMAND as I as I change these dimensions
here.
And now I have it set to eight deaths from
the bottom.
And this card should be good to go.
Now go ahead and touch this up here.
I might just reduplicate this.
So I don't want to modify the dimensions or
the spacing there and detach it holding option
command B.
And then I'm going to re label this layer
and remove that elevation.
And we're going to want to select outlined
the naming convention I've specified here
already beforehand.
And it this naming convention clearly states
what type of card This is.
It's an outline card with an overline utilizing
overline a title, which includes the body
copy blood, and then an image and some actions
being those actions being our buttons.
So now I'm gonna go ahead and reapply that
stroke color style, which is surfaces surface
overlay.
And that's set to one dip or pixel.
And what we're going to do is increase the
height of this card real quick.
And we're going to need to push this content
down because the baseline of this headline
or this header is 40 dips away from the baseline
of the overline text.
So what I can do is just push this content
down, duplicate this textile, or this text
and then change it to overline with overload
specified.
I'm just going to write out oh line.
And then I'm going to ensure that it is 16
dips from the top, which it is.
So now that we have our overline specified,
I'm going to go ahead and make sure that the
baseline is 40 dips away from, from the typography
here from the from the title here, and this
title uses an h5.
So it's slightly bigger, as as you can see,
now I'm gonna go ahead and double check, add
some, add this red line to the first baseline,
add a red line to the second baseline to the
title here, which is I'm going to call it
headline five.
And then I'm gonna grab a square and just
calculate that manually.
So that is currently set to 41.
So we want to do we were pretty close, push
that up one by default.
And now it's set to 40.
Right there, as you can see, which is exactly
what we wanted to achieve.
So that is fantastic.
I can have my rulers hitting shift R.
And we're good to go in that regard.
So let's go ahead and close out this spacing
from the headline and this text.
And this baseline of the headline is 24 dips
above the baseline of this body copy.
So we can go ahead and do the same process
here.
And just add another red line here to this
body copy, grab a rectangle and ensure that
this is all being done properly and is currently
has a height of 27.
So we're going to want to do is push that
up through few pixels and ensure that this
is set to 24.
Now, the baseline is not 24 pips away from
the baseline of the headline, the header five,
specifically, h5 and our textiles there.
And we'll go ahead and double check our spacing
between the body copy and buttons.
And that for some reason isn't specified in
our spec, but it is specified here in this
so it may looks like it's set to 16 pixels
below the typography and then below the buttons
themselves.
I go ahead and rename those buttons to buttons
from like getting confused between the types
of buttons in the other card, I can go ahead
and double check these elements and push them
over.
So the padding on the left is set to 16 now
so that is more consistent.
And you'll notice that the the buttons actually
pushed in now in the buttons type isn't aligned
with the type of the body copy right there.
So that is important to take note of it'll
be slow, it'll appear visually slightly indented,
then I can change the spacing between the
two buttons to eight dips again as as it should
be a dips there, and then eight dips below
the buttons.
So now I'm going to go ahead and just grab
this car to hold down Command and pull this
up.
It's currently set to nine dip smoothie below.
So if I push that up one more pixel, we're
good to go.
It's now eight dips below and now everything
is up to spec as need be river overline the
title and the body copy and the image which
we can replace here in the fill style.
And just select an image there.
So when designers duplicate this, and then
we have our actions which are buttons.
So now that that's done, that is fantastic.
We'll go ahead and create our next card.
So got that as the main component now.
Next, we're going to go ahead and tackle this
more complex component and and what we're
going to need to do is we actually need this
component here we have this set of stars so
stars in the spec, I'm going to disregard
that from this component because I actually
have some purposes for the this component
in particular that I want to use later on.
So I'm going to build without the stars because
I don't need to communicate the those ratings.
And what I can do is create this variant year,
specify the width to 344 dips and the height
510 dips and the corner radius to four.
This is an elevated car.
So I'm gonna go to my effects and apply the
one dip elevation, then we'll go to my Phil
and select surfaces surface color style.
And what that is linked, I'm gonna go ahead
and just ensure that I have the proper name
for this component in my components and then
we have a image placeholder as you can see
here, I can just grab the placeholder that
we have in our system and specify the width
to 344 dips, and then the height 294.
And then a hold down Option W and a to snap
that properly into our component as needed.
And then we'll set the constraints to top
left and right, so that way when this stretches
to needs to be stretched, it doesn't get all
funky.
it'll snap to all the edges properly, so it
looks clean.
And with that said, we have a title that is
44 dips, the baseline of this title is 44
dips from the top of this image.
So if I go ahead and add this title in here,
then apply the proper text style of subtitle
one.
Or actually, it's the h5 title, I believe.
There we go.
And now I'm going to set select the resizing
and set that to auto width, I'm going to push
this down and push that down a bit, push that
to 30.
and double check the baseline.
So the baseline from the image should be set
to 44, which is actually right here.
So it's actually 24.
dips from the top of the image, with the baseline
being 44 dips from the top.
And now I want to disregard these stars here.
And even, I can add some secondary text.
So at the secondary text, I'm going to utilize
the caption textiles.
If I duplicate this, change the text style
and go to caption, I can select that set,
set that to secondary text.
Make sure that's 16 Dibs from the left of
the container of the card.
And I'm going to make sure both these fill
styles are set to text and iconography.
High emphasis.
And once that is done, I'm going to go ahead
and duplicate this secondary textile, push
it down and stretch out the text box so that
it is 24 deaths from the right of the container
the car container.
And with that, it's going to push that over
three notes set to 24 from the right to the
constraints, the top left and right.
And then I'm just going to add in this body
copy that is already in this card.
And I'm going to pause it real quick.
This typography specified, you'll notice that
it uses a divider too.
So we can even pull in our divider component
that we've created a divider there, pull that
in, and you'll notice that it is 16 has a
padding of 16 dips on the left and 20 and
16 dips on the right so we can bring and we
can do the math we want to set the width of
this component is 344.
And then minus 32 is 312.
So we can change the width of this to the
divider to 312.
So when we bring it into our component, and
it's a little hard to grab.
So I can just go to my Layers panel and drag
it in if I need to.
And then hold down Option H and that will
align it horizontally and then option v to
align it vertically, the alignment properly
and I can push this down and ensure that that
is 24 dips from the baseline of the second
baseline of text in this body body copy.
So if I push this up, I need to make sure
that that's at the 24 so if I grab a text
box, I can measure 24 dips from the bottom.
I was rough.
Almost there.
I was close.
So Now that that set to the baseline is 24
dips away.
So I'm going to push this down on more.
Whoops, I'm going to grab this divider, push
it down one more pixel, and it's from, from
the textbox.
That's on this body copy, it's set to 20.
So that's good to note.
And we need to change the color of this text,
the spotty copy from high emphasis to medium
emphasis.
And now that is accurate.
With that divider implemented, we can go ahead
and add another caption, we're actually it's
a subtitle.
So I can duplicate this one, and push this
down a bit, label it subtitle, then just change
the text style to subtitle.
Now that we have the subtitle must like subtitle
to uses a smaller subtitle it looks like just
to maintain the hierarchy there.
As these as subtitle one, I believe, and then
just make sure that the spacing is appropriated.
So it's the baseline is 36 dips from the divider,
so we can go ahead and measure that.
From this divider.
Currently, we have it 41 dips away, so I can
push up this element.
And now we have this 36 steps away from the
divider, which is great.
And I'm going to go ahead and add in some
chip components.
So we have some action chips being utilized
here.
So if I type in action chip, or just actually
chip into our assets panel, I can drag a chip
in.
And what I'm gonna do with this chip is I
can duplicate it a couple times, right, and
they're spaced eight dips away from each other.
So I'm gonna throw three chips in here.
And they're, they're all labeled differently
item one.
One thing we need to ensure is that these
chips utilize auto layout, and it doesn't
look like it's utilizing auto layout right
now.
Because I needed to add up auto layout to
my chips because they weren't adapting to
the size of the text.
So now if I go in and type in item one, it
will maintain the proper spacing on the left
and right.
And here you can see we have four chips.
So let's go ahead and select those.
Here we have item 123, and four.
So I'm just going to label those accordingly.
And now, I can go ahead and just restructure
the spacing there, make sure those are all
eight dips apart.
And I'm gonna go and drag and drop this into
my v component here.
And it specifies the baseline 14 dips away
from the top of the chip.
And I'm assuming that that is actually eight
dips away from from the bounding box and the
typography, I can go ahead and double check
that.
And technically it is it's the baseline here
is 15 pips away, but we're gonna go and maintain
the spacing from the top of the subtitle and
keep that at eight.
And now that we have that specified, all we're
missing is an action below, which is 20 steps
away from the chip.
So if I go ahead and go to my assets and type
in my assets panel, type in button, search
for that button.
It's not appearing.
So if I go ahead and re type that and it searches
and I can grab this text button and just drag
that into the canvas.
I can just rename this to action one.
And once this action is being renamed, I can
go ahead and drag it into my new card component
and ensure that the spacing is set accordingly.
Make sure that's set to 20.
That's indicated in the spec here 20 away
and it is eight digit pixels away the the
outer frame of the buttons eight dips away
from the parent container because it will
align the typography with a chip here you
see that that's why that button is eight dips
away because it aligns the typography of the
button with the rest of the content in the
card.
And then I just need to specify that this
is eight dips below the spacing.
So I can grab the parent container hold down
Command as I drag up, make sure that's set
to eight, right now we have it at five.
So just push this down three pixels, and we
are golden.
Awesome.
So we've now created one of the more complex
card components in material design one of
the examples again, so I'm going to go ahead
and challenge you to create this car component
by yourself.
And then I'm going to pause the video and
show you the optimal, optimal way of building
out these car components.
All right, I'm gonna pause.
So I have now finished creating all the elements,
I created this variant here, the exact replica,
and I did it a little differently this time.
And the reason I wanted to go through this
exercise the way I just did before I show
you everything is very intentional, I want
to showcase to you the manual process of building
this component.
And then the power of having these elements
that I just created to, to use as building
blocks for design system, not only for yourself,
but for the designers you cater to if you
ever work on design systems team.
So here, we here you can see that we've created
we've manually created our cards, here are
some examples of have more composed cards.
And then I went ahead during this break, and
not only made these elements here, but I compose
them properly.
So when I say I compose them properly, these
these are all specifically elements for cards,
the width of these cards are defined by 344,
certain variants of them.
And here's like, we have them labeled as elements,
textiles, and you can think of them as tiles
as you, as you add tile onto a floor, you
can arrange them and add them and stack them
and whatnot.
So that's exactly what we're going to do.
So with these elements, I'm gonna go I can
break down what these are composed of.
And then it's wrapped in a frame with the
proper background color, which is set to surface,
the surface and then the proper elevation,
the resting elevations being set to one dip.
And then of course, the the elevated status
set to eight dips there, as you can see the
two differences there.
And in this frame, if I click on this frame,
go ahead and I go ahead and check out.
Whoops, I go ahead and check out the elements
in this frame, I have three pieces in this
component.
So I can drag these out.
And notice that they don't have any background
color applied to them except this is an icon,
I mean image placeholder.
So and see this is what is composed of these
three elements here.
So that is super important to note and understand.
So uses these these elements to start building
and adding on top of each other into the card.
And these are all elements you can have in
your design system.
And it's explicitly.
That's why it's there.
So we can go ahead and build out an example.
So you could create several examples of this.
So we can start off with this heading, I can
copy that heading, and maybe the heading has
supportive text, right.
And then I can go go ahead and add in like
an image, this supportive image above the
heading.
So we have the media and then the heading
there.
And then we have the support of text below.
So what I can do now that these are all connected,
I can select them all and then wrap them in
a frame, I select them all and then I hit
option Command G to create a frame.
And now I'm going to click on the fill color,
go to surfaces and select surface.
Ensure I have the proper rounded corner radius
that that the four pixels or dips there, and
then click clip content.
And we're gonna go to effects and select one
dip on the elevation styles and look out quick,
we were able to build a card component using
elements as opposed to going in and ensuring
everything's pixel perfect dragging and dropping
stuff around.
So if you do it, if you build out these elements
once pixel with pixel precision pixel perfection,
you should be good to go.
Today, we're at a design Academy, and we're
going to be creating some chip components.
And let's just give you the general overview
of this video.
We're going to Overview The chip components
first, how they're used, what they are, and
then also building out these chip components.
And we'll go ahead and open the link here
in our exercise file for the chips documentation.
And once that opens up, go ahead and once
that loads, you can see that chips are compact
elements that represent an input attribute
or action.
So this is here in our design.
This is our chip here as you can see, and
it is essentially in this text Where it's
specifying who to send an email to.
And it's this person labeled Peyton Smith,
named pin Smith, excuse me.
And as you can see, once the email has been
typed out or the username, and it's been selected,
it turns into a chip.
And there is a little image as well to represent
who that user is that profile picture.
And with that context in mind, we can go ahead
and understand the usage.
It allows users to enter information, make
selections, filter content, or trigger actions.
While buttons are expected to appear consistently
and with familiar calls to actions.
shifts should appear dynamically as a group
of multiple interactive elements.
And here you can see the principles they're
intentionally compact, relevant, so they have
clear and helpful relay information, information
in relation to the content or task that is
represented in the UI.
And chips should make tasks easier to complete
or content easier to sort.
And here we have all of the chip types here,
as you can see.
And we have an anatomy of one of the most
complex chips here.
So we have the generic container that holds
all of the chip elements and their size is
determined by those elements.
Here you can see we have an optional thumbnail,
which is the leading icon here, which can
be utilized to identify entities such as profiles,
by displaying an avatar logo or icon there.
And then we also have the the text, of course,
to display the entity name, description, tag
action, or, or conversational.
And then the fourth element to this anatomic
breakdown is the input chips can include a
remove icon, indicating that you can remove
that entire chip if need be.
And we're we have a breakdown of all the usages
for the different types.
But we're not going to get into that I recommend
you going through and consuming that information
as needed.
And here, we have all the types that we're
going to be creating.
But one thing I want you to note is that three
of these chips are the same, but there are
explicitly stated as different chips in this
documentation.
And I just want us to kind of take note of
that and pay attention.
So here in the specs, we have this action
chip, the outline chip choice chip filter.
And we have the input chips and the chips,
an example of chips in groups where they have
a spacing of eight dips there between each
chip.
And you'll notice that the action choice and
filter chip are all the same exact chip, but
the underlying functionality could be different,
which is kind of the point I wanted to get
to there.
And with that stated, we can go ahead and
jump into our finger file and start building
out these chips.
And I'm gonna go ahead, ensure that I have
my material design system library enabled
in this exercise file.
And with that said, we can go ahead and start
creating these chips.
So with this chip credit, I'm gonna go ahead
and create a frame.
And before I do, I'm gonna live copy that
name, label this label this action frame name,
because this is going to be our action chip.
And I'm gonna go ahead and add the the background
color surface under surfaces overlay.
And then I'm going to set the rounded corners
to 16.
So it's nice and nice and round there.
And I'm going to set the height to 32.
And then we'll go ahead and modify the, the
width as needed.
And the nice thing is we'll be able to quickly
add on allows for this.
So it dynamically adapts to the text string
within it.
So you don't have to manually resize it, which
is very helpful.
So I want to go ahead and add this text style
here.
And by adding this textile, I can go ahead
and select the body to textile because that
is what's utilizing chips.
And I can go ahead and label this action chip.
And I want by default, my my my typography
to resize automatically.
And then I'm going to go ahead and center
this.
And what I'm going to do is hold down shift
a, that creates auto layout, then I'm going
to hit shift a again, which creates auto layout
on the parent frame.
And now you'll notice I can adjust the dip
padding to 12 dips the left and right as opposed
to fit the one here, which is what specified
currently.
So if I type in 12, I have now shrunken that
to 12.
And it currently says 13 because autolayout
by default adds one extra pixel horizontally
and vertically to your element, which is annoying
in my opinion.
So we if we reset that you'll now it'll showcase
that it's set to 12 on the left and right
and is vertically centered, which is great
on the y axis and we have now created our
first chip and we can go ahead and bang out
the two other chips here.
The choice chip in the filter So here are
some intricate things to understand about
the design system.
And here is where decisions are made on on
a per team basis, as I like to call it.
So we have this action ship, right.
And there are three types of this, this action
ship where they all look the same visually.
But the the functionality under the hood could
be much different and utilize in different
scenarios.
So say this component, built in code is represented
differently, does that mean you want to reflect
that in your designs as well? Or do you just
want to utilize the same exact design and
just call that the action chip, instead of
having the actual chip choice and filter chip?
Well, to be consistent, in terms of the naming
conventions you have in your design files,
and what engineers have developed on the front
end, you may want to create three, three variants
of this.
So in order to do so all of the styling is
the same.
So I'm just going to duplicate this, and I'm
going to make this action ship a component.
And with that being a component, I'm going
to label this label.
And then I'm going to go ahead and rename
this the the choice ship, and then enter and
rename the frame as label.
And then I'm going to rename this filter chip,
I'm gonna label that filter.
And I'm gonna rename this text autolayout
frame to label layer two label, I can go ahead
and select both of these, both of those elements
and click on that and select create multiple
components.
And now I have all three component variants,
which is very important, what I'm going to
need to do is rename them.
So this is the choice chip.
This is the filter chip.
And now we are rocking and rolling, we have
those three variants knocked out of the park.
And what we can do now is focus on the outline
chip and the input chip.
So with that said, I'm going to go ahead and
grab this chip here, to get a head start.
And what this chip has currently is I'm gonna
detach this and label this out action outlined.
And once it's labeled properly, I'm going
to go ahead and get rid of the autolayout
by holding down Command Option, actually just
Option Shift A, then I'm going to do the same
exact thing to the other autolab frame layer,
and then hit Option Shift a and then hit Command
Shift G to remove that frame from the Texas
it's not needed.
So with this typography here, what we're going
to need right now is an icon placeholder because
this is an outline chip.
So what I can go ahead and do is in this file,
I already have an icon placeholder, copy that
and I'm going to hold that command on this
bounding box on the left to stretch that out
and paste this and I'm going to snap this
to the left.
And make sure that is four pixels to the left
there and is centered vertically, and then
move this text over, add this constraint to
set the constraints in this text right and
center on the y axis and then push this over
until the typography is eight pixels away
from the icon here.
So it's got to move this over about essentially
three pixels.
So I got to move that over one more pixel.
Whoops, there we go.
Once that's specified there, we got those
specs set properly.
We've got a and the padding is set to 12 tips
on the right and eight on the left, we are
good to go.
And that is our action outlined action chip.
I am what we're going to want to do now is
specify a one pixel stroke and set that to
inside which it already is by default, and
we're going to add the surfaces overlay color
to the stroke but I'm going to remove that
color style right there.
And I'm going to go to surfaces Overlay and
I now have that specified and if that icon
placeholders too hard to see we can change
the color of that.
And now we have our action outline chip and
we can go ahead and even add auto layout to
this so it the spacing is dynamic, so you
don't have to manually do this all the time.
So I hit shift a to make auto layout and then
I'm going to remove the default horizontal
and vertical padding And then realign this
up, you have to realign it when you do that,
and then I'm going to go ahead and move that
over, make sure that's four dips to the left
here.
And then we'll add that to this as well, and
remove the, the one pixel padding added and
re realign these elements, which is annoying.
And then what I'm going to do is go ahead
and shift click on on both of these in the
Layers panel and hit shift a.
And what I've essentially done is maintain
the spacing between this this these two elements
by creating that parent.
And now what I can do is go ahead and select
my action outlined frame the parent frame
and hit shift a.
And I can go ahead and specify the spacing
for that element as well.
And it will be dynamic, but one thing to note
is that this can auto layout can get tricky,
because you can't individually specify the
the spacing.
So if I want this to be 12 on this side, it's
currently not possible to do that thought
all out.
So what you can do is just go ahead and undo
those actions.
And you may have to manually readjust this.
And we'll tackle this in the in the next in
our next video in our next section of the
course Excuse me.
So now that we've created this outline action
chip, we can go ahead and duplicate it, and
then create that as a main component.
Once that's specified, we go ahead and start
tackling this input chip more is slightly
different, we're gonna, I'm gonna have to
end up removing the auto layout in frames,
here.
And then.
So I was using shortcut key Option Shift a
to remove the auto layout and then Command
Shift G to remove the frame.
As that is what is left.
Once you create remove auto layout, it turns
into a frame and then you have to remove the
frame.
So with that set, I will label this and put
whoops and put ship.
All the proper padding has been specified
right now we have that icon placeholder.
And now we need to add a an actionable icon
here.
And I already have that in here in our design
system library that is called the cancel icon.
So I can copy that.
Select your your parent frame, and then paste
it in there.
If need be, whoops, I'm going to drag this
here.
And I'm going to reset the size to 18 by 18.
And go ahead and drag this into this component
and tshirts vertically center and snap that
to the right and push that over roughly Yep,
eight dips.
And with that specified, we now have our input
chip.
But what we're going to need to do is set
the constraints on this action icon to right
in center vertically.
And then I'm going to go ahead and push this
content over so that there's only eight dips
between the text and this action icon.
And we're going to set that icon placeholder
to left and center vertically.
And then let set this to left and center vertically.
And then move this over and ensure I have
that spacing set appropriately.
So I have eight dips on the left and right
of this text.
And one thing I'm missing is a fill.
And I need to remove the stroke and add the
surfaces overlay color to this chip.
And once I've specified that we are now good
to go and we've created all of the chip types
for our design system.
All we need to do is label this input.
And once we specify that we have now created
all the main components necessary for our
chips.
And that is all I have to show you today.
Thanks so much for watching, and I'll catch
you in the next one.
I think I almost forgot, in addition to our
autolayout autolab tends to resize the height
of your components.
So we want to make sure we go into our components
here as we have the proper constraints set.
We want to double check we have the proper
constraints set for our components.
And with auto layout specified on some of
these components, we're going to want to resize
some of these elements and ensure they're
good to go.
Just make sure that's set to 32 is the height
for all of these chips are set to 32.
And I'm gonna go ahead and do the same thing
for the rest of these components.
And since the constraints are set to center
vertically, they will dynamically adjust properly.
And some of these have auto layout.
So I can't just manually adjust the height
with auto layout implemented.
So what I can do is, is remove that auto layout
and readjust that height.
And do the same thing here with this component.
Notice that when I remove the auto layout,
you can't see it, I'm using a shortcut key
Option Shift a, it preserves the the master
I mean main component icon.
But watch, watch this can't watch the bounds
change, I'll be able to change the height
after this.
So I just hit Option Shift a, it's now changed
the bounding box, and I'm going to go ahead
and crease that by one pixel on each side.
All the spacing is maintained and whatnot,
and we are good to go.
We'll be building out dialogues.
And we're gonna start off with understanding
what dialogues are and how they're used and
why.
And we're going to build out variants of that
dialogue.
And I'll also challenge you to building out
some variants as well, I have all the screenshots
here specified of the barriers we'll be making.
And then we'll go ahead and just dig into
the documentation by opening this link.
Once you have that open here you can see that
dialogues inform users about a task and contain
critical information and require decisions
or involve multiple tasks within that dialog.
So here, we can see that this dialogue is
triggered based on a button right.
And you'll notice that there's this background
overlay, we that's called a scrim.
And we have that in our design system as a
color style not only as a color style, but
scrim that we can pull from our system.
So if we go to our figma file, let's just
enable that here.
For go access our team library modal turn
on the material design system library, I could
go ahead and search for scrim and we already
have it accessible, we can drag and drop it
here to utilize later.
So that is a scrim for you and used in this
context.
And then you can see that there's some elevation
around the edges of this dialog being used.
And there's a divider, and in this in this
confirmation variant, you'll see that there's
this menu with some content overflowing.
So we'll go ahead and build out this this
variant.
And we'll go ahead and build out a what is
labeled a simple dialog here in this interactive
demo, where we have list items here.
And you'll notice that the states of these
do not spam the entire width of the dialog,
which is interesting.
So if we were to inspect the code, you'll
see that this this is a list item.
And there's some some padding set to 16 on
the left and right of this element.
So that is important to note there.
And on top of that in the parent element,
there is a padding of eight on the left and
right as well.
So that is padding on the left and right of
this dialog that is not applying to the list
items.
So that's why there's there the the state
there is not taking up the full width of that
element.
I'm going to close that Inspect Element.
And now we also have an alert dialog variant
as well, which we'll be building.
And not only are there those variants for
that, but you see there's one with just body
copy, just text and with the title.
Or, you know, we have the buttons side by
side or we have the option to have two buttons
stacked.
To me, I prefer the side by side variant that
seems to be a much more common pattern utilized.
And you'll see that there are other options
as well in this dialog, not for simple, but
for the confirmation.
There's the stacked variant of buttons as
well and side by side.
And we're gonna just go ahead and kind of
just understand the usage.
So a dialog is a type of modal window that
appears in front of an application or app
content right to provide critical information
or ask for decision dialog, disable all app
functionality when they appear and remain
on screen until confirmed dismissed or a required
action has been taken.
And these are purposely interruptive which
is which refers back to how this is displayed
in front of app content is purposely interruptive.
So they should be used sparingly.
And there's some principles around this component
where it is focused.
It focuses the user attention to ensure their
content is addressed at that point in time
quickly.
Dialogue should be direct and communication,
in communicating information and dedicated
to completing a task, dialogue should appear
in response to a user task or an action with
relevant or contextual information.
So it is very helpful and direct.
And here, you can see when to use either a
snack bar banner or dialogue and way dialogue
is used when these these, the the task at
hand needs to be very focused in this is considered
high priority.
So it blocks the app content below it until
the user takes the actions on the dialog or
exits the dialog if the options available.
And here you can see some examples there on
mobile and, and the anatomy breakdown.
We've got the container title here, some supporting
text and the buttons and the scrim in the
background which we've already pulled in their
finger file.
And we got some specs down here, we're gonna
just go ahead and dive right in and start
building some of these elements out.
So we can go ahead and start with the desktop
mobile alerts.
So I'm going to grab this here, I've already
had these labeled to place in our sticker
sheet.
And what I'm going to do is select these images,
move them over.
Here, I've referenced the typestyles as well,
so we know what to utilize.
And with this specified, I'm going to set
the width to 560 dips, and with the width
specified properly, I'm gonna set the height
to 182 dips and uses a corner radius of four
dips.
And then it uses the color surfaces surface
for the background, the fill, and then of
course utilizes the effect style of elevation
of 24 dip there.
And now we have the baseline specified, we'll
go ahead and rename this component to desktop,
forward slash mobile alert as that is the
dialog variant label material design.
And we're gonna go ahead and create an H six.
With an H six created, I'm going to label
this dialog header as specified in the file
there in the screenshot, set the autos, the
sizing to auto width, the resizing, go ahead
and select my h six.
And with that specify, we can go ahead and
rock and roll here, I'm gonna snap this to
the top and, and left, so it's 24 dips from
the left and the baseline set to 40, which
I believe is 24 minutes from the top as well.
And we can go ahead and double check that
here by just creating a rectangle and pushing
this content down.
So the baseline supposedly set to 40.
So I actually need to go ahead and push this
up a bit.
And in turn making that padding 21 dips from
the top there with the baseline set to 40.
As you can see.
So now that that is specified, we go ahead
and specify our color style for that header.
And go in to our color styles, text and iconography
and select the high emphasis color style,
we'll go ahead and duplicate that text and
select the body one color textile.
And now we have the proper textile set, we
need to specify the color style to medium
emphasis.
And what we can do essentially is specify
the bounding box of this.
And by specifying the bounding box here, I'm
going to go ahead and start to just pay attention
the specs.
And the baseline is supposed to set to 36
dips from the baseline of the header.
So we could essentially just do that create
a whoops, create a push this rectangle down
to the baseline, set that to 36 here.
So I just need to push this content up a tad.
So now the baseline set to 36 there.
And the bounding box here set to 24 bits on
the left and right of this text box.
So what I can do is address this to be a fixed
text box.
And that's currently at 23.
Let me push that three pixels.
And now it's at 24.
And we want to set the constraints to left
and right so I'm holding Shift and selecting
that right constraint.
And then what we can do is if I keep typing
lorem ipsum to lorcet Matt, and just keep
on typing and a new line will appear.
So with that new line appearing, we're going
to go we now just need to justify that the
art we need to have we need to justify our
text buttons here.
And our text buttons will potentially be 28
dips from the baseline from the bottom here.
From The container.
So here, what I'm trying to explain is that
the height of this bottom portion of the dialog
is emphasized.
So it's essentially in, you could think of
it as being in its own row, where the content
being the buttons within this bottom row here,
almost like the footer of this dialog utilizes
two buttons, and the height set to 52.
And it's centered within that, that bottom
row there.
And this text is essentially what the saying
is that this body copy is 28 dips from the
from the baseline of the text here, you see
that distance from here to that that container
row.
So to really get that precise, what we can
do is I'm going to create a frame here, you
could call this dialogue, you could you we
all reference this as footer, and I'm going
to specify the height there to 52 dips.
And of course, snap that to the left and bottom,
it's going to hold command and stretch that
out and specify the constraints there to bottom
left and right.
And we there's no need for a background.
And we need to implement buttons into this.
So if we grab open our team library, go to
text button.
If I type in button, I got my text button
there, and it's labeled in the spec of action
one.
And I duplicate that, and it's eight dips
away from this button, and then modify that
text to say action to we are rocking and rolling,
go ahead and bring this in and actually just
drag this into that row and specify see how
it is center aligned that So essentially,
our spacing is all proper, good to go, we
have the proper spacing there, eight dips
between the two buttons, and to the right
and the bottom, and the top.
And because of the height being specified
to 52 for that bottom footer, and we're good
to go.
And all we need to do is really just justify
the distance here between here and so 28.
So we're essentially to two pixels off, supposedly,
but this is accurate enough.
And it is 23 degrees away from from there
the text box, and we can go ahead and modify
that.
So it's set to 24.
For now, it's 2024 dips away, and we are good
to go.
This is all properly spaced.
And we now have this mobile alert dialog variant,
which is up to spec and we can make that a
master component.
Before I do, I'm going to duplicate that.
And it's a main component, I apologize.
So we have our main component variant.
I'm going to drag that in here.
And now that we have our main component variant,
I'm going to go ahead and see what we'll tackle
next, what should we tackle next? Well, we
can go ahead and create this confirmation
dialog with actions.
Nothing too special about this.
The width isn't actually specified in this
and it would kind of just be tedious to build
that one out.
So let's start with this one.
Actually, not we do have all the details necessary
disregard what I stated, we're going to build
up the mobile confirmation dialog.
So I'm going to copy that there.
Go ahead and rename this.
Now that I've renamed it, I need to specify
the width.
And we have the two actions.
And what we can do is this will resize because
we have the constraints set properly.
And we need to set constraints to both these
buttons.
And these buttons currently are, are snapped
to the top and left of its parent frame, but
we need to snap to the bottom and right so
when it resizes it will resize properly.
So what we can do is we have all the property
specified properly.
So we're good to go.
All we have to do is set the width from 560
dips to 280 dips, and look at that we have
everything constrained proportionately.
The only thing is we need to push this content
down.
And with that content pushed down with the
content pushed down, we should just specify
the spacing between this text and the the
footer row.
And as you can see it's 28 pips away from
the baseline.
So let's go ahead and ensure that that is
implemented properly.
It's going to change that to 28.
And what we're going to do is make sure that
when we resize this, this parent frame is
a set a ruler here within this frame right
here.
So as I resize it, I know that it as I resize
the parent frame, I know I need to push this
up one more pixel, I was hoping that that
red line would help me align the content,
but it does not actually do that it's not
responsive, those red lines, they stay in
place.
And then I'm going to drag this text box down
and ensure that that's set to 24.
So there we go, that that proper spacing there
on the left and right and bottom.
And we now have our confirmation dialog variant
there.
And again, this is adhering to a one line
variant.
There's also this is also indicating a two
line dialog header there with two lines.
So we could even go ahead and do that if we
wanted to.
So I can go ahead and do that real quick.
So we will have to push down this content
essentially.
So with that, I'm going to just push this
copy down.
And then right to bash line dialog header,
we now have our two line, I'm going to push
this up to 14, because that gives me the proper
spacing here.
of 36 dips there, from from one baseline to
another.
So that's set to 36, as I've stated, which
is awesome.
So that's properly, proportionately implemented.
And now I just need to justify the spacing
of between this text and the actions.
So that's set to 28 depth, so we can do is,
this should be much easier is actually go
ahead and put push this content, create that
28 dip rectangle to align things, and just
push this up for four dips there, and delete
it.
And now our baselines are aligned as specified
in the spec.
And what I can do is select Resize to Fit
or the shortcut key Shift Option command R.
And that should resize the content to the
parent container, which is awesome.
Or you can just hold down Command until it
until it snaps to your container.
And you now have your two two line dialog
header.
And we can go ahead and create this confirmation
dialog with long actions that are stacked.
So the difference between this one is that
these buttons are side by side.
And these are stack.
And all we have to do is we're not to do a
little more moving around here.
So they're in this scenario, there's the concept
of the footer doesn't need to be utilized,
it could be where I'm going to remove that.
And what I'm going to do is rename this to
turn on speed boost.
And with that specified, I'm just gonna align
these properly.
And then make sure they're 12 dips in distance
apart, and make sure that
they're dips from the right of this frame.
So it's a ditch in the right and should be
depth from the bottom as well.
So now that we have that specified, we have
our two buttons.
But what we need to know is the baseline.
So 828, so 36 dips from the frame here.
So when you specify 36 dips from the frame,
essentially what I did was I just calculated
the distance, the distance from this baseline,
and the distance from this between this button
and here, and that's 28 plus eight, which
is 36 five, if I'm doing my math, right, and
I can just go ahead and drag this up till
it snaps there.
And we're aligned.
So I am that appropriate spacing.
And now all I need to do is make sure I drag
up the bottom of this element.
So that is eight depth from the bottom of
the button.
And I could apply my constraints 30 set properly
and we are good to go.
I'm going to specify that this is a confirmation
dialog with long actions.
I'm going to make that a main component and
next up we can create the mobile alert dialog
I just attached my instance, label this alert
dialog.
And the alert dialog is very simple.
It doesn't even have a header, it just utilizes
body copy.
So what we can go ahead and do is add 52 plus
28 plus 38.
Whoops, you can't do math 28 plus 38.
I don't know why it's not doing the math for
me there.
So 28 plus 3866 plus 52, that's 118.
So the height of this element is going to
be 118.
So what we can do is just set this to 118.
And now we can put this text, push this text
up, just make it one line.
And now that we have that one line, I'm going
to set the typography to resize the width,
automatically, I'll then ensure that the baseline
is set appropriately.
So it's set to currently 38 dips from from
the top right now it's 40.
There we go at 38.
There, I can push this content up, excuse
me.
And now I can create a fixed text box.
And I want it to be 24 dips from the right,
or 624.
So if I push this in a little more at 22.
And now I have it set to 24.
And with that specified, I also want the textbox
to be eight dips from the bottom here, I have
this from the bottom of the buttons outer
frame.
So currently, it's set to four.
Now it's set to eight there, and we're good
to go.
We have all the proper spacing specified for
this alert dialog.
And we are good to go.
That is it.
Maybe we can just rename these to cancel and
discard.
And what we can do here is just ensure the
proper spacing is set to 12 currently set
that to eight, and then push this over.
For dips.
Now it's properly spaced, eight Between the
Buttons and bottom and right of the buttons.
So that's great.
And now we have our mobile variant of our
alert dialog.
And now that we've created three of these,
I can, I want to challenge you to building
out this dialog header here.
And we can see that it uses is, well if we
go to our list items, we can easily see that
we could use this variant here that I just
pulled the with the icon and text and the
action, which is another icon.
And we can resize this accordingly.
We can go ahead and actually build this together
by modifying some existing list item components
that we have.
So with that said, we have a we're gonna just
perfect this, this list item here.
So we're gonna label this icon and text, I've
got that list item.
And of course, we've applied constraints already
to this.
So it will be worth picking out of the box
because because we've already defined that,
and we're just going to set the height of
this 256 dips, content stay centered as needed.
And as expected, and then we'll set the height
of this 240 by 40.
But we want the height of the icon to be 40
by 40.
So I go ahead and implement this, with the
icon currently is set to 33 point 33.
So what we can do is I can detach this ungroup
it and I just want to make sure I'm scaling
the vector properly.
And the frame set to 40 by 40.
As you can see, and we can just use temporarily
we have a placeholder.
So if you knew this, actually, you know, refine
that icon later on, you can go ahead and do
that.
But I'm just gonna use this placeholder so
not to mess with the modifying the the icons
that are systematically built from.
For material design.
I'm just gonna change the quarter rate on
this icon placeholder so it's 40 by 40.
And it is 24 dips from the the left of of
this list item.
So now that I've moved that column That's
great.
And the text is 20 dips to the left of, of
the the icon as well.
And I'm going to make sure that constraints
are set to left and center vertically.
And the constraints are good to go on this
text here.
And all I have to do is, I could rename this
here so that the text is matching the, what's
specified in the spec.
And what we can do is just duplicate this
and align this to the bottom of the next list
item.
And just label this user two.
And then I can duplicate this again, and just
type an ad account.
And feel free to modify the fill of this and
change that to the image type and add an image
as needed.
As it utilizes icons, there are now that the
spacing specified on these three list items,
let's go ahead and make the parent container.
So our parent container, I would imagine is
set to Well, in this case set to 320, or two
at a specified here.
And that seems like the same width as a simple
dialog.
So I'm going to create a frame, go to my sticker
sheet and copy that naming convention.
and rename this to the mobile slash simple
dialogue, that the width to 280 corner radius
to four color style the filter surfaces surface
and then the effects to the have the effect
style of utilizing elevation of 24 dips.
And with that, we're going to modify the width
here to whoops, the width is should be good
to go.
What we're going to do is add a an H six here,
what I can do is just copy the H six here.
And then or I can grab this one liner h6 that
I've already created.
And they will position it within this element.
And we need to check and ensure that the baseline
of this is set is 40 depths from the top of
this frame.
And with that, let's see, set that to 40.
Just push, essentially just pushing that up
slightly.
And now that is good to go.
We have our dialogue header and is wrapped
in a a frame that has a height of 64.
So I'm going to set the vertical constraint
to center on the text.
So when I resize the frame I just wrapped
it in it will stay in position as needed.
So it's set to 60.
Now it's set to 60 for the height set to 64
dips, and it did not properly do what I wanted
it.
So I'm going to make sure it's centered within
that frame, then push that to the top, hold
down Command and resize this header frame
header, I'm going to label that header.
Now I have that set properly.
And then all these list items will stack on
top of this frame.
So I can now that they're stacked, these are
appropriately sized, I just need to adjust
the width.
And we're good to go.
All I need to do is justify resizing this
bottom portion.
And I may need to add 16 dips there, the bottom
is currently set to 870 and increase that
17% up one and we're gonna go.
So we now have achieved our simple dialog
variant.
And we have a couple more to create if we
want.
I'm actually going to challenge you to building
out the last two elements.
And what you're going to find yourself doing
in creating these last two is we've created
these four together.
But in these dialogues, you're going to find
yourself building out some complex dialogues
here, you're going to come across this, these
items or the items overflow and are are being
hidden because of the overflow because we
have this, these actions appearing above and
the user can scroll through these items and
select one.
So I'm going to challenge you to building
that and also challenge you to building out
this fullscreen dialog.
What you're not building are these text input
fields in the interface.
You could But for the fullscreen dialog, we
might, that's just a bonus for you to create,
and challenge yourself.
And, yeah, I'm just gonna pause this video
and build out this scrolling confirmation
dialog.
And I'll be right back.
So I've now built out my scrolling confirmation
dialog variant for mobile.
And essentially what I did was I just recreated
it, let me go ahead and grab it.
So our other mobile variant, our simple dialogue,
what I did was I copied this, detached it.
And I went to my assets and grabbed my radio
checklists, Marriott.
And then I wrapped that in a frame, I set
the height, as you can see here, to 48.
And I just specified the proper spacing between
all the elements within this list item, then
I just duplicated them.
And they were because they're supposed to
stack on top of each other.
And since our buttons are labeled properly,
I was able to just swap them between the two
states, which was awesome, set the constraints
to vertically, be centered if this height
ever gets modified.
And then I grabbed the footer here, and move
that to the top of the layer order.
So it looked like it looks like you're able
to scroll through this content, as indicated
here.
And this footer was already created, all I
had to do was add a divider into this element.
And I snap that divider to the top here in
the footer element in the footer frame.
And that's all I had to do.
And that's how I created that dialogue there.
And yeah, that was how I built that.
And that is all I have to show you today and
building out dialogues.
I hope you learned a lot and enjoyed this
video.
And I challenge you as a bonus to create this
fullscreen dialogue.
We are going to be going over date pickers
and we're going to gain a general overview
of what date pickers that are out there and
when and how they're used.
And then we're going to build out some date
pickers ourselves.
And here we have the documentation.
And I'm gonna go ahead and open the link.
And once your link opens, as you can see,
date pickers let users select a date or a
range of dates, as you can see here.
This specifies the current date and then the
selected date here.
And we have a header little edit icon to edit
the date from this field here, this header,
drop down menu there and some some arrows
to move between months.
and serve.
There's some elevation being utilized.
And here's a breakdown of the anatomy of a
mobile calendar date picker.
And here you can see that it has a title up
above and then the selected date here being
represented.
And then it has the switch to keyboard input
icon, which is what this is called.
And then it has the year selection menu.
And we also have the the pagination for going
from month to month either forward or backwards.
And then we have the current date here.
This is represented with this outline.
And then we have the selected date here with
a primary color as the background specified,
and some actions there to cancel or hit OK.
And you can see what the mobile date range
picker looks like.
So here's a mobile calendar date picker.
So this is a calendar date picker.
And then we have the date range picker.
So you can specify a start date and a end
date.
And then this is the selected range here with
the lighter primary color in the background.
Then we have a mobile input picker variant,
bunch of breakdowns of the anatomy there,
and whatnot.
And this video is going to be very dense.
There's a lot of things going on in this date
picker component, and we're going to do, we're
going to break it down, we're gonna we're
really going to simplify it and start off
with the little elements that it's composed
of, and then build out those elements accordingly.
And with that mental model in mind, we'll
be able to tackle building out these complex
components.
So that is awesome.
And we're going to be building out not only
mobile variants, but also desktop variants.
So that that's great.
and here if we go to our specs, you can see
that that we have touch targets specified
for a mobile date picker, where the touch
target size for a date picker is set to 32
by 32 dips.
And that the this is the recommended approach
here And the outer container is set to 40
by 48 nips.
And here we're starting to see the specs of
what the calendar header looks like here.
So that is very important.
And a bunch of specs specified to right there,
so you don't miss anything, since there's
a lot going on.
And here you can see a calendar view for the
mobile date picker, and a year selection view.
So on and so forth, we're going to be covering
these heavily in figma.
So let's jump right into it.
So here, I have a, our soon to be sticker
sheet here.
And here's a couple of elements we'll be building
out.
So we have the mobile calendar header right
here that we're going to build out, and our
mobile calendar picker tool, calendar picker
image here to reference.
So I'm gonna move some of these images out
of the way.
So just keep these here, push this image up.
And with that, we can go ahead and get started.
So I'm gonna go ahead and copy this, this
text, because that's going to be the name
of our main component once it's created.
And we can go ahead and start to figure out
what the, the width of this calendar view
should be in that set to 328 dips.
So we type in 328.
We know how the width specified, but what
we need to identify Next is the height of
this calendar header.
So here, you can see that it's set to 120.
And then we have 32 plus 24, so 100 and then
plus 120.
So with that, we get 176.
And the height of this is set to 176.
And now that we have the height, specified
properly, we're going to want to also specify
the rounded corners on this parent frame.
So set the rounded corners into an independent
corner.
So we're going to want to set it to the top
left and top right, and set that to four.
Now our corners are rounded on the top.
And we're going to need to do is add in overline
text property here.
As you can see, the baseline is set to 32
dips.
So if we go ahead and whoops, pull out our
text tool, and just specify select date, and
then change the text style to over line, we
now have select date specified and all of
our content will be 16 dips to the left, and
ensure are actually 24.
My apologies set to 24 dips to the left here
in this header.
And then we're gonna check that baseline.
And sure it's set to 32.
So 30, we're almost accurate.
So now that we have that set there, the baseline
set to 32 are good to go.
And one thing we do need is in this exercise
file, here are some icons, I'm going to copy
this edit icon.
And I need to place it towards the right of
this.
This field, so one thing I need to specify
is that what I could do is in my in this component,
if I named this properly in this element,
which is a calendar header, I can start to
wrap these elements accordingly.
So maybe I want to turn this into a frame
and label this select date row.
And with this Rowse, I could, what I want
to do is make sure that I hold out command
and snap this to and drag this to the top
and right edges of the parent frame.
So that way this content is being isolated
from the the text field here because you see
this box specified here this entire screen
you can think of it as a row when you implement
this in development.
And then we have a another row below it with
a big header.
So we'll go ahead and add that I believe that
as an h1, I'm going to specify that exact
date, November 17.
On Monday, go to my text styles and select
the h1 and it's clearly not an h1, we're going
to want to change that to an h3.
This looks like it's actually an h4.
So I'm gonna snap this to the bottom right
and what we want to do is make sure that our
text here Is 24 dips from the left.
And not only that, we're gonna have to go
ahead and align our icons here.
But on top of that, our typography here, you'll
notice in this component below, we have another
portion of the header that has a white background.
So what we're going to do is specify the distance
here.
So we have 128 72.
So we have a distance, I believe I have about
roughly 16.
Here, it's not really clear.
So if we subtract 72 plus 3200 420, mm is
104, we're getting 16.
So yes, we want to ensure that we have specified
the height of the bottom portion.
So what we can do is if we change this background,
or these colors to text, and I cannot content
on primary, and then I can change this to
content on primary as well.
And I go ahead and select the background fill
of this, the container, the component, and
I select that the primary, all I have to do
is I can even duplicate this row, delete the
text in that frame, and, and specify this
background to be set to surfaces surface.
And I just need to ensure that the height
is set appropriately.
So it's set to what is that 32 plus 24, which
will give us 56, the height set to 56 on this
on this element.
And I can just make sure that it snaps to
the bottom there.
And with that justified, I just need to make
sure that this typography whoops, this typography,
and icon is our our 16 dips from the bottom,
which we have now justified and 24 dips in
the left and right.
And as you can see here, whoops, the typography
is 64 dips to the left of this icon, which
now that everything is set proportionately,
we are good to go.
So I just need to make sure this icon is aligning
to the baseline of the type text in this date
picker.
So you push that down one pixel.
And now that is being aligned.
So that is great.
And we are rocking and rolling.
So we're almost done, we need to go ahead
and build out our typography here.
So here you can see that there is padding
on the top and bottom of this section here,
this date picker row.
So I can specify that.
And once that is specified in this date picker
row, I'm going to need to ensure I have the
proper typography specified.
And this looks like it's utilizing a caption
textile.
So this will essentially be centered.
And with that caption text text style, notice
type in November 2018.
Select my caption text style.
and center it since it's wrapped in a row
that has a height of 56 and specifies that
the baselines 32 pixels from the top of this,
I'm just going to center it as it clearly
is centered in this element.
Ensure that set to 24 dips in the left.
And we're also utilizing a a arrow down drop
down arrow drop down icon.
So I can copy this here.
Go ahead and select this date picker row,
paste it in and start moving this until it
is four dips to the left of this text.
So now that that is up to spec here for dips
there from left to this text.
And now that that is implemented, we can go
ahead and add the icons for moving between
months.
So I have both of those here.
I'm going to copy those and specify the spacing
to 24 between the icons and there's a spacing
of 24 as well right here.
So I can actually Just go drag these in here.
And once these are dragged in, just kind of
move these elements accordingly.
And now we are good to go, we have created
our header.
And we can go ahead and double check spacing
as needed there 16 dips sit on top and bottom
between our elements there.
And we can even wrap these two together if
needed.
You can apply constraints and in relation
to its parent element.
So I'm setting everything here to left and
center vertically, then I'll set these two
icons to right and center vertically.
So if they stay on their sides, if they move,
the width gets there any changes in width
there, I'm going to also select the date picker
row, and just specify that it's always stays
on the bottom and is set to left and right
so that it is constrained proportionately.
And we should be good to go.
So now with this calendar header created,
we can go ahead and start to use this element
across other mobile elements as well.
So if I go ahead, and I can just duplicate
this in case, I want to create a variant of
it, but establish this as a main component
and then duplicate that, we can go ahead and
proceed to tackling our first date picker,
which is the mobile input picker.
So what we're going to do is we have the header,
so we can copy the header.
And we need a text input field here.
So if I go to my assets and ensure that we
always have our material design system library
on, I'm going to go ahead and search for text
input.
And whoops text fields.
Sorry.
And then I can go ahead and just access a
text input field.
And we can go ahead and select, say, this
component.
And what this component specified, we're going
to want to wrap this in a frame as well.
And just pay attention to the specs here.
So the specs have the set to 16 dips on top
from the top.
And what we need to do is create a parent
container.
So we're going to establish this as the mobile
mobile input picker.
So this parent container will be called the
mobile slash input picker, then I'm going
to specify the height to 264.
You'll see that there's some space there.
And then I'm going to go ahead and use this
variation of the the component here.
And just reference that.
And place this into the container has the
proper padding on the left and right already
just need to ensure that the padding on the
top set to 16 there, which it is.
And now we just need to implement a background,
which is set to Ville surfaces surface.
And one thing to note is that we need to specify
the corner radius of the parent container
to for all around.
And also, since this is a modal, here, in
this scenario, we need to specify the elevation
224 24 dip elevation on the parent container.
And now we can go ahead and just use this
example textfield.
Notice that it isn't the right type of textfield.
But this is just an example of the implementation.
And here you'll notice that we might need
another header variant.
So that's kind of why I duplicated this here.
So I want to actually maybe go ahead and delete
this date picker row.
And before I delete that date picker, I'm
gonna go ahead select the parent container
and move this content up and make sure it
snaps and then delete that day pick a row
below and make that a main component and duplicate
it.
And then we'll use this one instead.
So if I go ahead and delete that, can I paste
this and snap it to the top, I can move this
element up.
So that is 16 picks dips from the top.
We now have that date picker and the width
is still set to is set to 364.
So I need to change that to 264 and we're
going to go ahead and implement some text
only buttons now.
So I'm gonna go to my assets.
Just pull in that text button and I need two
of them.
I need one that is says okay, so I'm gonna
go ahead and drag that in there.
And we're going to want to do is snap that,
in ensure that the typography aligns with
the end of this text input field, which it
does, meaning that this parent frame of the
button is 16, dips to the right from the container,
they're added to 16 dips from the bottom as
well.
So that is equivalent, equal size.
And I'm gonna type in cancel on this textfield.
And once that's specified, we'll just align
that here with this other button, and it has
to be eight dips to the left of the OK button.
So now, we have created our mobile input picker
quickly.
And this is one of the easier date pickers
to implement.
So with that, I'm going to make this a main
component, which is great.
Now we got to, we got our first date picker
here for mobile.
And next, we're going to tackle one of the
more complex components.
So here, you'll start to see what these are
composed on.
Maybe we'll start with your selection view,
it's a little simpler to tackle at first,
not as overwhelming.
But this is how we're going to break down
this component.
So what are we seeing here? Well, we're seeing
that we need to create units, we can call
these units or these cells, which will be
our elements, Id elements for date pickers.
And these elements contain the the text, of
course, and it's giving us the dimensions
of this, this cell that we're going to create,
and it's 52 dips in height, and it is 88 dips
wide.
So we're gonna essentially, and it has a selected
state variant.
So we're going to need to make that selected
state as well.
And that is Best Buy here.
72, dips wide and 36 dips in height, and it
utilizes the primary background color.
So that's great.
And we already have our header component here.
So we can go ahead and bring a copy of that
here.
And you'll notice that it doesn't utilize
in the year selection view for the mobile
input data input picker, doesn't utilize those
icons there.
So we can go ahead and just remove those.
So when we delete those instances, in our
instance, it'll just hide them, which is fine,
don't worry about it.
And we can go ahead and start to create these
cells, right.
So what we're going to go ahead and do is
create a frame, label this elements space
slash space, year selection, cell.
And then we can label that the default cell,
because we're going to have an active cell
or selected cell to actually, we can label
that this one unselected.
And then we're going to create another one
later called selected.
So now we have both those ensure that the
bill is set of surfaces surface, we're going
to go and we're going to do is just specify
the height for both of these 250 to kill two
birds with one stone there.
And the width for both of them is set to 88
dips.
That's fantastic.
Now we have typography in the middle.
So on the cell, we have text, we can, let's
see 2011, I can select that 2011.
And I'm going to make sure this typography
set to high emphasis, and then ensure that
the resizing set to auto width.
And now I need to apply the proper text style.
So it looks like it uses a caption.
So it looks like it uses a caption, I'm trying
to just verify that their looks accurate.
We can also reference the documentation if
we ever get confused on what textiles being
utilized some, but I have not found any specifications
on that.
So here we have that typography.
For the text, maybe we want to apply.
Let's double check and see if we need to utilize
the body text style.
That looks much better.
So we apply that body textile just center
it vertically and horizontally with the command,
I mean, the shortcut keys, option V and H
we should be good to go.
So we have the cell.
And now that we have that honestly, that was
the only thing we were missing.
We just need these the variant of this.
So the variant of this, I'm going to copy
that text, paste it and with this cell, let's
just set the constraints to center vertically
and horizontally.
And then do the same exact thing here within
this container cell.
So just stay center but there's not going
to be a scenario where we need to resize them.
Just for for best practices.
So with the selected variant, we're gonna
have to select the color content on primary,
I know we can't see it, but we're gonna end
up creating a rectangle with a width of 72
dips and a height of 36.
And we're gonna have to round out the corners
of this, we can change the corner radius to
24.
There, I'm gonna center this, place this behind
the typography, using command left bracket,
so it changes in the layering order.
And label that to state overlay.
And now, we can go ahead and change the fill
color to primary.
And we have now achieved our selected state.
And we should also specify that the typography,
both the both of the alignments are set to
text align center.
So it resizes from from the middle, when your
designers are renaming this.
And we should be good to go.
So now that we have both these cell variants,
let's go ahead and just build out this year
selection view.
So here, you can start to see how we're building
these modular elements to build out entire
interfaces.
So I'm going to create these multiple components
to have this one already.
And we're going to want to go ahead and just
move these up.
And I'm going to duplicate this on selected
variant whoops.
What's up duplicated that, what we want to
specify is, let's say I'm going to wrap this
in a frame label this.
I'm going to grab the naming convention for
this, the mobile This is the mobile year selection
view, date picker variant.
So this frame will be labeled exactly that.
And I'm going to apply a background color
a fill color of surfaces surface.
So now, I'm just going to stretch that height
out, because we haven't defined that exactly
yet.
But we will.
And you'll notice that there's also a divider
being used in this component, and then the
content gets cut off under it.
So we have three, five.
So with this component selected, let's make
sure it's within our, our frame here.
So I'm going to drag that in there, snap that
to the left, make sure that is has a left
padding of 24 and is snapping to the bottom
of the calendar header.
And what we can do is just go ahead and duplicate
this.
And there you know, there's a spacing of eight
dips between the elements.
And I just hit Command D to duplicate that.
And now we can just shift select all three
of these in this row.
And I can go ahead and just duplicate those
downward, hold down Command D, and they're
all lined, as you can see here, there's no
spacing between them vertically, only in terms
of the width, there's that gutter, so for
five, and then I got six, but I'll save six
for later.
And what we can do if there's way too many
elements here, if that's, that's difficult
for you to read, well, maybe we can just clean
this up by selecting them in a row format.
Or actually, we're going to want to group
these in a column format, because on mobile,
users will scroll through this, these columns
vertically at imagine as opposed to horizontally.
So you could create prototypes of this component
in figma with this column layout, so I'm gonna
wrap this in a frame, label this column, column
one, cell column one, if you want.
Just maybe, maybe, maybe just label it column
one, that might be easier.
And then I'll do the same exact thing for
this set of elements.
Whoops, hold down Command Shift G to rename
it and then rename it column two.
Now we'll go ahead and tackle the third one.
Very straightforward.
Group it, rename it column three.
And one thing about these columns is that
there's there's five rows here, and in each
column that are cut off, there's a sixth row
that gets cut off, but we're going to save
that and go ahead and implement our buttons
once more.
And we had already created the cancel and
ok buttons here.
So I'm going to Command click On these, hold
Shift return to select the parent layers and
copy that.
And the padding set to 16 and 16.
Oh, each side, I'm going to select the parent
frame here and paste these and move them down
and ensure that they're set to 24.
And I believe, whoops, 24 on the right, and
then 16 on the bottom, or eight on the bottom,
I believe.
Let's see, that looks correct.
Looks like it does.
And then we're going to ensure that we have
a divider eight dips above.
And we're going to go to our assets panel
and just pull in that divider.
and specify the width here, we want to make
sure we have that width specified and make
sure our parent container is for dip corner
radius.
So with this divider, need to change the width
to 328 to span the full width of the the date
picker there.
I'm going to drag that in there.
push that up.
So it's eight dips from the buttons.
And now all we're going to do is select our
columns, hold down Command and drag it to
the to snap to our divider.
And select clip content.
And what we're gonna do in each row is I'm
gonna hold column, Command D, and then drag
this so it snaps.
So you can see that one, when this content
gets pushed down, it whoops, the content gets
pushed down, it is ignored.
So that's important.
But you can't actually see it in the way we've
currently implemented it.
One thing we do need to add is a selected
state, for example.
So I could go ahead and delete this, copy
this instance, select that column and whoops,
select the second column or any column and
paste it in there.
And just make sure it's aligned appropriately.
And we know how that your selection view implemented.
And we now have our our date picker views
or your selection view of them look, just
copy these once more.
So here we have that column.
But you can't actually see it, and how we
specified it currently.
But you get the idea of this component, although
it appears to be hidden.
So we can do the same exact thing here is
duplicating this.
Making sure that are snapping appropriately.
And now I have these column views built out
and we're good to go we have our year selection
view.
So if I ever wanted to actually swap this
component with a selected one, due to our
naming conventions, we can go ahead and do
that very, very quickly in our instance, drop
down menu.
And that is our year selection view.
Make that a main component.
Go ahead and drag that over there.
And now that that one specified we have to
created.
Let's go ahead and tackle one of the more
complex views.
So with this calendar view.
Let's go ahead and copy that naming convention.
Here on mobile, we have the calendar view,
we clearly can utilize the mobile header calendar
header.
So we have that.
So our mobile calendar adders done, we're
going to wrap it in a frame, it's going to
be called mobile slash calendar view.
And we are going to specify the height to
be 512.
Whoops.
And once that's set to 512, we're going to
set the fill color to surfaces surface.
And again, this year selection view actually
has I apologize, in effect style 24 dips,
and so does this calendar view so let's go
ahead and specify that and in this element
need to go ahead and change this 000 color
style to texting iconography high emphasis.
Now that everything is attached color styles
are good to go.
And on this calendar, you'll specify the corner
radius to four dips.
So now that we have that, we need to start
creating these individual cells.
So in this format, we're going to go ahead
and specify the date here.
So it is utilizing a cell of 40 by 40 dips.
So make that frame 40 by 40, set the fill
to surfaces surface and copy this textile
not so paste it in here, and center it and
just the only difference being the color.
So this uses a medium emphasis, color style.
So we need to specify that set that medium
emphasis, I can even duplicate this, whoops,
can duplicate it, I'm sure that that's set
to a number now.
And that is centered.
And the numbers have a color style high emphasis.
We're going to need to name these cells.
So we have we have the it's an element.
And this is the date, cell day SEL.
de sel.
And then we're going to go ahead and copy
that specify this as as the elements date.
Day, so right now date, number.
So you can name it honestly, whatever makes
most sense for you or your team or organization.
And then of course, we're going to need a
Ace unselected variant, which is what this
will be.
And then we'll have a selected variant as
well.
If I go ahead and change that to selected.
And with the selected variant, we need a rectangle
set 36 by 36 dips.
With the primary colors when you change this
color style to content on primary, then go
ahead and create a rectangle within the frame.
set that to 36 or 36 dips and round, round
it out and then center it and use Command
left bracket to push it backwards.
And our now that we have this selected state,
we need to change the fill color to primary.
And we now have our text style set properly.
So we may want to push this over one pixel
as it doesn't look centered optically.
But now it does since we push it over.
And with that we can go ahead and make this
a main component.
And everything should be scaling accordingly.
I'll set the constraints properly to the selected
state as well.
And this typography is good to go make that
a main component and make the date day a main
component and the date numbers element component.
And we should be good to go.
All we need to do is start to compose this
accordingly.
So in this variant, you can see that the dates
are displayed and they snap it looks like
right below the right below the calendar header.
So I'm going to make that snap and the padding
left is set to 24.
And all I'm going to do is duplicate this
and make sure it's for four dips to the to
the right.
And then I'm going to duplicate it again and
keep duplicating it.
And since I have that spacing specified, I
am good to go see a duplicate.
Now that I have those three, six, I need to
apply this seven days here in the week.
And I now have that I'm gonna go ahead and
double check my spacing here.
So the spacing is not supposed to be set 24
on the left, it's supposed to be set to 12
for for the cells and that actually selecting
the date and I have it set to 24.
So my apologies.
For now now the content is centered properly
and now we're going to do is go ahead Select
our date number cell and duplicate that and
snap that here.
So that's day one.
And then we're going to go ahead and create
an entire row of this.
And it's going to be very simple, I'm going
to go ahead and create one row with you.
So all we have to do is duplicate it, ensure
that there's four pixel spacing between all
elements here.
And I'm going to just keep repeating that
all the way across the entire row.
And I'm gonna just do the same thing, select
all these elements, and ensure that they all
stack.
And just duplicate that again and duplicate
it again, and I have my, my 556 rows in its
entirety.
And we just need one more, we need the bottom
one, which is day 32.
Go ahead and check that out.
And what we can do, since we have our components
named properly, I can click this and make
sure it's the selected state.
And I'm going to pause this video and go ahead
and add in these buttons and also rename all
these days.
So I'll be right back.
Now I've created this mobile calendar view.
And all I did was I copied the buttons from
our year selection view, because the spacing
specifications are the same on this calendar
view.
So I pasted that in by and I pasted it once
I selected the parent container.
And that did me a big favor and just applied
that exact same position.
And here you go, we have our calendar view,
mature the new main component now.
And we've we've kind of debunked the complexity
of this and the only thing missing is this
current date.
So that is the current date cell.
So we're going to do is duplicate the date
number cell that's selected, and then we're
going to detach that, and I'm going to go
ahead and rename this to current date as it's
a specific cell.
And then, with the current date specified,
I'm going to select my rectangle and apply
a one pixel stroke.
That is, should be set to let's see surfaces
high emphasis, and we're going to delete that
fill.
And we're gonna go ahead and select our text
now and ensure that the content is set to
active or high emphasis.
So that is our current date variant of the
cell.
So what I can do is make this a master component
or main components use me.
And then we can even go ahead and select this
cell in our calendar view now.
And now we have a current date variant.
So now we have that.
And with our current date variant, I'm going
to actually push that pixel one pixel over
to the right, whoops, one pixel over to the
left, make it look more optically aligned.
And we're now good to go.
And now we can go ahead and set this aside
in the calendar view.
We have our the proper cells needed for our
our calendars for mobile.
And we also have a mobile range picker, which
I'm going to set aside and let you challenge
yourself and build that.
And essentially, with this overlay, what you're
gonna want to do is just create an element
that you can overlay or place under all of
these rows here, these are the cells to view
that effect accordingly.
So what we can do in actually our, our calendar
component is go ahead and start to select
all of these.
And you could put them in columns or rows
as needed.
So for example, whatever you and your team
find most efficient, I can specify this as
row three.
Here, you can clearly see that we have row
row one.
So row one, and then this happens to be row
two.
So that's important.
And I just realized I messed up this calendar
view, we need this calendar view to stack
properly.
So if I go ahead and click on this calendar
view, it's actually not positioned properly.
So I need to go ahead and what I'm going to
do is pause this and make all of these rows
and I'll and make sure I push this element
down and I'll be right back on my element
align properly and I grouped them into rows.
Even if there's only one element on that row,
say you were to build out that entire row
moving forward, you could stretch this out
and snap it, you can ensure that the width
snapped appropriately.
And then if you needed to modify it, you can
go ahead and duplicate insert snapping elements
to the, to the end and middle of your elements
as needed.
It's just a quick way to keep things organized.
And just also just keep those layers clean,
it's highly recommended, as you can see here,
and those wrapped into frames.
If not, it's a ton of cells just being viewed
when you expand it in the Layers panel.
So that's why we have our counter view done.
And I'm going to challenge you to build out
the this other view, the mobile range picker
will have a selected state.
And for the selected state, you'll have the
two months as well.
So you can detach the calendar editor and
copy those the tax property and whatnot.
In Yeah, you just need to create like a selected
state element, turned that into component,
and then just put that under the rows.
And you can reference the calendar view for
that.
So now we're going to go ahead and approach
a variant of the desktop.
Desktop is slightly different.
Since it's on a bigger device, you'll notice
that it's very dense.
on the desktop, here, we have a very dense
view, where the cells for the desktop variant
are set to 32 by 32 dips here.
Same same states for each cell, we have the
current date, we have the selected date, and
then we have the default one here.
And yeah, I mean, we're gonna and then we
also have one of the more complex ones, the
date range picker, where it's the where you're
selecting from one month to another month.
And we're going to go ahead and build out
this date range picker.
And then I'm going to challenge you to build
out the the following date range pickers by
yourself as this is a very dense video of
information that shouldn't be good practice
for you.
So we're going to go ahead and start off by
identifying the low level elements.
So with that said, we, we have here, cells
set to 32 by 32.
And then we have these icons.
So I'm going to go ahead and grab these cells
here.
Since we have, since we did apply constraints
to these cells, all we have to do is detach
them, renamed them properly.
And now that I realize it, we're going to
need to categorize these cells.
So these are going to be the mobile versions.
So we're gonna have to categorize all of these
to live under under mobile, because we're
going to have cells for desktop as well.
So I'm just going in, and just renaming certain
elements here.
Just applying mobile.
So just going in copying and pasting real
quick.
And once you've done that, you should be good
to go.
And now the nice thing about this is, since
we renamed all these to mobile, we can go
ahead and copy all these variants, we may
not need these at first, but I'm going to
detach those instances.
And we can go ahead and change if we batch
renamed by select everything, and then hit
command R, and then I type in mobile, I can
then go down to this replace with and type
in desktop.
So now I have my desktop variants.
If we look into the layers here, we have our
desktop cells.
And since our constraints are set properly
to center, we can just modify the parent container
and everything will resize properly so that
that's very helpful.
One thing we are going to want to do is create
this selected state here, this selected this
this range here of the between the the current
date, the selected date, the start date, and
the end date.
So we're going to want to do is create that
right now.
So we need to ensure that we know what the
height of this day is set to so we it might
be referenced In another spec, that selected
date there, let's see.
on desktop the height of that, more than likely
set to 28.
dips in height, slow my go with.
Yep, yep, set to 28.
Now with that said, let's go ahead and just
start cranking this out, I'm going to grab
the icons, I need here, my, my arrows here,
left and right, I'm gonna need my copy this
year.
We don't need no drop down arrow.
So I'm gonna delete that.
I do need this caption textile.
Sure that set too high emphasis.
Go change that here, make sure that's set
to high emphasis.
Know that that's systematize, we can go ahead
and move on, we have a frame here.
And let's go ahead and grab this name here,
desktop date range picker.
So now that I've copied that, select this
parent name, parent frame.
And we'll go ahead and set the corner radius
to four.
And we got a height of width of 512 dips and
a height of 280.
And with that, we can get rolling.
So one thing we can do is focus on the base
layer of the of these components.
Right? So what is the base layer? Well, things
that aren't going to be moving that will stay
in place is and that will be as dynamic dependent
upon the month since are specific days and
each month.
So this will all change these cells.
So that'll vary in like the how many rows
they'll be, there'll be and how many cells
in each row.
But the days will stay.
And the arrow and month will stay in this
divider.
So we're gonna go ahead and add this divider,
this divider takes up the whole height of
this, this date range picker.
So if we go to our assets panel, option to
pull in that divider, I'm going to hit Command
Shift Option type in rotate left, and then
I'm going to now I have it vertically set.
And it's already in my parent frame in the
parent container, which is great, I'm gonna
set the height to 280.
So then I'm gonna just hold down Option v
option h.
So now it is horizontally aligned perfect.
Li in between both sides have this date range
picker, as indicated here.
And if we haven't already, let's go ahead
and change this fill to surfaces surface.
Apply lips, plan effect style of eight dips,
because this is used in menus and sub menus,
like a menu or sub menu.
And now we're gonna go ahead and add in our,
our arrows.
So with that said, we're going to add this
arrow here, add the second arrow there.
And it is 16 dips from the top and right.
So if I snap that, whoops 16 dips from the
top and right, we're good to go there.
And with that applied now we need to go and
copy this textile.
And September here seems to be a 32 dips from
the baseline through two digits from the top
of the parent container.
And the spacing seems to be aligned.
Center horizontally between these elements
specified here.
So if we do 256 minus 32, we get 224.
So if we create a frame of, of 224 digits
wide.
So if I wrap this in a frame, label this as
row one or header row header, I just label
that header.
When I specify this to 224, you'll notice
that that distance gives me 16 digits to the
right.
And why I'm wrapping this in a frame is because
when I copy this text here, and I paste it
in this header, so I'm gonna paste it in there.
And it's in that parent frame.
So I'm going to vertically align and horizontally
align it so that it is vertical here on the
calendar side.
And one thing I could even do is, if I wanted,
I, if I don't want to repeat that, I can delete
this icon.
And what I can do is select the icon here,
and Hold OPTION D and snap that to the right
and then hit Shift H and that aligns properly.
And now I have this spacing set appropriately.
So that's awesome.
So now we have September and October.
So I can rename that.
And one thing we want to ensure is that it's
set to text align center on both elements.
And we're gonna go ahead and specify that
the this typography centers horizontally in
terms of when it resizes.
So that's important.
So go ahead, change that to October 2019,
then we'll change this to sep tember 2019.
And we should be good to go.
Awesome.
So with that specify, we have the header left.
And then we have the header, right.
And these could both be categorized on the
left, like month, left and month, right.
So we're going to start off with these days
here for the desktop view.
And again, there, they have a height of 32
by 32 dips, which we've already specified
here.
And what we want to do is I'm going to select
all these cells here.
And now I want to actually go ahead and resize
these to 32.
And notice that all the content centered and
then it got cropped, right.
But the reason this has been cropped is because
we need to specify this to have a height and
width of 28.
And then I'm gonna go ahead and center that
once more.
And I'm gonna do the same exact thing for
the current date cell type.
So now and then just center that now we are
good to go.
We have pushed us over one pixel so that it
is center and our elements here.
With that center, we are good to go.
So now I'm going to create these multiple
main components.
And I can copy this desktop Daiso is what
it's currently labeled as.
And I'm going to specify the date on both
the left and right sides.
And as you can see here, the spacing here
between the icon above and between the dates
isn't specified might be specified here, it's
set to 12.
As you can see, set to 12.
So we can go ahead and implement that here,
select that date range picker, paste it, no
option, a snap that in 60 set to 16 dips in
the left and the spacings 12 already by default.
So this is awesome, I can go ahead and just
copy these dates.
And now I have all seven days here specified.
And what I can do is select all these from
the get go my Layers panel, group them, label
them.
Row days, I can label this as row days or
whatever you find most intuitive or most effective.
That's what I recommend.
And then I'm going to ensure it Whoa, that
the spacing here is set appropriately.
And once that is set properly, we are good
to go.
Have those days here.
Road days, left, push that up.
Whoops.
And then I'm gonna organize these in my Layers
panel accordingly, the header right and then
the road days, right.
And then next, we're going to want to just
go ahead and start implementing our our days
here.
And what I'm going to do is just copy this
date number so for the desktop, paste it and
with that, we have it now a line already.
And then we're going to just create these
rows here and there is no spacing between
these cells.
So I can just keep going Hitting Command D
to replicate that.
Then I can group this, label this row three,
row three left, then I can label this, whoops,
I can group this as well, road to left.
And then what I can do is just continue to
duplicate this downward, and just ensure that
these are incrementing properly.
So this is row four.
And then we got row five here in action, and
then we got, we got row six.
So we're gonna go ahead and verify how many
rows are needed here.
For this day, we got, we got five, six, in
total, we got 1234, we need to create one
more row seems like she doesn't seem right,
whoops, I'm checking out the wrong 1234566
in total.
So we have 123456.
And this row, we only got, oh, we only have
one here specified one day on the last row,
and there's a eight dip, eight pixel padding
there on the bottom.
So I need to go ahead and verify that currently,
it's set to four, I don't know why that is.
And then the padding on top set to 16.
And the bottom is set to eight.
And then I have the height set to 280.
But it's still prompting me with dimensions
of four on the bottom, which I don't understand.
So what we can do is go ahead and select our
parent frame and just specify that to eight.
currently set to seven.
So I'll just push that down one more pixel.
And there we have it, we now have that this
variant here made, I'm going to I'm going
to go ahead and pause this and make this other
side and you should do the same.
And I'm just going to name everything accordingly.
positive.
So now I've created these rows here on the
right side.
So I'm going to just allow you to go ahead
and add all the dates and days here so that
it's precise.
And you can align it with what is specified
in the spec here.
And I'm going to challenge you to make this
date desktop date picker by yourself.
And the year selection view, we already have
the elements here ready and named properly
for design system.
And you just need to resize these a year selection
cells.
And one thing you can I'm going to go over
with you but not build out in pilot I'm going
to just guide you is creating this date range
selection.
So what you're going to want to do to represent
that range selection, we're going to I duplicated
this and just removed the the fill and change
this color here on the shape to primary low
emphasis.
And I changed the constraints so that the
constraints of this were on this element,
I need to detach it My bad.
Now I need to select the shape and set the
constraints to left and right.
So that way, when I select the parent container,
I can stretch it out properly.
So I can I can get that range I need.
And under range, I'm going to select deaths,
it's going to be named elements slash desktop
slash range selection.
So that's that now that we have that you can
go ahead and you know, make that a main component,
and you can copy it.
And then how you would use it is if you paste
it into your date range picker, you're going
to want to place it behind all your layers
below and align it with the height and the
size of the your text box.
And then you can go ahead and start stretching
that out as needed to select your dates.
And do note that everything's good to go in
that regard.
And there is a state where it's just one cell
to so that's awesome.
And that is all I have to show you today.
Folks, I challenge you to make this, these
other desktop variants and this mobile variant
and with all that knowledge you should you
have all the cells and everything needed.
In to build the following.
And thank you so much for watching.
And this was a long one, hope you learned
a lot, and how to deconstruct these images
and actually turn this into a system.
I know, it's challenging, but very rewarding
for you.
If you can get this into your muscle memory,
as a designer, you will become a very valuable
design system designer and designer.
Today, we're going to be building out some
dividers very straightforward.
And we're going to cover how they're used,
and then just create them, it'll be super
quick and easy.
The longest part will be just describing the
usage.
So a divider is a thin line that groups content
in lists and layouts.
As you can see, here, we have a bunch of list
components, and they're being divided into
their own rightful sections with this divider,
as you can see, here, we've got that divider
element.
And it talks about the principles behind it.
So it just is utilized to separate content
into clear groups.
And here you can see that it's heavily used
in messaging.
And this inbox, they're using lines to compartmentalize
each message being sent and received.
And here, you can use divider here you see
dividers, splitting the description of this
image and its pricing.
And then also, it's splitting that content
where it's very descriptive above and then
where there's some actions below and splitting
that content.
And here we have a divider being utilized
to split this page of what looks like contacts.
And there's a lot of great in depth context
here, I highly recommend you reading through,
it'll allow you to make more intentional decisions
on your designs moving forward.
And we'll just improve your game as a designer.
And here are some examples of dividers being
used in certain material design themes such
as the theme labeled fortnightly and owl material
theme.
And here you can see what that would look
like a divider would look like on a on this
primary background.
And then also cheers just the specs, which
is now in figma.
We'll go ahead and create that.
So very straightforward.
It's one pixel and height.
And we're just going to set that to the width
of an Android device, which is 30 to 60 dip.
So if I hit l on my keyboard, that creates
the the divider the line, so I'm going to
set the width to 360 and the height to one
pixel.
So now I have Whoa, whoops, I'm going to invert
that.
So the width is 360.
And we now have this line.
But the thing, the problem with this line
is that we need to flatten this.
So when I say flatten, we actually need to
outline the stroke, because we have essentially
a stroke as you can see here.
And when we fly in this row, you'll notice
in the Properties panel, it'll update, and
we'll go to outline stroke, and it will now
become Phil.
And why do we want that wall, I'll have two
examples for us, because it'll help us when
it comes to measuring elements.
Because right now this stroke is centered.
So that blue line is the center of where things
will be measured.
And you'll notice that that's not actually
giving us a proper measurement.
So if we want to separate a group of text
here, and we have this text box specified,
you see how this is 60.
Well, if I have this lined up, so they're
both strokes, if I go ahead and now change
this from stroke, you'll notice the distance
is 60 dips.
But watch, when I change this to a outline,
stroke, I outline the stroke, it'll change
it to a fill.
And then you'll notice that now the distance
is set to 59 pixels.
So the point I'm getting at is to be as precise
as possible with these dividers, we need to
ensure that we are flattening them.
And flattening is just a term for you see
how there's this line here.
And then when I flatten it, it's it's actually
a it's not a stroke anymore, so it's not in
the center of that have the stroke.
So it's now essentially kind of like a one
pixel rectangle that's very thin, you can
think of it as ended up with that being said,
the measurements will be more precise.
And that is exactly what we're trying to achieve.
As opposed to this this stroke word set to
60 in distance and this this flattened stroke
which is no longer stroke is set to 59 so
that is actually more accurate.
So that is great.
We have that there.
And all we need to do is apply the proper
color style and you need to ensure that your
material design system library is enabled
in this file, as always, and we'll go ahead
and select our color styles and go to content
and select the surface over Which is used
for dividers here.
And again, you can see that the color specified
on that divider is set to 00, which is black
and uses the 12% opacity.
So it's very light, and subtle.
And some important things to note is that
other design systems specify several dividers,
which essentially is just utilizing different
color styles.
And with those different color styles, it's
just communicating.
You could communicate different levels of
opacities.
For example, I detach this, say this was the
regular divider set at 12%.
But we had another divider that we wanted
to be more prominent in color, we can actually
bump up that opacity.
Maybe I just bumped that up to 80% 87%.
And if we wanted some sort of, for example,
muted divider, whoops, let's see here, duplicate
that we wanted a muted divider, we could just
change that opacity, again, to represent different
levels of prominence in the divider, and how
you want that to how visible you want that
to be on your designs.
So that's, that's one way of going about building
things.
But in material design, we just have this
one divider, and I'm just gonna label that
as regular that was just an example for you
all, and just reapply that content surface
overlay on surface color style, we now have
our divider and I'm gonna go ahead and label
it dividers space slash space and then divider.
So that is great.
Actually, I can go ahead and just label this
as divider and make that a master component
main component, excuse me, and we are good
to go.
And that is all we have to do to create a
divider and thank you so much for watching.